THE YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU FOR COMING
TO THE JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF THE TWO SELECT
COMMITTEES OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE. I WANT TO WELCOME
THE CO CHAIRS OF THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE DOCTOR PAN AND
CENTER ON BERG AS WELL AS OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE DIFFERENCE
LIKE COMMITTEES THANK YOU ALL
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
200-242-0020 FOUR IS A NUMBER
OF DAYS UNTIL CENSUS DATE APRIL
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY BY THE TIME
THE LEGISLATURE RECONVENES IN
JANUARY THAT NUMBER WILL BE
LESS THAN NINETY AND THE STATE
CENSUS PROGRAM SHOULD HAVE
ENTERED ITS ACTIVE PHASE BY
THEN. OUR OVERALL GOAL REMAINS
TO HELP INSURE THAT THERE IS A
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE COUNT. OF
ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS DURING
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
TODAY'S INFORMATION ON HEARING
WILL FOCUS ON LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE STATE'S MEDIA
OUTREACH AND PUBLIC RELATIONS
CAMPAIGN. FORTY SIX OF FORTY
SIX MILLION A FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OR 25% OF THE STATE'S
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR CENSUS FUNDING
HAS BEEN SET ASIDE FOR THAT
MEDIA CAMPAIGN BUT YOU COULD
ARGUE THAT THAT MONEY IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE 25% OF
REPRESENTS. SO MANY FOLKS HAVE
SPOKEN ALL OF US ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF MEDIA AND A
COORDINATED STRATEGIC. MEDIA
OUR REACH PLAN ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS IS THE FIRST OPPORTUNITY
FOR MOST OF US TO MEET WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
STATE'S RECENTLY CONTRACTED
MEDIA PARTNER MERCURY PUBLIC
AFFAIRS LLC. AND I KNOW THAT
MERCURY'S ONLY BEEN ON THE JOB
FOR A COUPLE OF WEEKS BUT IT
WE'RE GOING TO. SKIP A LOT OF
THE NICETIES IN THE HONEYMOON
PHASE AND THEN DIVE RIGHT INTO
THE GUTS OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
GOT TO DO OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF MONTHS BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU ALL BEING HERE.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
OFFICE WILL ALSO BE
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING. THEY CAN PROVIDE
BACKGROUND ON THE EVOLUTION OF
THE STATE'S MEDIA COMPONENTS.
AND INSIGHTS AS TO THEIR
INTENDED PATH FORWARD. AS A
LEAN INTO THOSE THIS
DISCUSSIONS WE WILL HEAR FROM A
STATE LEADERS SECRETARY OF
STATE PEDIA WHO STEPPED IN TO
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP AND ENERGY
TO CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO
ENSURE A COMPLETE COUNT. WE
WILL ALSO HEAR FROM A SELECTED
PANEL OF EXPERTS WHO WILL SHARE
THEIR EXPERIENCE IN RECENT
RESEARCH ON WHAT IT TAKES TO
EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES. I'D NOW LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY CO CHAIRS
FOR THEIR OPENING REMARKS FIRST
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN UP. THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ENDEAVOR THOSE YOU'VE BEEN HERE
BEFORE BUT HAVE HEARD US TALK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF GETTING
A COMPLETE COUNT IN CALIFORNIA
I WILL CONTINUE TO SORT OF
SOUND THE THEMES THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE WE'RE WE'RE
TAKING A HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S JUST
STATE INVESTMENT WITH COMBINED
LOCAL INVESTMENT HUGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY BEING SPENT ON THIS.
ENTERPRISE IT'S IMPORTANT
VESTMENT BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS INVESTMENT IS
DONE WITH ACCOUNTABILITY AND%
TRANSPARENCY DURING THE BREAK I
SPENT THE FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME
IN THE DISTRICT TALKING TO SOME
OF THE FOLKS IN OUR DISTRICT
TOO ARE RESPONSIBLE AT LEAST IN
ORANGE COUNTY FOR MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO GET A COMPLETE COUNT
SO MY CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ALLAYED SOME OF THEM. HAVE BEEN.
INCREASED OF BECAUSE I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT COMMANDED
CONTROL I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW WE INTEGRATE OUR MESSAGES
SO THAT THAT INTEGRATION IS
DONE WITH CONSISTENCY. AND OF
THE SAME PREVALENCE ALL OVER
THE STATE SO I'M ANXIOUS TO
HEAR ABOUT THE MEDIA PLAN I'M
ANXIOUS TO HEAR HOW WE'RE GOING
TO COORDINATE THAT MEDIA PLAN
WITH ALL THE OTHER. ENTITIES
AND ENTERPRISE AROUND THE STATE
TO OUR ENGAGE IN THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT. THANK YOU LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO A DOCTOR PAN ONE OF
THE OTHER CO CHAIRS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK.
NOW MY CO CHAIR CENTER NUMBER
AGAIN THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE AS WELL. AS
SOME THEIR BERMAN AND ALSO THE
OTHER. COMMITTEE MEMBERS WELL
ON BOTH. SELECT COMMITTEES.
THIS IS. THE CENSUS IS. IS OF
COURSE CRITICAL TO THE FUTURE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WERE THE
TALK ABOUT REPRESENTATION OR
TALK ABOUT FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
EVEN TALK ABOUT HISTORY. AND
TODAY WILL BE I KNOW WE'RE
FOCUSING ON THE MEDIA OUT REACH
PLAN I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE. ALEX O
THE AS- IS LEADING ON THIS IS
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE IN
ADDITION TO AS MANY OTHER TASKS
AND I KNOW HE'LL BE VERY BUSY
BECAUSE WE'LL HAVE A PRIMARY IN
MARCH AND A- CENSUS IN APRIL.
BUT I KNOW THAT HE AND HIS TEAM
IS ARE MORE THAN CAPABLE AND
DOING THIS AND DOING THIS WELL.
WE WANT TO HEAR TODAY ABOUT THE
MEDIA PLAN RIGHT AND MEDIA IS
GOING TO RANGE EVERYTHING FROM
YOU KNOW ACROSS THE STATE TO
INTO INDIVIDUAL NEIGHBORHOODS
AND HOW THAT INTERFACE. HAPPENS
I KNOW THAT THE. THE EFFORT IS
ALSO INCLUDED ENGAGING THROUGH
WHETHER IT'S. REGIONAL
NONPROFITS OR OTHER TYPES NEEDS
TO ENGAGE WITH TRUSTED
MESSENGERS AND WE NEED TO BE
SURE THAT THAT THE STRATEGIES
INTEGRATED WITH OUR MEDIA
STRATEGY. I ALSO CERTAINLY. I
AGREE WITH MY COCHAIRED THAT WE
NEED TO ALSO BE SURE THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT THAT NEEDS
ALSO BE BALANCED WITH BEING
BEING SURE THAT WE GET THE JOB
DONE WE HAVE A DEADLINE. THE
CENSUS WILL HAPPEN IN APRIL
WHETHER WE'RE READY OR NOT AND
THE CONSEQUENCES THAT CENSUS WE
WILL HAVE TO LIVE WITH FOR THE
NEXT DECADE SO IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET A RIGHT THAT'S WHY
HAVING THIS SECOND HEARING ICE
DISSIPATE WILL HAVE PRICE AND
ADDITIONAL HEARINGS BUT SOME
POINT THOUGH WE ALSO. NEED TO
BE SURE THAT THIS ENTERPRISE IS
WELL ON ITS WAY. DOING
OVERSIGHT IN LAST MINUTE IS NOT
GOING TO CHANGE ANYTHING SO
WE'RE LOOKING VERY MUCH FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM. BOTH THE FOLKS
FROM THE- GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
FOR. MANAGING THE CENSUS AND
ALSO FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS ON
THE GROUND. BECAUSE WE NEED TO
KNOW THAT THINGS ARE GOING TO
RIGHT DIRECTION THIS IS THE
TIME NOW WHEN WE CAN MAKE THE
ADJUSTMENTS THE CORRECTIONS.
WE'VE COMMITTED THE RESOURCES
AS THE LEGISLATURE APPRECIATE
THE LEADERSHIP GOVERNOR'S WELL.
AND SO I'M VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING THE
PRESENTATIONS TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN BEFORE WE
GET STARTED ONE WELCOME ANY
REMARKS FROM SENATOR OSEM OR
ANYBODY ELSE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO. OUR CULTURES.
OUT WITH MY COLLEAGUES SENATOR
UMBERG AND MYSELF ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WORKED REALLY
HARD. ON THIS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE. ALL OF THE-
STAKEHOLDERS THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. EVERYONE WHO
CAME FORWARD OVER SEVERAL. ARE
HEARINGS THAT WE HAD AND
MEETINGS THAT WE HAD. TO BRING
FORTH ALL OF THE ISSUES AND WE
TRY REALLY HARD. NOT ONLY TO
GET MORE MONEY WHICH WE'RE ABLE
TO. TO GET BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
IS WHAT IS GOING ON OUT THERE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT. WE
DON'T. NECESSARILY HEAR ABOUT
EVERY DAY. BUT HE WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY. THE REALLY REALLY
HARD TO COUNT. PARTS OF THE
STATE AND WHAT THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE SO I'M
REALLY EXCITED I'M REALLY
PROUD. AND ESPECIALLY I
UNDERSTAND ON THE AGENDA IS
THIS GUY. THAT I'VE HEARD ABOUT.
OF USED TO BE SOMEBODY CAN YOU
SPELL HE USED TO BE AND I
ALWAYS USE THIS TO BE SOMEBODY
AGAIN. NO BUT I'M I'M REALLY.
GLAD TO HEAR THE THAT. OF FOR
THE ENDING IS HERE BUT ALSO
FROM EVERYBODY ELSE SO. I'M
REALLY EXCITED AND I KNOW WITH
MY COLLEAGUES WILL WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE THE BEST EVER BEST EVER
NOT JUST WITH MONEY BUT THE
BEST EVER PROGRAM SO I'VE GOT A
FEW QUESTIONS WE SHOULD GET
GOING. THANK YOU SENATOR US
WERE VERY PLEASED TO WELCOME
SECRETARY OF STATE EXPEDIA TO
THE HEARING TODAY IN ADDITION
HIS RESPONSIBILITIES AS
SECRETARY OF STATE. SECRETARY
PO WAS RECENTLY APPOINTED AS
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HE'S ATTENDED
MANY OF THE COMMUNITY PLANNING
MEETINGS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
STAYING ENGAGING WITH
PARTICIPANTS AND LISTENING TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE PLANNING TO ENSURE
COMPLETE COUNT IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES A SATURDAY PRETTY A
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AS CHAIRMAN BOTH CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE USER. FIVE AND
HOW DO WE TEND THESE WORKSHOPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE ARE
TAKE SELF HE'S WITH US OF THE
LOCAL LEGISLATORS THE MOST
IMPORTANT FOR THEIR SOCIAL
MEDIA CAN. SO LET ME COVER I
THINK A COUPLE OF A IMPORTANT
TOPICS FROM THE FORTY THOUSAND
FOOT LEVEL AND AN ENTERTAINING
SEVERAL QUESTIONS IF ANYBODY
NAY HAVE A LONG AGENDA IN FRONT
OF YOU. IN A REFERENCE A COUPLE
TIMES ALREADY MY RECENT
APPOINTMENT AS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE CAL
COMMITTEE. SO COMING ON THAT
FIRST THAT MOVED IN AND OF
ITSELF. IS UNPRECEDENTED RIGHT
IN TEN YEARS AGO TWENTY YEARS
AGO WE'VE HAD A CALIFORNIA HAS
HAD COMPLETE HOW COMMITTEES IN
THE PAST MORE OFTEN THAN NOT TO
WORRY BUT THE MEMBERS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CABINET THAT HAS
OVERSEEN THE EFFORTS IMPORTANT
EFFORTS BUT WHEN I GOT A CALL
FROM GOVERNOR NEW SOME EARLIER
THIS YEAR TO TAKE ON THIS
CHARGE WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
BUDGET INCREASE TO MY AGENCY
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL STAFF. AND
WITH THE BLESSING OF MY WIFE IS
BECAUSE HE KNEW HELP PORTENT IT
WAS A BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENTS THREAT THIS
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR FIGURE IS EXPONENTIALLY
LARGER THAT MOLD HAS BEEN
INVESTED IN DECADES PAST AND SO
I THINK ONLY RIGHTFULLY SO
ELEVATE THE LEVEL OF LEADERSHIP
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE AND ELEVATE THE
LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT AND
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIPS.
BECAUSE IT'S GONNA TAKE AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK APPROACH. TO MAKE
SURE WE COUNT EVERY CALIFORNIAN
IN TWENTY TWENTY. I THINK FOR
CONTEXT OF WE KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT ANY SENTENCES FOR
EVERY TEN YEARS COUNTING EVERY
PERSON THE COUNTRY AND-
CALIFORNIA CLEARLY AS THE MOST
POPULOUS AND MOST DIVERSE STATE
IN THE NATION. IT'S A HARD
ENOUGH TASK THAT'S WHY THERE'S
THAT FORMAL CRITERIA OF A HEART
TO COUNT. COMMUNITY POPULATIONS
THAT ARE THE TAKE EXTRA EFFORT
TO MAKE SURE THESE STATEMENTS
SENSES BECAUSE OF. ECONOMIC
LEVELS IN IN THEIR AREAS
BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AGE GROUPS IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AT CETERA. LET'S BE
CLEAR MORE THAN 70% OF
CALIFORNIANS A. FIT SOME SORT
OF HARD TO COUNT CRITERIA SO
THE CHALLENGE EVERY TEN YEARS
IS TOUGH ENOUGH ON THE NATURAL
ADD TO THAT THE COUPLE OF THE
UNIQUE ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES
GOING INTO TWENTY TWENTY.
WHETHER IT'S FUNDAMENTAL
CONFIDENCE OR LACK THEREOF IN
NOW. WHETHER IT'S TRYING TO
MAKE UP FOR EASIER IS OF UNDER
FUNDING UNDER STAFFING OF THE
US CENSUS BUREAU. WHETHER IT IS.
THE FACT THAT TWENTY TWENTY
WILL BE THE FIRST DIGITAL FIRST
SENTENCE THERE WILL BE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTICIPATE IN
ON PAPER EVENTUALLY BY PHONE IT
CETERA BUT THE FIRST NOTICE
MOST BOB HOUSEHOLDS WILL
RECEIVE. THE POSTCARD HOW TO GO
ONLINE TO SUBMIT YOUR
INFORMATION BUT THEY'RE STILL A
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN AMERICA AND
CALIFORNIA IS NO EXCEPTION. OR
ISSUES OF IT HERE'S ANOTHER
CHALLENGE YOU KNOW POTENTIAL OF
CYBER SECURITY CONCERNS
MISINFORMATION DISINFORMATION
CONCERNS. SO TAKE A LOT OF THE
IMPORTANT LESSONS WE LEARNED IN
ELECTIONS SPACE. ON QUALITY
INFORMATION PROACTIVELY AND IN
RESPONSE. AND APPLYING IT NOW
TO THE SENSES WE'VE TAKEN A LOT
OF WHAT WE LEARNED IN SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE FROM.
OUTREACH TO PROMOTE NON
PARTISAN VOTER REGISTRATION AND
TURN OUT AND APPLYING IT TO
SENTENCE OUTREACH AND WE DO SO
HAPPILY BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
STAKES AGAIN WITHOUT GETTING
INTO DETAIL THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS ALL TOO WELL. THE LEVEL
OF FEDERAL FUNDING THAT TOUCH
STICK IF THERE IS AN UNDERCOUNT
IN CALIFORNIA NEXT YEAR THE
LEVEL OF POLITICAL
REPRESENTATION FOR CALIFORNIA
IN THE HALLS OF CONGRESS.
BECAUSE CENSUS DATA DRIVES THE
REAPPORTIONMENT PROCESS BY
EXTENSION BY THE WAY WE KNOW
THE DEADLINE WAS EXTENDED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION. THE REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION RELIES ON CENSUS
DATA TO DROP THEIR DISTRICTS.
WHAT THE CENSUS IS DONE SO
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY
THE CENSUS DATA IN A FAIR AND
ACCURATE COUNT. IS IMPORTANT.
THE RAP THAT ALL UP TOGETHER
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO DO OUR PART
OF IT NOT NOT TO LEAVE FRANKLY
FRANKLY THE QUARTERBACK RECORDS
YOU CAN TAKE ALL OF US ON THE
FIELD. TO GET THE JOB DONE.
WHAT EXAMPLE THAT I'VE SHARED A
WITH A LOT OF FOLKS HIS RULES
WORK AND THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO YES WE HAVE SOME OUT REACH
CAPACITY AND IN EXPERIENCE. BUT
WITH THE EARLY PRIMARY NEXT
YEAR. RIGHT OUR PRIMARIES IN
MARCH NOT IN JUNE. SO PROVIDE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS REMIND
YOURSELVES. THAT MEANS THE
VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE IS
GOING OUT IN FEBRUARY. RIGHT SO
IT'S NOT ON THE EVE OF THE
SENTENCE IN APRIL BUT IT'S ON A
TIMELY BASIS. AND SOBRE
COMMITTING CENSUS INFORMATION
TO BE PROMINENTLY DISPLAYED IN
THE VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE. TO
EVERY HOUSEHOLD IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WILL RECEIVE NOT QUITE
TWENTY MILLION. BUT A BIG
NUMBER AND DEATH TO EVERY
HOUSEHOLDBUT WITH
APPROXIMATELY FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT'S A PRETTY
GOOD PENETRATION. RIGHT A WE
DEVELOP THE CAPACITY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE TO
EMAIL DIRECTLY TO VOTERS THAT
OF SUBMITTED AN EMAIL ADDRESS
TO US. SO WERE HOPEFULLY
APPROACHING ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION EMAIL ADDRESSES BY NEXT
MARCH PRIMARY GET THE TOP EVERY
CALIFORNIA BUT THAT'S A PRETTY
GOOD PENETRATION. THEY OFFER
THOSE EXAMPLES OF JUST WHAT
WE'RE DOING. IMAGINE EXTENDING
THE EXERCISE AND THE CHALLENGE
EVERY STATE DEPARTMENT AND
AGENCY WHAT CAN YOU DO TO HELP
GET THE WORD OUT TO EVERY
LEGISLATOR EVERY CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER BUT CAN YOU DO TO GET
THE WORD OUT. BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT STATE GOVERNMENT CAN'T DO
IT ALONE. RIGHT SO IF WE ASK
THE SAME QUESTION OF EVERY
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA OF EVERY
CITY IN CALIFORNIA OF EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA.
WE CAN GET THE MESSAGE OUT
EFFECTIVELY INVESTORS
GOVERNMENTS RIGHT I THINK
THROUGH THE COMPLETE CAL
COMMITTEE AND THE ECB OWES THE
CBO'S UNDER THEM THE
RELATIONSHIP TO THE NETWORKS
WERE ALSO ENGAGING COMMUNITY
GROUPS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THE FOUNDATION WORLD LABOR
UNIONS THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY
RIGHT THE PRIVATE SECTOR HAS A
BIG STAKE. IN ALL THIS IS WELL
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
CAN DO TO SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
NEED TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE INFORMATION IS EFFECTIVELY
GETTING TO ALL CALIFORNIANS AS
POSSIBLE AND THAT'S WHAT WE SEE
THAT YOU MADE REFERENCE TODAY
I'VE VISITED A HANDFUL AND
THERE'S STILL SOME ARCTIC TO
GO. OF THESE WORKSHOPS IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
AND WHAT IS CAMPAIGNING SARS
FRANKLY THE STAKEHOLDERS OF
COMMUNITY BY READING COMING
TOGETHER. TO COMMIT TO WORK
TOGETHER A TO SHARE IDEAS AND
PAST EXPERIENCE IN THAT'S GREAT
THAT'S EXACTLY LEVELS OF
COLLABORATION THAT WE NEED NOW
WE TAKE THAT BOOK BOTTOM UP AND
TOP. TEN RIGHT BECAUSE IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S
WORKING GREAT AND SANDY WILL
COUNTY. THAT MAYBE CAN INFORM
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. RIGHT WHAT
ARE THE MECHANISMS FOR THE
INFORMATION TO BE SHARING
TRANSLATED MATERIALS TO BE
SHARED YOU KNOW ALL OF THE
ABOVE AND VICE VERSA. AND IT
WITH A FOCUS ON THE
COMMUNICATIONS CONTRACTED
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN OF WOULD
HAVE A LOT OF THE GROUND
ACTIVITY GOING ON THAT'S ALL
GOING TO BE SUPPORT THE
FOUNDATION WILL REALLY BE LATE
WITH THE STATE WIDE BOTH EARNED
MEDIA PAID MEDIA AS WELL AS
SOCIAL MEDIA STRATEGY THAT'S
COMING TOGETHER TO REINFORCE IT
ALL GIVE IT A CRISP CONCISE
EFFECTIVE MESSAGING WITH.
INDIVIDUALS AND EVERYTHING ELSE
IN BETWEEN SO I HAVE SOME GOOD
NEWS. AND SOME BAD NEWS. THE
BAD NEWS IS WE'RE ALL ABOUT
SEVEN MONTHS OUT. THE GOOD NEWS
IS. FOR ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS OUT
RIGHT THE CENSUS DOES NOT START
TOMORROW SO I GIVE A LOT OF
KUDOS IN CREDIT TO ADIDAS AND
THE ENTIRE COOK CALVET COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE TEAM FOR
GETTING US TO THIS POINT RIGHT
THE EARLY PHASES OF THIS OF
HIRING UP OF STAFFING OUT OF
OUT REACHING IN GETTING
CONTRACTS IN PLACE ALL THAT
STUFF. WAS LABORIOUS BUT IT'S
DONE AND WERE QUICKLY ENTERING
THE PHASE WHERE WE ARE ENGAGING
AND WE ARE OUT REACHING AMBER
ORGANIZING AND WERE MOBILIZING.
WHEN I SAY IT'S GOING TO BE AN
ALL HANDS ON DECK IS NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF ALL THE PARTNERS
THEY NEED TO DO THEIR PART. BUT
THAT WE LITERALLY TOUCHED ALL
CORNERS OF CALIFORNIA. IN ALL
LANGUAGES OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE
OVERALL STRATEGIES REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF THIS GOLDEN STATE
INTO. YOU KNOW ALL THE ALL IN
WITH THIS OF MY SAID SEVEN
MONTHS OUT THE MEANS WE STILL
HAVE SOME TIME TO GET THIS
TOGETHER. JUST TYPE IN THE
ELECTIONS WORLD BY THE VOTERS
DON'T REALLY START PAYING
ATTENTION TO WHAT TIME ABOUT
WHO'S ON THE BALLOT UNTIL THE
LAST COUPLE MONTHS THAT'S WHY
CANDIDATES DON'T SAVE THEIR-
MAILERS IN COMMERCIALS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. UNTIL CLOSER
TO ELECTION DAY. AT THE WAS TO
HAVE THAT WINDOW IN CALIFORNIA
AS A PERTAINS TO THE SENSES WE
ALL GET IT BECAUSE WE DO WHAT
WE DO. BUT THE GENERAL PUBLIC
NEXT APRIL RIGHT THERE THEY'RE
JUST LOOKING AT HOW TO PAY THE
RENT NEXT MONTH. AND SO WE
STILL HAVE A CHANCE TO GET THE
RIGHT POSITIVE. UP MESSAGING IN
FRONT OF MOST PEOPLE IN TIME
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY SENT TO
SEND TWENTY TWENTY IS GOING TO
BE A BIG YEAR. RIGHT WE KNOW
EVERYBODY'S PAYING ATTENTION TO
POLITICS RIGHT NOW. WE SEE A
CABLE NEWS EVERY NIGHT. I CAN
ASSURE YOU WE SEE IT OF THE
VOTER REGISTRATION NUMBERS
EVERY WEEK. I EXPECT RECORD
REGISTRATION RECORD TURNED OUT
NOT JUST NEXT NOVEMBER. BUT
NEXT MARCH AS WELL. AND WORK
SMALL IN A SMART FASHION
INSTITUTE AGREE WE CAN CHANNEL.
THAT AWARENESS. AND ENERGY AN
ENGAGEMENT AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE APPLY TO THE CENSUS. IS WELL
SO THAT'S THE TASK BEFORE US WE
HAVE A LOT OF GREAT PARTNERS
CONSTRUCTION PLACE. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
SIR DEPUTY WANT TO. OPEN UP TO
COLLEAGUES. I'M GONNA GO TO MY
ASSEMBLY CALLING. MISTER JONES
SAWYER AND THEN BRING IT BACK
TO THEM I CO CHAIRS. PLEASE DO
TO CULTURES ARE ALL MESSED UP
WITH THE- WHAT TIME FOR
EVERYBODY OKAY WE ONLY WE ONLY
HAVE THE SCRIPTED FROM FOR THE
FACT THAT I THAT I SO NOW IS
WIDE OPEN ALL RIGHT IN THANK
YOU SECRETARY PRETTY UNKNOWN
I'M GLAD TO HEAR HIS. BECAUSE
MY QUESTION IS ONE THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE PROBABLY THE ONLY PERSON.
THAT NOT ONLY CAN HANDLE IT BUT
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE
IT. BOB WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
FOR ME BOB LET ME JUST SAY FULL
DISCLOSURE I'M A CONSPIRACY
THERE. AND I BELIEVE THERE ARE
THERE ARE THERE ELEMENTS THREE
THOUSAND MILES AWAY THAT WANT
TO UNDERMINE BOTH THE VOTE. AND
THE CENSUS AND WHEN I DROVE
AROUND IN MY DISTRICT THE WEEK
BEFORE THERE WERE TALKS OF
HAVING SWEEPS. AND A WEEK AFTER
THE WEEK OF THAT WE CAN UP THE
SWEEPS. I SAW A LARGE NUMBER OF
LATINOS AND AFTER AMERICANS IN
MY DISTRICT NOT GO TO PICNICS
NOT GO TO THE MOVIES NOT GO TO
RESTAURANTS. FEAR NOT GOING TO
CHURCH FEAR IS A POWERFUL THING
AND IF YOU'RE AFRAID YOU'LL BE
SEPARATED FROM YOUR FAMILY YOU
FEAR THAT YOU MAY BE LOCKED UP
YOU FEAR THAT YOU MAY BE
DEPORTED. THAT COULD HAVE A
DRAMATIC IMPACT PACKED ON A
WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND I DON'T
KNOW IF WE THOUGHT THROUGH. A
CONTINGENCY PLAN BECAUSE I IT.
EXPECT SOMEONE. FROM THE EAST
MAY SAY SOMETHING OR START TO
DO THINGS THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
TRY TO UNDERMINE OUR COUNTY
CALIFORNIA IN A VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT WAY AND DO WE HAVE
HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT OF
CONTINGENCY PLANS TO KIND OF
OFFSET THAT ANOTHER PART OF THE
MEDIA STRATEGY BUT I WILL TELL
YOU FEAR THE FEAR TO LIGHT WITH
MY CONSTITUENTS WHEN I SAT AND
TALKED TO THEM. ABOUT JUST BE
JUST GOING TO A MOVIE OF GOING
TO A WEDDING. AND WHY THEY
DIDN'T GO IS VERY REAL. AND
THAT'S IT IS NOT JUST A MOVIE
STATUS TO WEDDING. COULD BE A
TO SCHOOL SHOP SO I GET IT I
GET IT UP YES YOUR YOUR CONCERN
IS NOT LOST ON ME IN A FIGURES
SOME ENCOURAGING NEWS. UNLIKE
ELECTION DAY. SENT THIS ISN'T
DONE IN JUST ONE DAY. WE HAVE
APRIL FIRST DESIGNATED AS SORT
OF SENSES DAY BUT THAT'S MORE
FOR OUR OF VISIBILITY PUBLIC
EDUCATION RALLYING POINT OF
PERSPECTIVE OF THE GENERAL
COUNTER FOR THE SENSES IS THIS
IN ITS PREFACE BY LOOK WE WILL
WILL GO TO THE POLLS OR MAKE
TROUBLE BY MAIL BALLOT HAS BEEN
MAILED BY MARCH THIRD. OF
TWENTY TWENTY. MARCH TWELFTH
NINE DAYS LATER IS WHEN
POSTCARDS BEGIN TO GO OUT.
INFORMING PEOPLE HOW TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT SENSE RIGHT
SO PEOPLE SHOULD EXPECT TO
START RECEIVING THEM STARTING
ON MARCH FIFTEENTH. APRIL FIRST
IS BIG SENSES DAY RIGHT IT'S
SORT OF A PRIME TIME IT WAS
GETTING THIS NEWS HERE'S HOW.
YOU CAN BEGIN TO A OF SUBMIT
YOUR INFORMATION. BUT IT WILL
CONTINUE THROUGH APRIL AND INTO
MAY OF THE CENSUS BUREAU WILL
MAKE REPEATED ATTEMPTS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EVERY
HOUSEHOLD ALREADY BEEN RESPOND
TO THE FIRST POST CARD WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ARE GONNA SEND YOU
ANOTHER ONE IF YOU DIDN'T
RESPOND TO THE FIRST COUPLE OF
ATTEMPTS TO GO AND SUBMIT YOUR
INFORMATION DIGITALLY EVENT
WILL GET A FORM IN THE MAIL
BOX. YOU ALSO GET INFORMATION
HOW TO PARTICIPATE BY PHONE.
AND ONCE THOSE FIRST COUPLE
MONTHS ARE THROUGH THE CENSUS
BUREAU WILL HAVE THIS
INFORMATION OF WHICH AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA. DOWN TO THE CENSUS
TRACK LEVEL HAVE HIGHER RATES
OF RESPONSE TO PARTICIPATION
VERSUS WHICH ONES ARE LOWERED.
AND IT'S NOT JUST RESPONDED OR
NOT RESPONDED BUT LEVELS OF
RESPONSE TO AND THAT INFORMS
WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE NON
RESPONSE FOLLOW UP. RIGHT
PORTION OF THE SENSES SO IF
FOLKS HAVE RESPONDED BY THEN.
YOU KNOW THEN WE CAN ANTICIPATE
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH BUT ALSO
THE KNOCKS ON THE DOOR FROM THE
ENUMERATORS BETTER OUT THERE
AND I THINK A LOT OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OF PARTNERS HAPPENING. AT THE
GRASSROOTS LEVEL DROUGHT THE
STATE THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE.
THEY'RE DOING THAT INFORMATION
SHARING WELL TO GET YOU TO
COMMUNICATE TO DID AVERAGE
CONTINUE TO ASSIST. OF. SO I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN YOU HAVE
ABOUT. FORCES FROM THREE
THOUSAND MILES AWAY OR FRANKLY
ANYWHERE IN BETWEEN BUT AGAIN
THE GOOD NEWS IS NOT GOING TO
BE YOU KNOW ONE AND DONE ON
APRIL FIRST IT'S GOING TO BE
OVER THE COURSE OF SEVERAL
MONTHS AND SO MAYBE THE THREATS
WILL BE SUSTAINED THIS
INFORMATION COULD BE SUSTAINED
BUT SOBRE ALL EFFORTS TO ENGAGE
AND INFORM. ANOTHER PARTY
IMPORTANT MESSAGING AND I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT TO THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WHETHER IT'S
ON THE- MISINFORMATION SIDE OR-
ON THE VERY REAL CONCERN ABOUT
HOW CAN THE INFORMATION I
SUBMIT TO THE SENSES BE USE.
POTENTIALLY AGAINST ME OR MY
FAMILY OR MY COMMUNITY. FEDERAL
LAW IS CLEAR THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION WE SUBMIT TO THE
SENSES CANNOT BE SHARED WITH
OTHER DEPARTMENTS OR AGENCIES
FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSE. AND
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA LEADERS AND
OTHERS CAME TOGETHER TO FIGHT
AGAINST THE ADDITION OF THIS
PROPOSED CITIZENSHIP QUESTION.
CALIFORNIA LEADERS WILL STAND
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THE PRIVACY
AND CONFIDENTIALITY. OF
CALIFORNIANS INFORMATION
SUBMITTED THROUGH THE SENSES
WHETHER IT'S TO DO POLITICAL
PRESSURE LEGISLATIVE PRESSURE.
OR LEGAL PRESSURE BUT THAT'S
OUR COMMITMENT. INTO REAL QUICK
I NEED A LIAISON BECAUSE EVERY
TIME LOOK AT I'VE BEEN TELLING
PEOPLE TO GET SOUTH LOS ANGELES
WE CAN'T. DO THING TO SAME WAY
BE DONE OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
EXPECTING DIFFERENT RESULTS AND
I'VE PROPOSED DIFFERENT WAYS TO
GO OUT EVEN USING YOUNG PEOPLE
IS VALID. TO GET PEOPLE TO DO
THE CENSUS ON ON TIER BASIS AND
ACTIVATE A WHOLE GENERATION OF
FOLK. AND WHENEVER I ASK FOR
RESOURCES BICYCLING ENEMA. BUT
I KNOW IT IS A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS MONEY HERE AND ARE WE
DON'T PAY FOR THAT IS LIKE. THE
MOST FRUSTRATING THING. CAN
IMAGINE AND THEY'VE ALSO HEARD
ME TALK ABOUT JUST HAVING A
BIG. RALLY OF I CALL IT. YOU
KNOW BARBECUE BURRITOS AND
BEARD WHEN WE ALL GET.
EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND YOU KNOW
OUR COMMUNITIES FOOD AND DRINK
AND WE ALL COME TOGETHER FORGET
THE MUSIC ENOUGH YET TO MUSIC.
AND NOW YOU HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH
OF PEOPLE TOGETHER TO DO THAT
BUT I'M NOT GETTING ANY. THE
I'M AT OTHER MEET OTHER THAN ME
BLOWING UP YOUR FONG. WHAT CAN
I DO TO GET PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT YES IT DOESN'T
FIT INTO THIS CATEGORY BUT IT
WILL WORK. AND I'LL GET YOU
MORE IMPACT THAN THE
TRADITIONAL WAY OF DOING
THINGS. SO CONSIDERABLE UP BY
PHONE. BUT ALSO WILL
COMMUNICATE BEER STAFF TO
ENGAGE YOU IN THE UPCOMING
WORKSHOPS. IN LOS ANGELES AND
IN VARIOUS PARTS OF LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE CAN
MEETINGS ARE OF. THE FORMAL
CONTRACTORS THAT ARE IN PLACE
ARE READY FOR THE REGION FOR
THE COMMUNITY AND THOSE WHO
WANT TO BE A PART OF TWO
DIFFERENT POOLS OF RESOURCES
THE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION STATEWIDE THAT WE WERE
FROM TEXAS THE STATE PARK.
RIGHT THE CENSUS BUREAU ITSELF
WILL HAVE SOME RESOURCES.
AVAILABLE FOR OUT REGION
AWARENESS FOUNDATION TO PUT
MONEY ON THE TABLE LOCAL CITIES
AND COUNTIES AND EVEN SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT MONEY ON
THE TABLE SO IT'S A MATTER OF
WHICH POTS OF FUNDING ARE OUT
THERE BECAUSE NOT ONE SINGLE
POT WERE TALL. CENTRALIZED ANNA
AND WHO'S DOING WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING. THANK YOU TO FIRST
PERSON THAT SAID THEY WERE.
WILLING TO HELP THAT'S ALL I'M
TRYING TO TELL YOU. OKAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU
THE US SECRETARY PADILLA LET ME
ECHO THE- SENTIMENTS OF. SOME
MEMBER REGGIE JONES SAWYER THAT.
WE ARE FORTUNATE THAT YOU'RE
LEADING THIS EFFORT WERE IN
THIS WEIRD POSITION WHERE
PROBABLY THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS ANTAGONISTIC TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITH RESPECT TO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ENTERPRISE. IS
YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S CUT RESOURCES 50%
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND TEN AND
WE'RE EVEN IN A WEIRD POSITION
BECAUSE AS YOU MENTIONED WE
ACTUALLY HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
INFORMATION THAT IS GATHERED IN
GAME IN THE COURSE OF THE
SENSES. IRRESPECTIVE OF YOUR
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS NOT GONNA
BE SHARED WITH OTHER ENTITIES
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT BUT IT IS
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IF
YOU ARE. FOR EXAMPLE JUST TO
PICK AN EXAMPLE PRESIDENT I'D
STATES AND YOU WANT UNDER
COUNTING CALIFORNIA IT'S IN
YOUR INTEREST TO ACTUALLY
CREATE THIS SITUATION WHERE YOU
ARE SPREADING MISINFORMATION WE
HOPE IS MISINFORMATION THAT THE
INFORMATION WILL NOT BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL. IN SEOUL Là
DRAWING ON MY PAST EXPERIENCE
THAT THE BEST WAY TO.
ANTICIPATE ARREST
MISINFORMATION IS TO INOCULATE
OURSELVES BY. AS PART OF THE
CAMPAIGN LETTING PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
MISINFORMATION AND THAT THAT
JUST AS WE ANTICIPATE THIS
MISINFORMATION WILL COME BUT IT
IT WILL BE AN ACCURATE BUT
THAT'S DRAWING ON LIMITED
EXPERIENCE I LOOK FORWARD TO
OTHERS WHO ARE GONNA TESTIFY
LATER ON IN THE COURSE OF. UR
OVERSIGHT OF THE OF COMPLETE
COUNT IS THE HOW WE'RE GOING TO
I HOPE GET IN FRONT OF THIS
MISINFORMATION BECAUSE I'M
FAIRLY CONFIDENT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THIS INFORMATION. SO IT'S
AN ALL OF OUR HANDS BUT YOU'RE
YOU'RE LEADING THE EFFORT
MISTER SECRETARY SO HOW DOES
THE OUR OFFER THIS TO PARK
COMMENT ONE AGAIN HAVE A LETTER
FROM THE ELECTIONS EXPERIENCE
THERE'S THE MISINFORMATION OR
DISINFORMATION TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS. UP OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS IT CETERA SO USING
THE SAME RELATIONSHIPS. AND
PROTOCOLS TO REPORT WRONG
INFORMATION. TO BE REVIEWED
ADDRESS BY THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS THEMSELVES WERE
BUILDING TO APPLY FOR CENSUS
CONTENT THAT WE COME ACROSS.
SEPARATELY HER NOT COMPLETE
SEPARATELY BUT IN A TO THE
ELECTIONS EXPRESS TO DEVELOP
PROTOCOLS AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OTHER STATE DEPARTMENT OF
AGENTS AND AGENCIES THE
NATIONAL GUARD TEACH P.
EMERGENCY SERVICES THE TETRA
BUT ALSO FEDERAL. FBI HOW MUCH
SECURITY IN OTHERS AS THEY
MONITOR. NOT JUST THE WEB AT
THE BAR DARK WEB CHATTER AND
CAN IDENTIFY SOME OF THE STUFF
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
DOES SEEM TOOLS. ARE BEING
APPLIED TO EITHER PREEMPTING OR
RESPONDING TO A CYBER THREATS
OR DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN
DOESN'T PERTAIN TO THE SENSE
SO. THAT THAT IS A- DEFINITELY
ON OUR RADAR ONE JUST ADD ONE
MORE THING TO A- A SOBRE JONES
SAWYER IS COMMENTS. CAUSES
ANOTHER PERIL TO ELECTIONS YOUR
TO GREG AND THE RIGHT TO VOTE
ACROSS AMERICA YEAH. RIGHT AND
REMINDING PEOPLE IF. IF YOUR
BEING ABLE TO VOTE WAS BAD
IMPORTANT. WHY THEY TRY TO TAKE
IT AWAY FROM YOU. CORRECT SO IF
YOU PARTICIPATING IN THE CENSUS
WAS NOT THAT IMPORTANT. BY THE
TRYING TO MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
YOU WHETHER TRYING TO SCARE YOU
FROM DOING IT SO THAT. AND IN
MANY INSTANCES CONSERVE AS A
MOTIVE A TOUR FOR PARKS. THANK
YOU SENATOR ARE THE. JUST ALONG
THOSE LINES I THINK YOU'RE THE
PERFECT PERSON TO LEAD THIS FOR
A NUMBER OF REASONS ONE IS YOU
HAVE OF A BROAD COMPLETE VISION
AS TO WHAT YOU JUST MENTIONED.
THE CIVIC. RIGHTS OF ALL
PEOPLES IN THIS IN THIS STATE
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS. NOT
NECESSARILY RIGHT NOW BUT HOW
YOU CAN GIVE THAT BROADER VIEW
WHICH IS A POSITIVE VIEW
ENVISION FOR EVERY CALIFORNIAN
TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
SPECIFICALLY. AND SORT OF FLIP
OF. INSTEAD OF JUST BEING ON
THE DEFENSIVE WHICH WE HAVE TO
DO ON THESE THREATS AND- AND
THIS NEGATIVITY AND HOSTILITY
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW DO YOU
FLIP IT AND MAKE IT SOMETHING
THAT WORKS FOR US. THIS GOES
BACK TO PROP ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
WE MADE A WORK FOR US. IN SPITE
OF THESE THIS ATTACK SO. EITHER
TODAY OR ANY OTHER TIME I LOOK
TO YOU TO GIVE THAT KIND OF
VISION AS WELL TO WHETHER IT'S
THE MEDIA OR ON THE GROUND
CAMPAIGN THAT YOU KNOW WE LEAD
PEOPLE WITH A POSITIVE. WHAT
THE POSITIVE OUTCOMES NOT JUST
MORE DOLLARS BUT OUR VIEW OF
EVERYBODY'S RIGHT TO YOU LED
THE CHARGE ON VOTER
REGISTRATION AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS SOMEHOW TO
MAKE IT. CONNECT WITH THAT AND
NOT JUST SOME ISOLATED THING
THAT'S OVER HERE. SIR I HAVE
SOME IDEAS AND SOME EXPERIENCE
TO BRING TO THE TABLE BUT WOULD
LIKE TO BE UP EXPERTS WORKING
FOR FORMER SPEAKER NUNEZ TO.
MERCURY AS PART OF THEIR
CONTRACT TO HELP DIGEST ALL
THIS STUFF AND CREATE THOSE
ACTUAL MESSAGES AND PLATFORM
FOR DELIVERING THAT MESSAGE.
THIRTY PM. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
THANK YOU SECRETARY FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. I DID ONE JUST ASK
IN TERMS OF COMMITTEE AND WILL
DRAW MORE INTO IT WHEN WE HAVE
THE SPECIFIC. PEOPLE COMING
SAID ABOUT THIS BUT CERTAINLY
IS OUR SECRETARY STATE NO
TIMING WISE WE HAVE PRIMARY
ELECTION FOLLOWED BY. US THE
CENSUS. YOU MADE REFERENCE TO
YOUR DOCTOR REMARKS THAT IN
SOME SENSES PEOPLE MAY NOT AS A
PAY ATTENTION TOLD CLOSER BUT
IF I PARDON ME IF I COULD USE
THE PHRASE WE NEED TO INOCULATE
PEOPLE FROM THIS NFORMATION
THAT MAY SO IT MAY BE SOME.
PREVIOUS WORK. SO I GUESS IN
TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
RAMP UP THE CENSUS WITH THE
FACT THAT THE PRIMARIES
HAPPENING SHORTLY BEFORE. AS
THE COMMITTEE BEEN LOOKING AT
FOR EXAMPLE LET'S A PURCHASING
IF YOU HAVE TO PURCHASE MEDIA
TIME RIGHT IF YOU HAVE A BUNCH
OF CAMPAIGNS PURCHASING MEDIA
TIME. THAT'S GOING TO JACK UP
THE RATES MAKE IT MORE
EXPENSIVE OR NOT CAN BE USES
MUCH. SO THINKING STRATEGICALLY
ABOUT HOW THIS INTERFACE
BETWEEN. PRIMARY AND CENSUS
THERE SOMETHING WE CAN LEVERAGE
AN ADVANTAGE I THINK YOU MADE
REFERENCE TO SOME OF THAT BUT-
I ALSO MADE CREATE SOME
CHALLENGES. THERE MAY BE. THIS
INFORMATION ARE ARE THINGS THAT
MAY BE USED. IN A CAMPAIGN THAT
MAY ACTUALLY HAVE AN- IMPACT ON
THE SENSES BECAUSE IT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE GOT SCARED SOMEONE YOU
SOME SORT OF TACTIC OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. NOW WE'LL
SEE WHETHER TRUMP'S ON THE
BALLOT OR NOT. BUT SO I GUESS
MAYBE CAN SPEAK TO HOW YOU SEE
THAT INTERFACE PERFECTLY WHAT
STRATEGIES TO COMPETE COUNT
COMMITTEES USING. TO BOTH
INOCULATE MISS AGAINST
MISINFORMATION BUT ALSO THE
THAT LEAD UP WITH THE FACT THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO BE RUNNING
INTO. THE PRIMARY AND ALL THE
MEDIA SO SEE WITH THAT. ON THE
WAY TO THE CENSUS ITSELF BEING
APRIL AS YOU SAID IT IS OF NO
MORE A MONTH LONG PLUS PROCESS
SO IT'S NOT LIKE ON APRIL FIRST
AT ONCE. TURNING IN THEIR
CENSUS FORM BUT CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THEM. ABSOLUTELY AND AGAIN
OF THE FIRST TO A OUR FRIENDS
AT MERCURY HERE TODAY JUST THE
CREATIVE SIDE OF THAT MESSAGING
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT BUT
FROM A PLANNING. AND EXECUTION
SIDE KNOW THAT WE HAVE. WINDOWS
ON BOTH ENDS OF THAT PRIME
CAMPAIGN TIME THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
GROUND WORK THEY CAN BE LAID.
BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF THE
YEAR AND FRANKLY EVEN IN
JANUARY. RIGHT BEFORE THE
AIRWAVES ARE CONSUMED. WITH.
THE FILL IN THE BLANK AND I
APPROVED THIS MESSAGE. BUT THEN
WE HAVE BUT THEN THOSE RATES
ARE GONNA DROP COME MARCH
FOURTH. RIGHT FOR ALL THE PRICE
INCREASE THERE MAY BE FOR
COMPETITION FOR THE AIRWAYS
PRIOR TO MARCH THIRD. SECOND
DROP AFTER MARCH FOURTH IN THE
LEAD UP TO MARCH TWELFTH
FIFTEENTH AND APRIL FIRST SO.
YOU KNOW THERE'S THE CUTS BOTH
WAYS ABBAS. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR THE SECRETARY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I SHOULD SAY AS A
NEWLY MARRIED MAN THANK YOU TO
YOUR WIFE FOR GIVE YOU
PERMISSION TO TAKE ON THESE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES BUT
I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW A LOT OF
US FEEL VERY CONFIDENT WITH THE
WITH THE HOME OF THE COMPLETE
CALCULATED AND I'LL WALK AWAY
WITH THIS FOR ALL THE GREAT
STUFF YOU'LL HEAR TODAY AND
GOING FORWARD ABOUT. STATEWIDE
MEDIA PLAN AND SOCIAL MEDIA
EARNED MEDIA PAID ME TO
STRATEGIES ENGLISH SPANISH AND
A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER LANGUAGES
THERE'S ALSO NO SUBSTITUTE FOR
THAT PERSONAL ENGAGEMENT SO I
INVITE YOU TO ENCOURAGE YOU I
IMPLORE EACH AND EVERY
LEGISLATE TOWARD. TO GET
ENGAGED IN THEIR DISTRICT AND
INVITE ME. WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
SCHOOLS TO FAIRS TO TOWN HALLS
OR WHATEVER IT IS. IT'S ALL
HANDS ON DECK TYPES OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GREAT THANK YOU.
SO NEXT UP I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER I BELIEVE IT TO DOCTOR
PANAS TO KICK OFF THE NEXT
SESSION OKAY THANK YOU SO OUR
NEXT PANELS ON EXPERIENCE AND
RESEARCHING COMMUNICATING WITH
HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES AND
WE HAVE. THREE IMMIGRATION THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
JONATHAN TRANCE SENIOR PROGRAM
MANAGER TO CALIFORNIAN DOWNMAN
AND GENEVIEVE FLORES HARO SO
SEATS IF I MISPRONOUNCE IT WAS
NAME APOLOGIZE. ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR. XO INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN HEARING YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. ON OUR HELP MEDIA
PLAN AND OUTREACH AND YOUR
SUGGESTIONS THANK YOU AND
WELCOME SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THEM MR ASK VIDEO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU OUR GERMAN PAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
AND IT'S REALLY AN HONOR TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY COME SHARE
MORE ABOUT OUR WORK. AND ALL OF
THE GREAT EFFORTS HAPPENING
AROUND THE CENSUS MY NAME'S F.
BY UNESCO WELL I'M ICE
PRESIDENT AT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. AND WANT
TO START OFF BY JUST EXPRESSING
THANKS TO BOTH CENTER PADILLA'S
OFFICE WHO'S BEEN EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE WITH A LOT OF THE
PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE WITH
JUST AN IMMENSE AMOUNT OF
ACCESSIBILITY TO ATTEND
MEETINGS. TO SHARE THOUGHTS TO
LISTEN TO THINGS WERE WORKING
ON AND PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND
ALSO TO DO THIS AND THE TEAM AT
THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
OFFICE WHO HAVE BEEN DEFINITELY
GREAT IN TERMS OF BEING
ACCESSIBLE AND ALSO PROVIDING
GUIDANCE AND LEADERSHIP AS WE-
PUT EFFORTS FORWARD TODAY I
WANT IT. OR WITH WITH YOU ALL A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND WITH THE SUPPORT
OF PARTNERS FROM ACROSS THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE AT THAT AS
THE ADMINISTRATIVE CBO FOR
REGION EIGHT WHICH REPRESENTS
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AND AS PART
OF THAT WE HAVE BEEN FOR MORE
THAN A YEAR WORKING ON THE
GROUND PUTTING TOGETHER LOCAL
PLANS FOR WHAT'S IT GONNA TAKE
ONE OF THE CONCERNS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE THE CAPACITIES
THAT WE CAN BUILD ON. AND WHAT
IS THAT ONE OF THE CAPACITY
STILL MISSING THAT WE COULD USE
SUPPORT FOR AND DO AND I'M I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT. WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE STATE. AND
SUPPORT OF PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY
I JUST THIS PAST MONTH WE HAVE
ROLLED OUT AN INITIAL SET OF
ACTUAL GRANTS SO DOLLARS ON THE
GROUND. TWO FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE COVERING PRETTY MUCH A
LARGE PART OF THE COUNTY BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY. SOME OF THE
HARDEST OF THE HARDEST TO COUNT
TRACKS IN THE COUNTY TO BEGAN
AS SECRETARY PADILLA MENTIONED
THAT EARLY EDUCATION WORK WHICH
IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL. TO ONE
NOT JUST. EDUCATING PEOPLE ON
WHAT IS A CENSUS BUT ON BRIDGE.
OF THOSE FEARS OF PARTICIPATION
TRUSTING GOVERNMENT. THAT OUR
E. CENTRAL TO SUCCESS IN IN IN
CALIFORNIA I'M. WE FULLY
RECOGNIZE AS WE GOT THESE
DOLLARS OUT AND ARE WORKING
WITH AN INCREASING AMOUNT OF
PARTNERS ACROSS LA COUNTY. THAT
UP WITH THE AMOUNT OF TIME AS
HAS BEEN REFERENCE A SEVEN
MONTHS LEFT IT'S ALSO TIME TO
GET VERY PRACTICAL AND TACTICAL.
SO TODAY MY COMMENTS ARE AIMED
AT GETTING JUST RIGHT AT THE
KEY OF WHAT WE'RE LEARNING ON
THE GROUND WHAT WERE SEEN IS
WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE. A TO
REALLY. INCREASE PARTICIPATION
IN THE CENSUS PARTICULARLY AT
AN ALLEY COUNTY WHICH IS
RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE
HARDEST ACCOUNT COUNTIES. ARE
IN THE NATION AND ESSENTIAL TO
CALIFORNIA SUCCESSFUL CENSUS.
SO FIRST WATER KEYS TO SUCCESS
AND WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS AND MESSAGING
WHILE THE FIRST AND VERY QUICK
LESSON WAS THAT. THERE IS NO
SILVER BULLET MESSAGE THERE IS
NO ONE SINGLE UNIFIED MESSAGE
THAT IS GOING TO RALLY EVERYONE
IT'S NOT ABOUT MOTIVATION. PER
S AND WHAT ARE IS GOING TO BE
ESSENTIAL THAN IS BUILDING DEEP
MESSAGING THAT ONE FOCUSES ON
INSTILLING TRUST. IN PEOPLE
THAT PARTICIPATING IN THE
CENSUS IS NOT GOING TO HAVE A
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES ON THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
TO EMPHASIZING THE
CONFIDENTIALITY AND THAT THE
RULE OF LAW PROTECTS THE
CONFIDENTIALITY. AND THIRD
DIRECTING PEOPLE TO WHERE IT IS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO GET ASSISTANCE AND WHAT
WE'RE FOCUSING ON IS A HARD TO
COUNT A COMMUNITIES AND I WILL
SAY THAT. BEYOND MESSAGING
WE'RE GONNA NEED SUBSTANCE
BEYOND THAT MESSAGE AND I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE WORK OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO. IN AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE WHICH IS
SEEKING TO ACTUALLY A FIRM
WATER PEOPLE'S RIGHTS WHAT IT'S
HOW WAS CALIFORNIA. A FIRM
THAT'S RIGHT AS A AS A STATE
THAT HAS MORE DEPRESSED OF THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. DOES TO WORKING ON
VEHICLES LIKE THAT IS GOING TO
BE ESSENTIAL TO MEET KIND OF.
THESE OF THESE MAPS JUST. THE
SECOND IS THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
AN INTEGRATED APPROACH TO
COMMUNICATIONS WE CANNOT HAVE A
CASE THAT PLEA BOMBARDS OFFLINE
LOOKS GREAT ONLINE GETS A LOT
OF IMPRESSION BUT IS NOT
CONNECTED TO. OUR LINE WITH.
THAT US SECRETARY. MEDINA
MENTION RIGHT SO LUCKY FOR
PARTNERSHIPS. ART BACK CONTACT
EVERYTHING WE'RE GOING TO BE
DUE ON THE AIR TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND IS
GOING TO BE ESSENTIAL TO OUR
SUCCESS. WHEN THE **** TO SHARE
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE THROUGH
A CBO THEM PARTNERS ON THE
GROUND ENCOURAGING THE BUILDING
OF COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS AN EXAMPLE AN
OUTLAY. WE'VE SET UP A
COMMUNICATIONS DURING A
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE THAT
HAS ALL OF THE COMMUNICATORS
FROM SOME OF OUR OUR MOST
RESILIENT AND STRONG AS
COMMUNICATOR ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
TO JUST START MEETING TOGETHER
BUILDING TRUST AND SO AS WE
LOOK TO IMPLEMENT THE WORK UP
STATE PARTNERS CONNECTING TO
THAT AN ENCOURAGING THAT IS
GOING TO BE THE BEST WAY TO
COMBAT. MISINFORMATION ON THE
GROUND. I WANT TO NOW SHARE.
FIVE JUST PRACTICAL WISHLIST
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I'LL SHARE
WITH YOU FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
ON THE GROUND. THE FIRST IS
THAT GIVEN THE TARGETS OF US
CENSUS SUPPRESSION EFFORTS AND
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE SEEN.
ARE WIDELY THAT WE REALLY NEED
AN ETHNIC MEDIA STRONG STRATEGY
IF WE'RE GOING TO APPROACH THIS
FROM AN EQUITY STANDPOINT. AND
THEN TO. THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE NOT JUST WORKING
WITH NETWORK STATIONS BUT
MAKING BUYS ON THE GROUND AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. THREE THAT
WE'RE ENGAGING AND SUPPORTING
TALENT BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T
JUST TRUST THE MESSAGE I'M
GONNA SEND A TRUST THE TENANT
THAT BRINGS IT SO DJ
ENDORSEMENTS AND THEN LASTLY.
WOULD JUST SAY THAT. WE NEED TO
FIND WAYS THAT IN OUR
INVESTMENTS WERE CREATING LOCAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ACTIVATION SO
WE PLACE A BY CAN WE GET ALL
THESE EVENTS THAT THE STATIONS
ARE DOING AND THE DJS AND
CONNECT THEM TO THE NONPROFITS.
ON THE GROUND. IT'S TIME TO
REALLY TRANSITION CRIME
TRANSACTIONAL GET YOUR
STRATEGIC PLANS IN A GET YOUR
INVOICES AND TO NOW BEING
PARTNERS WITH THE STATE BOTH AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND ON THE
GROUND. AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT COMING OFF OF THE
CONVENING YESTERDAY THAT
BROUGHT TOGETHER A CBO THAN CBO
PARTNERS STATEWIDE OUT. WE FEEL
VERY SUPPORTIVE AND WE FEEL
THAT WITH THAT TRANSITION IS
STARTING TO HAPPEN AND IT'S
GONNA BE THROUGH THAT
PARTNERSHIP APPROACH. THAT WILL
BE VERY SUCCESSFUL WE NOW
CLEARLY NOW AFTER IT'S
COMPETING ON NOW HAVE SKIN IN
THE GAME SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE FROM OUR
WORK AND LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU. JOHN
THE TREND FANTASTIC. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON PAN
BERMAN NUMBER MEMBERS OF THE-
JOINT COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY. AND FOR YOUR ON
GOING PARTNERSHIP IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A COMPLETE
ACCURATE CENSUS COUNT. AGAIN MY
NAME IS JONATHAN TRêN ON THE
SENIOR PROGRAM MANAGER THE
CALIFORNIA DALVIN AND ALSO
SERVICE CO CHAIR OF OUR
INTERNAL SINCE THIS WORKGROUP.
A BEFORE I DO BEGIN THOUGH I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
TREMENDOUS WORK THAT STAFF IS
PUT INTO MAKING THIS. COMMITTEE
HEARING TAKE PLACE IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND ALSO ESPECIALLY THANK
YOU THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE
TREMENDOUS INVESTMENT. THAT YOU
MADE IN TERMS OF MAKING. SENSE
AS A PRIORITY AND THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
REACH THE HARDEST TO CAL
POPULATIONS HERE IN THE STATE.
AS A STATEWIDE HEALTH
FOUNDATION BEING DOWN IT
FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THAT IT'S
ACCURATE CENSUS COUNT IS GONNA
BE CRITICAL TO OUR HEALTH AND
RACIAL EQUITY MISSION AND GOALS
IN THE LONG TERM. AND AS SUCH
AS PART OF OUR TEN MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR SINCE
IT'S OUT REGION ENGAGEMENT OF
THE INDOMINUS ACTUALLY
EMBARKING ON A THREE PHASE. PAY
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY TO HELP
PROVIDE EARLY EDUCATION AS THE
STATE BEGINS TO ROLL OUT IN
THAT IT SEPARATES SO PHASE ONE
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO LAUNCH. IN
SEPTEMBER AS PART OF EARLY
EDUCATION STRATEGY TARGETED
SPECIFICALLY AT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THIS INCLUDES THINGS
LIKE PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
LOCAL UNIVISION STATION. PAY
DIGITAL THAT REDIRECTS FOLKS
BACK TO THE A. CBO'S AND
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE AREA
TRADITIONAL PRINT TO READ AT
REACH AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES AND GOING AS FAR AS
DOING AMONG RADIO WITH LOCAL
PARTNERS THAT ARE GOING TO BE.
THE ONES THAT ARE DOING THE
DOOR TO DOOR OUT REACH WERE
ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THE NEXT TO PHASES
THAT WILL COINCIDE WITH
ULTIMATELY WHAT THE STATE'S
PLAN. BUT WE FIGURE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GET EARLY
EDUCATION OUT THERE AS SOON AS
WE CAN BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE
CHALLENGES IN FRONT OF US ARE
GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANT. I'M
NOT GONNA SPEND. A WHOLE LOT OF
TIME IN TERMS OF DISCUSSING
WHAT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE SAN.
SINCE WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT. OP BUT
RATHER I'M GONNA FOCUS AND SOME
OF THE LESSONS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED. IN TRYING TO SURVEY
THE FIELD ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND FROM MESSAGING
STANDPOINT. TO KIND OF QUALIFY
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'RE
GONNA PUT FOR JUST TO GIVE YOU
SOME CONTACTS. OVER THE COURSE
OF LAST FOR MONTHS THE
ENTITLEMENT HAS PARTICIPATING
CONDUCTED SEVERAL FOCUS GROUP
TEST ACROSS THE STATE
PARTICULARLY UNDER REPRESENTED
A AREAS OR- AREAS THAT RARELY
RECEIVE THAT SUCH TESTING. THIS
INCLUDES PARTS OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THE INLAND VALLEY AND
ALSO SAN DIEGO AND WE TARGETED
HARD TO REACH POPULATIONS
INCLUDING. LATINOS AFRICAN
AMERICANS MILLENNIALS RESIDENTS
THAT SPEAK VIETNAMESE TAGALOG
MYSTICAL AND PUT JOB. AT THIS
VERY MOMENT THE DOMINANT ALSO
CONDUCTING A QUANTITATIVE
SURVEY THAT WE HELD BACK TO
WAIT FOR THE DECISION ON THE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION SO THAT WE
CAN BETTER ASSESS WHAT THE
ACTUAL CLIMB IT LOOKS LIKE AS
SOON AS WE HAVE THE FULL REPORT
WILL BE SHARING ULTIMATELY THE
FINAL RESULTS OF BOTH THE FOCUS
GROUP TESTING AS WELL AS
APPOINT SURVEY SO THAT. ALL THE
PARTNERS WORKING ON CENSUS WILL
HAVE. ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT OUR FINDINGS ARE SO LIEU
OF THE FULL REPORT I'M JUST
GOING TO HIGHLIGHT THE TOP FIVE
THINGS FROM THE OVERALL FOLKS
GET FOCUS GROUP TESTING THAT I
THINK ARE GOING TO BE RELEVANT
IN THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS AND MEDIA. SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS JUST THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT AWARENESS
ABOUT THE CENSUS IS GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY LOW BUT WITH BASIC
INFORMATION PARTICIPATION
BECOMES MORE LIKELY SO NOW TO
THE FOCUS GROUP CONDUCTED
ACROSS EVERY SINGLE G. ABOUT
GEOGRAPHY AND POPULATION IS
OVERWHELMINGLY CLEAR THAT MOST
PEOPLE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE
SENSES IS ONE. NO IDEA WHEN THE
CENSUS IS TWO AND THREE MORE
IMPORTANTLY DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THE CENSUS ULTIMATELY
AFFECT THEM IN THEIR FAMILY SO
IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
EDUCATION IT IS GOING TO BE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE GET
AHEAD OF THE CURVE IN TERMS OF
EDUCATING POPULATIONS ABOUT
WHAT THE SENTENCES IT'S TIME
LINE AND SO WE FULLY ANTICIPATE
THAT STATE IS GONNA BE PREPARED
TO PROVIDE. THAT INFORMATION.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
GONNA BE CRITICAL BECAUSE JUST
THE BASELINE OF INFORMATION
GETS FOLKSINTERESTED
ULTIMATELY. AND FILLING IT OUT
WHICH CAN LEAD TO THE SECOND
POINT. DON'T TELL PEOPLE SIMPLY
THAT THE CENSUS IS IMPORTANT.
SHOW THEM HOW IT AFFECTS THEIR
DAILY LIVES WHAT I MEAN BY THIS
IS THAT WE I CAN'T UNDER
EMPHASIZE THE FACT OF THE-
EDUCATION. ABOUT THE SENSES
NEEDS TO BE TIED TO HOW THE
SENSES WHAT IMPACT PEOPLE ON A
DAILY BASIS. SO ONE EXAMPLE OF
THE MESSAGING THAT WE TESTED
WAS WHETHER OR NOT SOMETHING A
SLOGAN LIKE EVERY PERSON
COUNTED OUT MEANS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS MORE FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY. WE BELIEVE THAT
MAKING THOSE TYPES OF
STATEMENTS FROM THE FOCUS GROUP
TESTING WAS KIND OF A FALSE
COMMITMENT IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE
PUTTING A FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR CHECK IN PEOPLE'S
POCKETS RIGHT. MOREOVER IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT GRAN
NUMBERS LIKE CALIFORNIA STANDS
TO LOSE X. BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IF WE DON'T HAVE A COMPLETE
SENSE OF DOUBT ALSO DOESN'T
WORK BECAUSE IT'S NOT RELEVANT.
THE INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES LIVES
THAT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AT
STAKE DOESN'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN INDIVIDUALS WHAT.
INDIVIDUALS LIVES ALTERNATIVELY
WHAT WE FOUND TO BE SUCCESSFUL
WAS MESSAGING THAT REALLY
RELATED TO FOCUS ON A LOCAL
LEVEL SO FOR EXAMPLE. WHAT THE
CENSUS BECAUSE IT'LL HELP
FREEPORT ELEMENTARY KEEP ITS
HEAD START PROGRAM. BE SPECIFIC
AND BE LOCAL ABOUT OUR APPROACH
FROM A MESSAGING STANDPOINT I'M
GONNA SKIP AHEAD IN TERMS OF
OUR OTHER FINDINGS AND REALLY
LAND ON SOME OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS I WOULD REITERATE.
MARINES POINT ABOUT THE
EMPHASIS OF THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE A SINGLE TAGLINE OR HASH
TAG I WISH WE COULD THROW A
HASHTAG ON AND MAKE EVERYTHING
WONDERFUL AGAIN. BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT THE CHALLENGES
THAT EXISTS FROM SENSES
STANDPOINT A REALLY GOING TO
COME DOWN TO THE RELATIONSHIPS
AND TRUSTED MESSENGERS ON THE
GROUND. AND SPECIFICALLY THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
COMMUNICATIONS PLANS AND
ULTIMATELY THE FOLKS ON THE
GROUND AND HOW THEY TIE BACK
TOGETHER. THROWING TAGLINES OR
TRANSLATING MESSAGES IN MALTA
THE SAME MESSAGE IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES JUST ISN'T GOING TO
BE GOING TO WORK YOU NEED TO
TAILOR IT SPECIFIC TO THE
POPULATIONS AND THEN ULTIMATELY
MAKE SURE THAT THE PAID ME A
DOLLARS. ARE DONE IN
COORDINATION WITH THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE LEADING
THE EFFORT ON THE GROUND. THANK
YOU AND WE WILL PROBABLY HAVE
MORE TIME FOR SCHOOL WE GET THE
DISCUSSION PART AS WELL SO
FINALLY WE HAVE GENEVIEVE OR
SORROW WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
A COMMITTEE CO CHAIRS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER IS
HOW TO AND THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR FOR THE MIX THAT GOING
TO CONNECT ME TO ORGANIZING
PROJECT. OR MY CUP FOR SURE
THEY ALSO ANSWER TO MAKE UP
WERE MULTI LINGUAL. OF THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE INVITATION
TO BE HERE ENSURE SPACE WITH
YOU ALL. EARLIER THIS YEAR MY
CUP WAS SELECTED AS ONE OF TWO
STATEWIDE CONTRACTORS FOR
FARMWORKERS SENSES EDUCATION
OUTREACH EFFORTS. OF FORGET
INTO THAT JUST WENT A LITTLE
CONTEXT A LITTLE GROUNDING I
AND THE WORK THAT WE DO
SATURDAY TODAY MY CUPS WORKERS
TO SUPPORT ORGANIZE AND EMPOWER
INDIGENOUS MIGRANTS LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA CENTRAL COAST'S OF
SANTA BARBARA INTERCOUNTY
SPECIFICALLY. ACROSS NINETEEN
PROGRAMS THAT TOUCH A CROWD
THAT TOUCH ON COMMITTEE
ORGANIZING DIRECT ASSISTANCE
AND OUR COMMUNITY RADIO STATION
ABOUT THE ON THE CAN AM. MY
COUPLE HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND ONE
WITH 85% OR STOP COMING FROM
THE INDIGENOUS MIGRANT
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS 50% OF OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. AND IT TWO
THOUSAND TEN AN INDIGENOUS
FARMWORKERS STUDY WAS CONDUCTED
WITH SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT SO IN A
SENSE OF OUR TYPE OF CENSUS SO
OUR NUMBERS NEED TO BE UPDATED
AS WELL. BUT FROM THAT STUDY
THEY SHOW THAT THERE'S AN
ESTIMATED ITS WANT ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE TO ONE UNDER
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DIGITS
MIGRANTS LIVING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
MAJORITY OF THESE FOLKS HAD
HELP FROM SOUTHERN MEDICAL. AND
BETWEEN 5840250% OF THE
FARMWORKERS AND THE CITY
CALIFORNIA ARE INDIGENOUS AND
THEN SPEAK THEIR INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES THAT INCLUDE MIX THAT
GOALS UP WITH THAT GOAL PUT IT
BETCHA. FREAKY OR TO ME NOW
WHAT. AND MANY MANY MORE. ON
THESE. LANGUAGES ARE SEPARATE
UNTO THEMSELVES AND UNLIKE
SPANISH AND UNFORTUNATELY WHAT
WE SEE IN OUR LINE OF WORK IS
THAT ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE FROM MEXICO.
GET LOCKED IN THE SPANISH
SPEAKERS SO TRADITIONAL WAYS
OF. REACHING OUT TO SPANISH
SPEAKERS JUST DON'T WORK FOR
OUR FOLKS. ARE INDIGENT MY
COMMUNITY HAVE LOW LITERACY
LEVELS BECAUSE OF THE ORAL
NATURE OF THEIR LANGUAGES. AND
WE LAKE SECTOR PRETTY
MENTIONED. A WE ALSO CUT ACROSS
DIFFERENT HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS OF CHILDREN WE HAVE
MANY CHILDREN AGED ZERO TO
FIVE. LOW BROADBAND AREAS OF
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
RENTERS IMMIGRANT STATUS AND
MORE. AND WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THROUGH THIS WORK I WITH THE
SENSES THAT THERE ARE OTHER.
POCKETS A FARMWORKERS INCLUDING
PUNJABI. LONG OR THE SPEAKERS
THAT WE FEEL WE CAN APPLY THE
SAME STRATEGIES AT IT IN TERMS
OF. OUT REACH. SO DURING THE
LAST FEW MONTHS MY TIME HAS
BEEN SPENT SETTING THE
GROUNDWORK FOR OUR SENSES WORK.
BY ATTENDING IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN WORKSHOPS AND BAKERSFIELD.
FRESNO SALINAS. AND SANTA ROSA
I'VE BEEN ON TOUR THIS IS ALSO
PART OF. SO THESE WORKSHOPS TO
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INTERFACE WITH FOLKS ON THE
GROUND GIVEN THAT WERE SO
SPECIFIC TO ENTER IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. TO LEARN FOR-THE FOLKS ON THE GROUND HERE
WHAT THIS ISSUES ARE SPECIFIC
TO EACH REGION. PART OF OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN HAS A THREE
PRONGED APPROACH TO ALREADY
HEARD HIGH TOUCH BOOTS ON THE
GROUND. BUT THE OTHER PIECE OF
IT IS A RADIO GAME. SO AS I
MENTIONED WE HAVE A COMMUNITY
BASED LOW POWER RADIO STATION
PROBABLY WHEN THEY CAN NOW. AND
WE ENVISION OUR COMMUNITY BASED
RADIO STATION MUCH LIKE THE
OTHER TWENTY BASED RADIO
STATIONS TO CALIFORNIA. TO BE
USED AS AN AGGRESSIVE OUR
RITUAL TO PUSH MESSAGING
CONTENT INTO CREE ATTITUDINAL
CHANGE ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY.
TWENTY. I'M CURRENTLY OUR VIDEO
STATION IS PLAYED. AND
AGRICULTURE FEELS THEREOF AND
TERRA AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTY.
AND WE USE AS A VEHICLE TO GET
A CRUCIAL INFORMATION SO FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN OUR AREA WAS HIT
BY THE THOMAS FIRE. WE'RE USING
THAT TO PUSH OUT EVACUATION
NOTICES. THE IMPORTANCE OF IN
ANY FIVE MASKS AND SO MUCH
MORE. HOW WE CURRENTLY HOST
FORTY HOURS OF LIVE ORIGINAL
PROGRAMMING. AS WELL AS
HUNDREDS OF HOURS APPROVED
COURTED PSAS. SO WE SEEK TO
UTILIZE OUR PRODUCTION EXPERT.
EASE OF PSAS. TO WORK WITH THE
AT THE NEW CONTRACT MEDIA
PARTNER. I'M TO PUSH OUT
INFORMATION AND MESSAGES THAT
ARE TAILORED TO OUR COMMUNITY.
AND OF THESE PSA WILL BE
RECORDED IN SPANISH MAKES THAT
GOES UP WITH MICHAEL ENGLISH.
WHAT ABOUT GENTLY. WE BELIEVE
THAT CONCEPTS CONSISTENT AND
ENTER. THE MESSAGING THROUGH
PSAS GIVES THE- TRINITY TO
ENGAGE IN AUDIO. AND FORMALLY.
WITHOUT THEM ACTIVELY SEEKING
OR AND REALIZED THAT THEY'RE
BEING INFORMED. FOR EXAMPLE WE
ALSO RUN OUT OF THE AND ALL THE
ON BREAST CANCER. COMMENTS BUT
AGAIN IT'S JUST A WILL. ENGAGE
FOLKS. AGAIN MY ANOTHER BAY IS
NOT RATE OF FIRE. SO FOR THIS
IT'S A DRIP DRIP METHOD THAT
WE'VE BEEN CALLING. AND WE
FOUND THAT IT'S- BEEN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET
INFORMATION OUT ALSO TO FOLKS
LEVEL. WILL EDUCATION
ATTAINMENT. AND WE ALSO VISION
IS PSAS NOT LIMITED TO A RADIO
STATION BUT BEING PLAYED IN
PLACES LIKE AMBULATORY CAN.
CLINICS FOR THE COUNTY. HUMAN
SERVICES. AGENCY OFFICES IT'S
FOR ALL REALLY. RADIO AND RADIO
PROGRAMMING LIKE IT AS A WAY TO.
CHANGE ATTITUDES ON THAT UNLESS
THE YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO INVITE
REPRESENTATIVES SO FOLKS IN
YOUR OFFICES FOLKS FROM THE
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE EVEN
BOOKS IN THE FEDERAL CENSUS
BUREAU TO HAVE A PRESENCE ON
RADIO. SKIPPING. AND JUST
WANTING TO ALSO REALLY
REITERATE YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH OUR
FOLKS HAVE YOU KNOW LITERACY
RATES THERE ON SOCIAL MEDIA
THEIR KIDS MAKE THEIR FACEBOOK
ACCOUNT THERE WHAT'S UP
ACCOUNT. AND SO THAT'S ALSO
ANOTHER READ PLEASE THE YOU CAN
PUSH AUDIO AND VISUALS. OUT TO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN WE DO A RADIO BROADCAST
OUT OF THE AND THEY CAN I WE
ALSO PUT IT ON FACEBOOK SO IT'S
RECORDED AND PEOPLE CAN COME
BACK TO IT THEY CAN RE SHARE IT
THEY CAN LIKE IT. AND SO ALSO A
REALLY GLAD THAT A FRIEND AND
ON A COUPLE TOUCH ON ON THIS
PIECE YOU KNOW WE ARE CAN A
COMMUNITY BASED RADIO STATION
IS NOT ANYTHING LIKE A
COMMERCIAL RADIO STATION. SO
ALSO THE PUSH FOR FUNDING TO
COME IN AND SUPPORT THAT WORK
AS WELL WE SEE OUR FUNDING
REALLY AS GOING TOWARDS THE
GROUND GAME AND SO WE REALLY
NEED BOTH. AIR AND GROUND TO
COMPLIMENT ONE EACH OTHER AT
THE COMPLETE COUNT. HERE
THROUGHOUT THE I. P. W'S I
REPEATEDLY HEARD THE PHRASE
TRUSTED MESSENGER AND LIKE WHAT
IS TRUST AS MESSENGER REALLY
MEAN AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
THESE COMMUNITY RADIO STATIONS
PROVIDING UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY.
AS A TRUSTED MANAGER ASKED
SOMETHING THAT FOLKS TUNE INTO
DAY IN AND DAY OUT. IT'S NOT
LOST ON US THAT MY COP AND ON
THE ON THE KING OF THE NEED TO
AFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING. A COMMUNITIES
INFORMATION AS IT RELATES TO
THE ANSWER. TEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE. AND THAT'S NOT
TRUST THE WERE. READILY GOING
TO SQUANDER. WE REALIZE THIS IS
IMPORTANT IT'S YOU FOLKS HERE I
COMMITTEE. AT US AS A STATEWIDE
CONTRACTOR. IS THE PILOT
THAT'LL THAT'S PUSHING ICE
CREAM AND IT'S GONNA TAKE ALL
OF US TO GET A COMPLETE COUNCIL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I THANK
ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS ARE THE
PRESENTATIONS NOW QUESTS
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY YES SOME EVER
RANDALL SO FIRST IF I CAN JUST
GO THROUGH THE SEQUENCE OF
PRESENTERS AND JUST HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE THINGS I THOUGHT
YOU SAID QUITE WELL AND
SOMETIMES READER REITERATING IT
BACK ACTUALLY WILL ALLOW THAT
MESSAGE TO BE HEARD A SECOND
TIME. I REALLY DO BELIEVE WE
NEED TO EMPHASIZE
CONFIDENTIALITY AND MAKE THIS
PRACTICAL AND IMPACTFUL AND
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR THAT A
FRIEND. JONATHAN TREND YOUR
COMMENTS REGARDING LONG RADIO
AND THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS NOT
LOST ON ME FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES WHO WORKS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT
IS A VERY GOOD ADVOCATE FOR
THIS AND I HOPE YOU CONTINUE
ALONG THAT PATH TO MAKE SURE
THAT. COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
FORGOTTEN GET INCLUDED BUT I
WANTED AND WITH MY COP IF I
COULD BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT
I'VE DONE WITH YOU IN THE PAST
HOW CAN WE HELP DRAW THE IN THE
HINA EXPAND TO RODEO BILLING
WAY ARE THERE WAYS WE CAN SHARE
PLATFORM SO THAT OUR COMMUNITY.
IS THAT ARE MORE WORLD GET
ACCESS. WHY I'M GETTING TO IT
IS REPRESENTING A RURAL
COMMUNITY IT'S THE RIGHT MEDIUM
IT'S WHERE PEOPLE ARE AT THEIR
IN THEIR CARS LISTENING TO THE
RADIO. AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET THAT TRUSTED
MESSENGER. THAT WAS THE POINT
TO ME. THAT WAS THE STRONGEST.
IT'S NOT THE MESSAGES TO
MESSENGER. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO REMEMBER THAT TO STAY
GROUNDED IN THAT SO THAT WE
HIRE THE RIGHT TALENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET A COMPLETE
CAM. I CAN RESPOND REALLY
QUICKLY SO PART OF WHAT I CUT
OUT WAS MENTIONING ABOUT THE OF
THE LANGUAGE ACTUALLY RATHER
WILL INCREASE. THE EXECUTOR TO
LIMóN ELLIS WAS THE REASON WHY
WE HAVE TO HAVE YOU IN THE CAN
A SO WE DO HAVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM AND KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE A NETWORK OF
FOURTEEN OTHER. COMMUNITY RADIO
STATION THAT SETS THEM IS
RATHER COMPASS CENA IT'S OUR
RADIO STATION LONG RADIO THING
PUT JOBY ONE A ONE ARE OF USA
ONE A ONE IT'S ALL THESE RADIO
STATIONS THAT ARE GOING TO COME
TOGETHER TO DO THE WORK. ON MY
DAD WENT TO COLLEGE TOGETHER
OKAY. NO HIS TWIN KIDS AND SO
HE'S A GREAT ADVOCATE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND AGAIN ANOTHER
TRUSTED. WHO BECAME THE
APPOINTS ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK. THANK YOU
YES SIR DORADO. A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. YOU CAN NEED ALL
THREE OF YOU TO ANSWER A AND
THANK YOU FOR ON ALL OF YOUR
WORK HAVE YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
EXAMPLES OF HOW YOU THINK AND
PARTICULARLY THE HARD THESE
HARD TO COUNT. REALLY REALLY
HARD TO COUNT. ARE THERE ARE
YOU FINDING WAYS THAT WOULD
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THESE CAN BE
USED TO FILL OUT THE CENSUS
FORM. AND TO HAVE YOU FOUND THE
CORD NATION. I KNOW TO DO THIS
WORKS EXTREMELY HARD AT THIS
AND SHE REALLY BELIEVES IN IT
BUT HAVE YOU FOUND SUFFICIENT
COORDINATION. AMONGST ALL OF
VARIOUS ENTITIES THAT ARE
ENGAGED IN THIS WORK OR DO YOU
HAVE SUGGESTIONS FOR. OTHER
WAYS THAT WE COULD FURTHER YOU
KNOW DO THIS. I CAN I CAN SHARE
SOME REALLY QUICK AND BRIEF
EXAMPLES TO RESPOND PLANNED AND
BITE MY PEERS TO DO SO AS WELL
SO. FIRST I THINK IN TERMS OF
THE ACCORD NATION PEACE JUST AS
AN EXAMPLE AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. PART OF THE PART OF THE
CHALLENGES THE GEOGRAPHY RIGHT
FOUR THOUSAND SQUARE MILES
EIGHTY EIGHT DIFFERENT CITIES.
SO THE WORK THERE HAS REALLY
BEEN LOCALIZED THROUGH A SET OF
WHAT WE CALL REGIONAL TABLES
WHICH MEET ON A QUARTERLY BASIS
WHICH I THINK CURRENTLY RIGHT
NOW ARE MAXING OUT ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED TOTAL ORGANIZATIONS
PARTICIPATING. AND WHAT THEY DO
THERE'S THROUGH AN AGENDA THEY
LINK UP THE AS SOON TO FIRST
ALL SHARE WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN
THE DIFFERENT CORNERS OF THE
COUNTY. AND THEY BREAK AWAY AND
THEY ALL PLANNED LOCALLY AND
SORT OF IDENTIFY WHO'S DOING
WHAT WHO'S GOT WHAT RESOURCES
AND WHAT ARE WE DOING. OP THAT
THAT'S JUST BEEN HAPPENING FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS NOW AND WHAT AND
THAT. ALSO BE GRANTS AND THE
RESOURCES THAT WE GAVE I'VE
GIVEN US A VIEW OF. EACH
ORGANIZATION THAT APPLIED
SHARED WHAT REGION'S THEY HAVE
STRENGTH IN AND WHERE THEY WILL
BE DOING WORK AND THAT'S
ALLOWED US TO START TO SEE WHO
ARE IN THE JOBS THAT WE MAKE
SURE CONNECTING. AND TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE WHAT THEY'RE
WORK WORK LOOKS LIKE IN TERMS.
OF AN EXAMPLE A PRACTICAL WAY
AND. IS IT. VERY PLAIN TERMS OF
REACHING THE HARD TO COUNT IS
GONNA BE THAT. THERE'S NOT ONE
SINGLE MEDIUM SOCIAL MEDIA IS
CRITICAL AND WE CAN'T REMEMBER
THAT WHILE WE'RE ALL CITING.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS A DIGITAL
FIRST SENT TO THAT THE
CHALLENGE. FOR MANY IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES IT COULD BE TURNED
INTO AN ASSET BECAUSE THEY
SPEND A LOT OF TIME DOWNLOADING
VIDEO ON MOBILES AND SO AS LONG
AS THIS APP. FOR THE FORM IS
MOBILE FRIENDLY I THINK IT
COULD BE AN ASSET AND THE KEY
THING IS TO REMEMBER THAT. ARE
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ARE MIXED
STATUS AND SO WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING TO THE PARENT WERE
TALKING TO THEIR NIECES AND
NEPHEWS TO THE KIDS THAT
ACTUALLY NAVIGATE. A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES FOR THEM AND WILL
NEED TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE
GEARING THE IMAGES AND THINGS
THAT THEY SEATED MAKE THIS BE A
FAMILY PEACE THOSE ARE JUST
SOME VERY. IMMEDIATE THINGS
THAT WERE SEEN. ARE JUST REALLY
QUICKLY TWO THOUGHTS ON THAT I
THINK ONE OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM. THE WORK THAT WE
DID AROUND ENROLLMENT DURING
THE ACA WAS TO BE ABLE TO
COORDINATE OUR P. MEDIA
STRATEGY WITH IN REAL LIFE
ACTIVITIES AND EVENTS THAT
ULTIMATELY. ARE PAID MEDIA
DOLLARS NEED TO BE DRIVING
PEOPLE TO SUPPORT ON THE
GROUND. AND TO HELP THE HARDEST
PART IS. TOCOUNT POPULATIONS
GET. THE TANGIBLE SUPPORT TO
FILL OUT THE CENSUS FORM AND SO
A LOT OF FOLKS TALK ABOUT. THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE I THINK ACT
ACTUALLY DIGITAL LITERACY
COMPONENT. AND SO GETTING FOLKS
TO THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
IS CRITICAL THE OTHER THING WE
LEARNED FROM THE FOCUS GROUP
TESTING IS THAT WE'RE PROBABLY
GONNA BE MORE EFFECTIVE TALK
ABOUT THE SENSES BY NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE SENTENCE. TALK ABOUT
THE ISSUES THAT PEOPLE CARE THE
MOST THAT IMPACT THEM THE MOST
SO. FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE CRITICAL IS
WORKING WITH. CLINICS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE HIGHLIGHTING
THE SENSES BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
FOR THE HARDEST ACCOUNT
POPULATIONS THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE ENTRY POINT. TO TALK ABOUT
THE CRITICAL ISSUES THAT IMPACT
THEM AND THEN ULTIMATELY
HOLDING IN. A MESSAGE. FLANK
THAT LIGHT SENSES MESSAGE ON
TOP OF THAT. YEAH I MEAN WE-
PART OF PART OF WHAT WE SEEK TO
DO IS ALSO USING OUR PROMOTE A
MODEL THAT WE ALREADY USE AND
TERMS OF TRUST AND MESSENGERS
FOLKS WERE FROM COMMUNITY SPEAK
THE LANGUAGE ARMING THEM LITTLE
TABLETS AND YES I WAS GAY YOU
HAVE YOU HEARD OF THE SENSES
THIS IS HAT IT IS AND KIND OF
GETTING THEM YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE DOING THERE ARE WHICH
FOR OTHER PROGRAMS YOU KNOW
HAVING YES IT IS INFORMATION
AND KNOW YOUR RIGHTS FORMS
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
COME FOR THAT SEE OF FOLKS IN
THE DOOR THE NO YOU'RE RIGHT.
AND THEN WELL AS THEY LEAVE
WILL HELP THEM WITH THE CENSUS
WORK RIGHT AND AGAIN GIVEN THAT
OUR FAMILIES DO HAVE LOW
LITERACY AND IT'S YOU KNOW
ONLINE MAKING THAT PHONE CALL
IN A WITH THE FAMILY AND
SUPPORTING THEM THAT WAY AND
THERE ARE SOME WAYS THAT WE SEE
US SUPPORTING. HANDS ON OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN FILLING
OUT THE CENSUS. THANK YOU.
TERRIBLE ALRIGHT THANK YOU THE
SENATE BENT COUPLE QUICK
QUESTIONS MISS FLORES HARO
YOU'D MENTIONED NUMBER OF
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES I WOULD
ATTEMPT TO PRONOUNCE THEM WHAT
DO A ROUGH ESTIMATE AS TO HOW
MANY MONOLINGUAL SPEAKERS OF
THOSE INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE
EXISTING CALIFORNIA I REALIZE
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THE SENSES
AND HELP THEM BUT YEAH BUT JUST
AN ORDER OF MAGNITUDE YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S THAT'S HARD TO SAY
AND THAT'S HARD TO SAY IF ONLY
BECAUSE SOMETIMES OUR FOLKS
DON'T SELF IDENTIFY AS BEING
INDIGENOUS SO THEY DON'T SELF
IDENTIFY AND THAT'S- REDING OF
THE WHOLE OF THE HEARING ON
LIKE COLONIALS ATION
INTERRELATION IMPERIALISM AND
ALL THAT. BUT I COULD GIVE YOU
REST ROUGH ESTIMATES YOU KNOW
IN TERMS OF INTER COUNTY WE'RE
LOOKING AT PROBABLY
200-002-5000 SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY IS A LITTLE BIGGER
TWENTY NINE TO LIKE THIRTY SOME
THOUSAND AND IT JUST REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE GROUP SO THE
MYSTICAL GROUPS ARE MORE
MONOLINGUAL VERSES THAT
POLITICAL MORE BILINGUAL IN THE
OF A US THE SIZEABLE AMOUNT IS
UP WITH THAT GO AND SOUTH LA.
FOR EXAMPLE SO REALLY JUST
DEPENDS ON THE GROUP AND OTHERS
PUT IT PENSIONS AND COACHELLA
VALLEY THEY LOOK. MORE
BILINGUAL SO IT REALLY JUST
DEPENDS. OKAY. SOUNDS LIKE A
LAWYER IT DEPENDS BUT IN ANY
EVENT. IS IT LIKE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND YOU THINK MONOLINGUAL
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE SPEAKERS
SOMETHING I'M JUST I'M REALLY.
LOOKING FOR A ROUGH ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE YEAH YOU KNOW I THAT
I DON'T KNOW. THE THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF STUDIES ON IT WE WERE
PART OF A STUDY THIS YEAR ON
STUDYING THE LANGUAGES AND SO
THOSE RESULTS ARE JUST COMING
OUT. BUT AGAIN IT IT DEPENDS
BECAUSE EITHER BILINGUAL
SOMETIMES EVEN TRACK WITH THE
U. THE TRILINGUAL WHICH IS
GREAT BUT MONOLINGUAL IT'S HARD
TO SAY. IT ALSO DEPENDS ON THE
WAVE TO AS WELL WHAT WE SAW IN
THE NINETIES. HIGHER OF.
PERCENTAGES OF MIT MONOLINGUAL
INDIGENT SPEAKERS. AND THEN
QUESTIONS TRYING. IS IT I TAKE
YOUR POINT ABOUT THE SORT OF
MICRO MESSAGING THAT THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S IN
IT FOR ME IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD. I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE POINTS
YOU WERE MAKING. WHICH WOULD
MILITATE AGAINST SORT OF DOING
A BRANDING KIND OF COKE KIND OF.
THAT'S THE GOOD THE BEVERAGE OF
TALK ABOUT. THE OF THE SORT OF
SORT OF A CAMPAIGN SO IT WOULD
SEEM THAT BROADCAST TV IT WOULD
NOT BE VERY USEFUL OR BROADCAST
RADIO THOSE KINDS OF THINGS IS
THAT ACCURATE I WOULD SAY IT'S
YES AND I THINK YOU ABSOLUTELY
NEED BOTH IN TERMS OF CREATING
THE SOUTH SURROUND SOUND TO DO
THE ONE A ONE EDUCATION ABOUT
THE CENSUS. BUT TO GET TO THE
HEART IS THE HARDEST REACH
POPULATIONS I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA NEED MUCH MORE TAILORED
LANGUAGE DIRECTED AT THOSE
POPULATION SO YEAH SO I WOULD
SAY IT'S A YES AND CONVERSATION
RATHER THAN EITHER OR IF I HAD
A BITE PRIORITY LIKE IN TERMS
OF WHERE I'M INVESTING
RESOURCES RIGHT I WOULD. AND
HISTORICALLY UNFORTUNATELY THAT
THE TARGETED IN NARAL APPROACH
IS NOT BEEN THE CASE RIGHT SO
YOU LOOK AT THE CASE WE COVER
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS NOT THE
STRATEGY. WILL HELP THE PARENTS
THE POIGNANT READ THEY WERE NOT
TARGETING THESE MONOLINGUAL OR
SMALLER POPULATIONS AND THERE
WERE CONSEQUENCES FOR THAT
RIGHT SO I THINK A LESSON
LEARNED IS LIKE REALLY TAYLOR
THOSE MESSAGES FROM A VISUAL
STANDPOINT I THANK YOU BOTH THE
RIGHT LIKE YOU CAN ATTACH. AND
GEO TARGET TO THE EXTREME IN
TERMS OF. LIKE HITTING THOSE
POPULATION SO THAT THE ABSENT.
OKAY WELL WE DON'T HAVE
UNLIMITED WE HAVE RIGHT TO
RESET BUT NOT UNLIMITED
RESOURCES SO OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AS WELL SO. FIRST OF
ALL ACTUALLY FROM A SLUR SORROW.
IN TERMS OF WELL WHAT WE WHAT
WE THINK ABOUT MEDIA RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE WRITTEN
YOU CAN HAVE AUDIO VISUAL AYE
AYE VISUAL TOGETHER AND- WE DO
HAVE POPULATIONS NATIVE
POPULATIONS OTHER PPULATIONS
WHO REALLY. YOU KNOW
COMMUNICATE. WITH NOT MAINLY
THROUGH NON WRITTEN MEANS RIGHT
AT SOMETIMES WE CREATE WRITTEN
THAT BUT REALLY FILES THAT'S
THAT'S CONNECTS PEOPLE DON'T
DON'T REALLY READ THEIR
LANGUAGE. SO HOW DO YOU HOW DO
YOU SEE. HUSH WHAT DO YOU THINK
IN TERMS OF. OUTREACH
STRATEGIES WE SHOULD
PARTICULARLY PURSUE FOR THOSE
POPULATIONS AND PERHAPS MAYBE
SOME OF THE OTHER PRESENTERS
MIGHT HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT AS WELL SO IT JUST.
PROTECT YOUR TERMS OF IT GET IT
GET THAT COMES OUT THE
TARGETING AND A TAILORING BUT
DOUBTS SOMETIMES PEOPLE GET A
LITTLE OVER RELIANCE ON OKAY
WOULD WILL DEVELOP A FLYER. OR
SOMETHING RIGHT YEAH I KNOW IT
DID ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE. PICTORIAL
NOVELLAS AS WELL WILL COME INTO
PLAY I THINK HAVING A REALLY
STRONG WITH VISUAL MESSAGING.
IN TERMS OF THIS IS A LOGO OF
SOMETHING AND WHEN YOU HAVE THE
PROMOTE OR IN FRONT OF YOU LIKE
YOU SEE THIS IMAGE YOU KNOW
THAT THIS IS WHAT THIS IS FOR
ITS FOR THE CENSUS YOU KNOW
THAT IT'S SAFE. YOU KNOW THAT
ME FROM MY COOPER FROM YOU KNOW
CENTRALLY NACIONALES CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT WE ARE TELLING YOU
THAT THIS IS AN OKAY IMAGINE SO
WHENYOU SEE THIS IMAGE TO
TRUST THIS IMAGE. AND HAVING
THAT GO ALONG WITH THE PATROL
STORY NO IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WE HAD THE SAME
ISSUE WHERE PARENTS THEN STAN
A. B. D. HAVE ON SO WHAT WE
ADVOCATED FOR TEACHERS IF THEY
HAD A MYSTICAL SPEAKING PARENT.
OF GREEN IS GOOD YELLOW THEY
NEED WORK IN RED IS YOU KNOW
NOT GREAT. YOU KNOW AND THE
OTHER THING IN THE SPACES THAT
WE'VE BEEN AND AS MY CALL WITH
REGARDS TO THE SENSES MAKING
SURE THAT WHATEVER IS DEVELOPED
IS DEVELOPED. AT A SECOND GRADE
LEVEL OR LOWER BECAUSE THAT YOU
CAN GET REALLY LOST IN THE NEW
ONES AS OF THAT AND SO MAKE
SURE THAT IT SENSIBLE. IN TERMS
OF LEVEL IF YOU KNOW IF THE
GATE WAS IN SPANISH THAT IS
JUST NOT. POSSIBLE GRADE LEVEL
FOR FROM TO REACH REGARDLESS OF
THE LANGUAGE. WE HAVE OVER TWO
HUNDRED LANGUAGES SPOKEN AND
YOU START TO ADD THAT UP.
FACING SOME VERY SIMILAR
CHALLENGES CHARACTER BASED
LANGUAGES AND YOU KNOW. YOU
KNOW SOUNDS GREAT TYPE
LANGUAGES AND SO. IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT A NUMBER IN LA
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE YOU'RE
PROBABLY LOOKING AT ABOUT ONE
OUT OF EVERY FOUR PEOPLE. IN LA
COUNTY ARE IN THE HOUSEHOLD
THAT SPEAKS A LANGUAGE. OTHER
THAN ENGLISH. AND SO IT'S A
PRETTY LARGE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS. AND I THINK WHEN
IT GOES WHEN IT GETS TOWARDS.
HOW WE DELIVER INFORMATION HOW
WE DO THAT. I THINK IT'S NOT. I
THINK PROBABLY WHATWE'RE
ADVOCATING FOR IS THAT IF YOU
HAVE A TOTAL BUCKET OF DOLLARS.
AND YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THE
HARDEST TO REALLY MOVE. HAVE
ALL THESE CHALLENGES ARE VERY
BIG LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE. AND
VERY STRONGLY CONNECT TO MEDIA
THAT REFLECTS OUR CULTURE. WE
SHOULD MAKE THE HEAVIEST
INVESTMENT THERE. AND THEN TRY
TO PROVIDE THE OVER ARCHING.
YOU KNOW GENERAL MARKET
INVESTMENT. THERE BUT-
TRADITIONALLY WE'VE DONE THE
OPPOSITE WE'VE INVESTED 10% OF
THE BUDGET. IN THE HARDEST TO
REACH PEOPLE. AND NINETY
PERCENT. ON THE SNAZZY REALLY
COOL LOOKING THING. TO
NORMALIZE THE CENSUS. SO I'M I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT A CULTURAL
ASPECT. ENTER PAN TO YOUR POINT
IT'S ABOUT A CULTURAL ASPECT
AND MAKING SURE IT'S EMBEDDED
AND THINGS. AND THEN ANOTHER
QUESTION. AND PRY ALSO ASK IF
THE FOLLOWING PANEL BUT- SO YOU
KNOW THE CENSUS IS ACTUALLY
FEDERAL ACTIVITY SO WE'RE
PUTTING A LOT OF MONEY AND THE
STATE BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS SO. THE FEDS
ARE GOING TO DO THEIR OWN.
MEDIA PLAN OF SOME SORT. WE
WON'T HAVE VERY MUCH SAY IN
THAT I THINK SO WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THAT. FLOATING OVER. SO IN
ADDITION TO POTENTIAL YOU KNOW
MISINFORMATION DISINFORMATION
OTHER TYPES OF MESSAGING WE
HAVE DURING PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGNS
OTHER TYPES OF ACTIVITIES GOING
ON THAT MAY. BE PEOPLE MORE OR
LESS WILLING TO OPEN THE DOOR
TO A STRANGER. WE WILL ALSO
HAVE A FEDERAL MEDIA CAMPAIGN.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE STATE.
TAILORING ITS CAMPAIGN IN
RELATION TO THE FEDERAL
CAMPAIGN AND THEN OF COURSE WE
TALKED ABOUT THE INTERFACE
BETWEEN THE STATE AND DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES BUT THEN WE ALSO OF
THIS FEDERAL CAMPAIGN TO I MEAN.
THAT'S GOING TO BE OUT THERE
WHETHER WE COORDINATE WITH THAT
OR NOT WHETHER WE'RE IN SYNC
WITH THAT ARE NOT YOU KNOW WE
COULD CREATE CONFUSION OF OR
NOT. SO DO YOU HAVE THOUGHTS
ABOUT FOR ON THE GROUND AND
MAYBE THE PEOPLE JUST IGNORE IT
BECAUSE IT'S TOO. DISCONNECTED
FROM THEM I DON'T KNOW SO I'D
END UP WITH YOU ANY THOUGHTS TO
YOUR SURVEYS OUR FOCUS GROUPS
OR SO FORTH WE'RE GONNA GET
MESSAGING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S. ON CENSUS. WHERE
SHOULD THE STATE POSITION
ITSELF RELATION TO THAT FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE. YEAH I THINK
IN LOOKING AT SOME OF THE EARLY
CONTENT THAT'S COME OUT FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT FEELS
PRETTY AGNOSTIC IN TERMS OF
THEIR APPROACH TO THE CENSUS
WRITING HAT. FOR THE MOST PART
THE CONTENT COMING FROM TO THE
CENSUS BUREAU HAS NOT BEEN
NEGATIVE RIGHT OR HAD I NOT
BEEN FILLED WITH ITS
INFORMATION CREDIT TO THE I
KNOW ANYWAY AND PAY THAT I
WANT. AND I WILL BE VERY CLEAR
BECAUSE YEAH I WAS WATCHING I
HAVEN'T I AM NOT ACCUSING VERY
WAS. OR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OF DOING THAT THERE ARE OTHER
ACTORS THAT A VERY INVOLVED
THAT SO I HAVE NO GOOD AND
THAT'S NOT MY CONCERN BUT THE
US CENSUS WILL DECIDE ON A
MEDIA STRATEGY. THEY'LL PLAY A
MEDIA STRATEGY THAT'S BOTH AN
OPPORTUNITY AND POTENTIALLY
CHALLENGE THE PENNY OF WHAT
STRATEGY THEY PICKING WHETHER
THAT SEEMS RESONATOR NOT BUT IT
WILL BE OUT THERE. WRITING BUT
NOT THIS INFORMATION SHOULD BE
IN ALL THE CENSUSES PART RIGHT
YEAH I THINK I WOULD. I WOULD
TAKE THE LANDS OF LOOKING AT IT
IN THE CONTEXT OF I DON'T THINK
FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DIFFERENTIATE RIGHT WHERE THE
MESSAGE IS COMING FROM RIGHT.
WHAT IS GOING TO RESONATE WITH
FOLKS IS HOW MUCH THEY TRUST
THE PERSON TELLING THEM ONE AND
THEN TO. I THINK IT GOES BACK
TO THE POINT ABOUT LIKE IT'S
NOT ABOUT THE MESSAGE OF THE
MESSENGER SO I THINK THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT NEEDS TO BE
REALLY TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THOSE
MESSENGERS TO BE BEAT REALLY.
SPEARHEADING THE EFFORT. ON THE
COMMUNICATIONS AND BECAUSE I.
LIKE THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO TELL UNTIL THE END OF THE AD
WILL WEAR THE LABEL LIKE WHAT.
WHAT LOGO YOU THROUGH ON THERE
LIKE IT'S GONNA BE HARD FOR
FOLKS TO DIFFERENT. I THINK.
AND PROVIDE FOR MY
UNDERSTANDING CORRECT ME ANYONE
FROM WRONG BUT I THINK IT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S TRYING TO
ACQUIRE THE COUNT VON COUNT
FROM SESAME STREET. OR
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT AND SO
IT'S A VERY. BROAD KIND OF
IMAGE WHICH IS LIKE AND THE
TAILORING OF THIS BUT THIS
SEMESTER THAT WE'VE BEEN
MENTIONING HERE. AT THIS PANEL
SO. JUST A OKAY TERRA BURKE.
QUICK FOLLOW UP THE AND I TAKE
YOUR POINTS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE MORE OF CALLED
MICRO MESSAGING VERSUS SORT OF
THE GENERIC BROADCAST TV KIND
OF THING THAT THAT'S GOING TO
CREATE A CHALLENGE FOR ALL OF
US BECAUSE OUR COLLEAGUES WILL
SAY WE'RE SPENDING A HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ON
MEDIA AND I HAVEN'T SEEN A
FACEBOOK AD THAT APPEARS ON MY
COMPUTER I HAVE WELL I YOU KNOW
IT WHEN I WATCH YOU KNOW SEAN
HANNITY I DON'T SEE. ADDS
CONCERNING THE SENSES ON FOX OR
WHATEVER. THAT'S OKAY BUT IT A
MINUTE I'M NOT BEING FACETIOUS
IT DOES CREATE A CHALLENGE FOR
US BECAUSE OF WE'RE DOING THESE
MICRO MESSAGES. SOME OF US
WON'T WON'T QUITE SEE THEM SO
WE'LL NEED TO DO. THAT FOR
THOSE OF US THAT HAVE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY. TO MAKE SURE
OUR MONEY IS WELL SPENT THAT
THAT THAT MEANS THAT THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DO A GOOD JOB. OF
DEMONSTRATING TO OUR COLLEAGUES
AND OTHERS IN LEADERSHIP
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHERE WE
ARE ACTUALLY. DELIVERING THE
MESSAGE AND HOW EFFECTIVE IT IS
SO I BECAUSE MY SECOND POINT.
AND BESIDES TRANSPARENCY THAT'S
ACCOUNTABILITY. CONTINUING
ACCOUNTABILITY TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT WE'RE GETTING. HILL
CONTACT OR SOME SORT OF. SOME
SOME SORT BANG FOR OUR BUCK SO
THANK YOU THREE. I WOULD THAT'S
WHAT THE SWORD DATABASE WILL
COME INTO PLAY IN TERMS OF LIKE
THE TOUCHES AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THOSE ARE NUMBERS
THAT ARE TANGIBLE AND REAL THAT
COULD BE SHOWN I'VE NOT GONNA
PRETEND I'M AN EXPERT ON THE
WHOLE PLATFORM BUT- BUT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
DEFINITELY REFER TO AS WELL.
THANK I'D SAY NO OTHER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS I
KNOW IT'S ALWAYS CHALLENGING
THE TAKE A LOT OF INFORMATION
AND FINISH SORT OF OUT OF TIME
BUT THIS IS BEEN VERY IMPORTANT
AND THAT ONE THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR PRESENTING HERE SO NOW
FOR OUR FORCED HIM TO TURN IT
OVER TO. SENATOR AND CHAIR OF
BURKE. THANK YOU SELF FOR THE
OVERVIEW OF STATE SINCE
COMMUNICATION EFFORTS AND HOW
THE STATE'S MEDIA CONTRACTOR
WILL REACH THE HARD TO COUNT
POPULATION WE HAVE MISSED. THE
DIRECTOR OF CENSUS TWENTY
TWENTY MISSED THE IS A COMMA
GAY. MARTHA DOMINGUEZ
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT.
MERCURY PUBLIC AFFAIRS STATE
MEDIA CONTRACTOR OF FORMER US
SPEAKER PHOBIA NOON YES AND
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF WE'VE
ALSO MERCURY CAROLINE BECKER.
THIS CATEGORY YOU'D LIKE TO
LEAD THAT WOULD BE GREAT GREAT
IT'S THE THIS KENTUCKY. THANK
YOU CHAIRS ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC
BERMAN SENATOR DR JAPAN'S UNDER
TOM UMBERG. AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SORRY TO HELP MY BACK
TO YOU SENATOR. FOR ALLOWING
THE COOK CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
COUNT SINCE TWENTY TWENTY
OFFICE PRESENT TODAY. I'M TIAS
CATARGIU DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORT TO ENSURE A
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE COUNT OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS. I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY TEAMMATES OR DID
BUT THIS IS THANK YOU SHOULDN'T
CONNECT THE NAME WITH THAT THIS
IS MARTHA THE MINGUS. SHE IS
OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS AND MEDIA RELATIONS FOR
THE COMPLETE COUNT OFFICE ON.
REPRESENTING OUR RECENTLY
SELECTED MEDIA CONTRACTOR I'M.
GLAD TO INTRODUCE FROM MARKET
PUBLIC AFFAIRS OF COURSE YOU'LL
KNOW BOBBY A NEWNESS. AT
CAITLYN BECKER AND STACY LIKE
A- SO WE ARE VERY EXCITED I
PERSONALLY VERY EXCITED BECAUSE
I KNOW WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR OVER A YEAR ABOUT OUR
MEDIA CONTRACTOR. HOW WE'RE
HAVING OUR AIR GAME IN LINKING
OUR GROUND GAME WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES WITH OUR
GROUND GAME BECAUSE I THINK WE
THAT. THAT TAKES A LOT OF A LOT
TO MOBILIZE ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE'RE EXCITED. TO WELCOME.
THEM TO SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO INTEGRATE OUR
GROUND EFFORTS AND ENSURE THAT
WE REACH THE HARDEST OF HARDEST
ACCOUNTS. SO WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO PASS IT OFF TO MARTHA
DOMINGUEZ TO DISCUSS THE
STATE'S COMMUNICATION EFFORTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THE
BIGGEST. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR HAVING AS SOME JUST
GONNA WRITE DIED BEEN INTO MINE
TALKING POINTS AND- FIRST OF
ALL WE JUST WANTED TO. MAKE
SURE THAT YOU WERE AWARE THAT
WE'RE FULLY COMPETENT TO AND
FULLY EQUIPPED TO GUIDE DIRECT
IN SUPPORT STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN
OF THIS CALIBER. TO REACH THE
HISTORICALLY UNDER COUNTER
COMMUNITIES. OUR ABILITY TO
PLAN DESIGN DISSEMINATED
EVALUATE EFFECTIVE SOCIAL
CULTURAL COMMUNICATIONS
CAMPAIGN FOR THE BASE AND
ADOPTING INTEGRATED THEORIES.
EVIDENCE BASED MODEL STRATEGIES
TO DELIVER AND DESIGN INFORM
INFLUENCE AND PERSUADE THE
TARGET AUDIENCE IN. PARTICULAR
TO SOME ACTION EVERY AT ASPECT.
THAT JUST COMPLETELY IN THAT
SENSE AS TWENTY TWENTY FORM.
WE'RE FOLLOWING OUR BEST
PRACTICES AND WE'RE SHARING
THESE WITH MERCURY AND THEY
HAVE IT EMBRACE THEM AND THEIR
BREEDING THEM INTO THEIR
EFFORTS. IS TO USE RESEARCH
BASED STRATEGIES AND APPROACHES
FROM DATA FOR ME TO RESEARCH TO
SHAPE. AND DESIGN THE MESSAGING
MATERIALS AND PRODUCTS AND TO
SELECT THE CHANNELS TO DELIVER
IT THE IDEA ON THE MESSAGES TO
THE TARGET AUDIENCE. WE ARE
ALSO TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AND
LEARN AND COMMUNICATE WITH
VARIOUS CULTURES AND
COMMUNITIES AND LEARN THEIR
PRIORITIES. FROM CONVENTIONAL
WISDOM IDEAS AND LANGUAGE FROM
THAT IDEAS ABOUT THAT WE JUST
HEARD FROM THE PANEL BEFORE.
WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO INFUSE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY IN AN
INFORMATION ACCESS SO WE WANT
TO KNOW HOW TO BEST DISSEMINATE
INFORMATION NOT JUST FROM THE
LETTER C. BUT ALSO AND HOW THEY
WILL RECEIVE INFORMATION ON THE
INTERNET ACCESS OR SMARTPHONES.
OR EVEN THE TYPE OF MEDIA
EXPOSURE THAT THEY HAVE WERE
FULLY AWARE THERE WHERE IT. IN
CALIFORNIA VERY DIVERSE WERE
ORAL AND LITERACY HI BUT A
DIFFERENT. GAMBIT IN TERMS OF
HOW INFORMATION IS ABSORBED.
DEVELOPING CULTURAL INCOMPETENT
PRODUCTS AND COLLATERAL
MATERIALS IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE FULLY INVESTED AND WE
WILL BE ANALYZING. THOROUGHLY
TO ENSURE THAT NOT JUST ON THE
AIR GAME BUT THE TRADITIONAL
MEDIA BUT ALSO THE INTERNET
SOCIAL MEDIA FROM WHAT'S UP WE
CHAT FAKE FACEBOOK. AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNELS
THAT ARE. TRADITIONALLY UNDER
REPRESENTED A COMMUNITIES
UTILIZED FROM THE ONE ON ONE
INTERACTIONS FROM THE BUT I'M A
THOUGHT AS THE QUESTION YOU'RE
ASSISTANCE CENTERS AND JUST
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD. OUR NEIGHBOR
ACROSS THE STREET. I'M AND WE
WOULD NOT BE SELF SUFFICIENT
AND WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY WE WILL BE
MEASURING AND EVALUATE EVERY
EFFORT THROUGHOUT THE CAMPAIGN
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN MONITOR
ALL TRENDS AND EVALUATE EVERY
EFFORT TO ENSURE. THAT WE HAVE
THE BEST A VALUABLE INFORMATION
ACROSS ALL COMMUNITIES AND
CULTURES AND CALIFORNIA. WE I
WANT TO GO OVER VERY BRIEFLY ON
HOW WE LANDED HIM WITH MERCURY
WE WENT THROUGH A VERY HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE I REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL. WE HAD A SENSE AS
EVALUATION TEAM OF SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS THAT WERE ABLE
TO REVIEW ALL THE PROPOSALS AND
IN THAT PROCESS IT WAS
DETERMINE THE MERCURY PUBLIC
AFFAIRS WAS AN IDEAL PARTNER
NOT JUST FOR OFFICE BUT ALSO
FOR CALIFORNIA. AFTER THE
NOTICE OF INTENSE WE WENT IN
THROUGH CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS
WHEN WE REVIEWED MERCURY'S
PROPOSALS. A LOT OF THE IDEAS
AND DELIVERABLES MORE ENHANCE
THE CENSUS OFFICE DETERMINE
THAT MERCURY'S PROPOSAL
PROVIDED THE BEST VALUE FOR THE
STATE BOTH IN TERMS OF APPROACH
AND COST. AS OF JULY TWENTY
NINTH. AGREES CONTRACT WAS
FULLY EXECUTED FOR FORTY SIX
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS AND
SINCE IT'S DAY MERCURY HAS
DEMONSTRATED THE REASONS WE
SELECTED AN AVID DYNAMIC AND
ENERGETIC CULTURE RESPONSE A
PARTNER. TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE OFFICE BUT ALSO WITH
CALIFORNIA. ALONG WITH MERCURY
WE WILL. WE ARE READY TO
EDUCATE MOTIVATE AND ACTIVATE
ALL COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
THE HEART ACCOUNT COMMUNITIES
TO ENSURE THEY PARTICIPATE ARE
EDUCATED AND WELL INFORMED AT
THE CENSUS TWENTY. AND A VERY
TANGIBLE AND PRACTICAL MATTER.
AND THE INTROVERT TIME AS WE'RE
GETTING MERCURY UP TO SPEED OUR
OFFICE HAS ALSO BEEN PROVIDING
OUR FUNDING PARTNERS AND LOCAL
PARTNERS EVIDENCE BASED
RESOURCE INFORMATION SUCH AS
THIS. RESOURCE TOOL WHICH WE
HAVE SHARED WITH YOU GUYS THAT
HAVE STANDARDIZED MESSAGES AND
THE HAS BEEN DISSEMINATED TO
ENSURE CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED. WE
HAVE ALSO DEVELOP A WEBSITE AND
EIGHTY A COMPLIANCE TO ENSURE
FUNDING PARTNERS CAN RETAIN
UPDATES LATEST INFORMATION AND
COMMUNICATE. VARIOUS EVENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. WE HAVE ALSO
BEEN VERY TANGIBLE AND
PRACTICAL AND ENGAGING WITH
EARNED MEDIA TO ESTABLISH
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES ARE THEM
AND ALSO IN LONG GATOR MESSAGES
ACROSS THE STATE. WE HAVE ALSO
BEEN STABBED MACHINE VARIOUS
PARTNERS AND SOME OF THE PANELS
THAT YOU'VE HEARD PREVIOUS OUR
OUR SOME OF OUR PARTNERS BUT
ALSO TO CROSS SHARE. BEST
PRACTICES FOR COMMUNITIES TO
ENSURE INFORMATION TO SHARE AT
VARIOUS LEVELS AND TO MEET THE
CONSUMERS WHERE THEY'RE AT.
SUCH AS THE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY DOES THE DESIRE TO
HAVE ORAL INFORMATION THE
THOUGHT ABOUT HAVING FOUR
NOVELLAS IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE- LOOKING AT TWO SO WE CAN
DUPLICATE ACROSS THE STATE. WE
HAVE ALSO ENGAGE WITH THE LGBT
COMMUNITY TO AND THEY HAVE ALSO
REMINDED US THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCLUDING HOMELESS YOUTH AND
ALSO INCLUDING THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY. WE'VE ALSO BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE WITH THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
THEY HAVE REMINDED US A
CRITICAL ROLE OF FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ALONG WITH PRINT
MEDIA. WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY
NOT ONLY DO ARE WE WERE
REMINDED BUT WE HAVE ALSO
ENGAGE WITH VERY IS IMMIGRANT
AND DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE'RE
REMINDED AT THAT HOW DIVERSE
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES ARE.
NOT JUST FROM MEXICO OR CENTRAL
AMERICA BUT ALSO FROM AFRICA
ASIA AND RUSSIA. OUR PARTNERS
HAVE EQUIPPED AS WITH THE
COMMUNITY GATEKEEPERS TO ENSURE
MESSAGES CAN BE DISSEMINATED
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE WE WANT
TO BE EFFECTIVE ACROSS THE
CAMPAIGN YOU WANNA BE SCIENCE.
SCIENCE SPACE BUT ALSO
CULTURALLY CONGRUENT WE'RE NOT
JUST GONNA BE TRANSLATING ITEM
WE WANT. TO LEARN HOW THE
COMMITTEE BASS HE RESPOND TO
INFORMATION. SO WITH THAT I'M
PASSAGE TO MISTER AUDIBLE FROM
YET MILLIONS. WITH THE YES WILL.
I WAS GONNA SAY MISTER CHAIR
BUT THERE VARIAS CHAIRS OF THIS
COMMITTEE SAWYER STATE CHAIRS
IN THE US AND THE PEARL AND A
FLORAL AND ALSO TO ALL OF THE
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THIS
ALL BI CAMERAL OR SUBCOMMITTEE
DOING WHAT I BELIEVE IS SOME OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT WORK ON THAT
WILL HAPPEN IN AND TWENTY
I KNOW FOLKS MAY ON MY TEAMMATE.
LET ME A LITTLE BIT BUT MAYBE
MOVE AWAY A LITTLE BIT FROM MY
NOTES TO. ADDRESS JUST FIRST
THE CAN A CONTEXTUAL OF A
QUESTION IN TERMS OF HOW WE
APPROACH THIS WORK. UP BUT ALSO
TO IN THE PROCESS IF I QUIT AND
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED. I
KNOW THAT OF FOR EXAMPLE.
ASSEMBLYMAN JONES JONES SAWYER
REYES AND FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE.
ALL THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN. BOB
IN CERTAINLY THE LAST SEVERAL.
ALL SINCE THIS CAMPAIGN IT'S
NOT IN THE LAST THREE OR FOUR
DECADES. WHICH HE MENTIONED
WHICH IS THE QUESTION OF FEAR.
IN THE TWO THOUSAND CENSUS WE
HAD A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT.
THAT WAS RELATIVELY FRIENDLY TO
CALIFORNIA. RELATIVELY FRIENDLY
TO OF. VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
RELATIVELY FRIENDLY TO MULTI
CULTURAL OF A COMMUNITIES WE
FACE A DIFFERENT REALITY TODAY
THAN WE DID IN TWO THOUSAND BUT
THAT WAS UNDER OF PRESIDENT
CLINTON. OUR AND YET IN TWO
THOUSAND THERE WAS A LOT OF
MISTRUST OF THE OF THE
GOVERNMENT AT THEIR TENDS TO BE
OUR DURING THE COURSE OF
HISTORY. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN WE HAD THE PRESIDENT OBAMA
WHO WAS WIDELY SUPPORTED IN
CALIFORNIA BY BOB. FOLKS ACROSS
THE ACROSS THE POLITICAL A
GEOGRAPHIC SPECTRUM YET THERE
WAS STILL A LOT OF MISTRUST
WHEN IT CAME TO THE SENSES IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN DESPITE THE
GREAT WORK THAT THE US AND THE
CENSUS CAMPAIGN DID IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BOB THAT
WAS THE FIRST TIME CALIFORNIA
DIDN'T GROW IN TERMS OF OUR
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION. THAT
WAS TWO THOUSAND AND TEN BUT
YET WE DID AN EXTRAORDINARY JOB
THE STATE DID IN DOING A UP THE
BEST JOB I COULD TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY WAS ADEQUATELY
COUNTED IN THE CENSUS THE
DIFFERENCE RIGHT NOW IS THAT
THE POLITICAL STAKES ARE MUCH
HIGHER AND NOT TO TURN THIS
INTO A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN
BECAUSE IT'S NOT. BUT CERTAINLY
ONE CAN'T SIMPLY JUST READ
BETWEEN THE TEAMS WE HAVE TO
TAKE THIS ON THIS ISSUE ON HEAD
ON AND THE ISSUE IS THAT THE
LEVELS OF FEAR PARTIAL
HEIGHTENED. IN THE VERY IS
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN THAT
ARE TYPICALLY UNDERCOUNTED BUT
ALSO WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUTSIDE
OF THE UNDERCOUNT CATEGORY ARE
JUST YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
WHETHER IT'S A LATINO IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY WHETHER IT'S THE ARAB
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY THERE'S
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES INSIDE A
CALIFORNIA FOLKS. HAVE
DIFFERENT DEGREES OF FEAR.
WHERE IT RELATES TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO. ALL OF A
SENATOR OUR IN OUR LOVE SAYING
THIS IN THIS CONTEXT THAT
SENATOR RUSSELL SO RIGHTLY SAID
IN HER COMMENTS THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SHIFT FROM
THE NEGATIVE TO THE POSITIVE
AND HOW YOU JUXTAPOSE THAT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY IN TODAY'S DAY
AND AGE IS THAT WHILE THERE IS
A LACK OF TRUST FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT IT GOES MUCH
DEEPER THAN THAT IT'S A LOT OF
FEAR TOWARDS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THE PART OF MANY
OF THE VULNERABLE COMMUTERS IN
CALIFORNIA THERE SEEMS TO BE A
GROWING AMOUNT. OF SUPPORT FOR
THE STATE. THE CALIFORNIA HAVE
FOR BOB THE POLITICAL.
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES INSIDE OF
THE STATE OF FOR MANY REASONS
SOME WHICH ARE ARE VERY OBVIOUS
TO PEOPLE. SO WHAT DOES THAT DO
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR US AS
WE COME INTO INTO THIS CAMPAIGN.
YOU KNOW THERE WAS A
CONVERSATION EARLIER TODAY.
ABOUT WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE TO
HAVE A STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN THAT
ULTIMATELY BRANDS ITSELF BUT
THE STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN VERSES
DOING THE MICRO OF MESSAGING
WITH AUTHENTIC OF MESSENGERS
THE PEOPLE TRUST. AND I WOULD
SAY TO YOU THAT WE NEED TO DO
BOTH OF THOSE ONE DOESN'T.
DOESN'T WORK WITHOUT THE OTHER.
ALL THE BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
WORK THAT WE'RE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT DOING HERE. THE
QUESTION THAT SENATOR LAWCENTER
USED TO BE SENATOR PADILLA BUT
NOW ARE. SECRETARY PRETTY UP
MAKE MENTION WITH RESPECT TO
HOW WE ADDRESS THIS QUESTION OF
THIS INFORMATION AND
MISINFORMATION. YOU KNOW THAT
COULD PRESENT ITSELF AS TEN
MAYBE FIFTEEN MAYBE 20% OF THE
PROBLEM WE'RE PREPARED AND HAVE
A STRATEGY. ALL THAT IS BEING
DEVELOPED AS WE SPEAK AND
COULDN'T. IN EFFECT
INTELLIGENTLY TALK ABOUT IT
TODAY IF YOU WANTED TO ALTHOUGH
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH OF THIS
YOU YOU YOU WANT TO BE OUT IN
THE IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN. THAT
I THINK THAT WE'RE VERY WELL
PREPARED FOR US TO DEAL WITH
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION IN A WAY IN
WHICH HELPS US UP TOWNER OF
THOSE MESSAGES BOB WHETHER IT'S
IN THE DARK WEB OR WHETHER IT'S
YOU KNOW ONCE IT GETS. TO THE
VARIOUS SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
OR. IT GOES PUBLIC WITH THE
MORE TRADITIONAL MEDIA. HOW TO
COUNTER ALL THAT THERE'S A
WHOLE STRATEGY TO DO THAT NOW
WE DON'T WANT THAT TO TAKE A
100% OF THE EFFORT BECAUSE YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE PLAYING.
DEFENSE RIGHT WE WANT TO BE WE
WANT TO HAVE A POSITIVE
CAMPAIGN BUT THE POSITIVE
CAMPAIGN HERE IS THE FACT THAT.
BOB BUT PEOPLE ARE MORE WILLING
THAN EVER. TO GET TO BE ENGAGED
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
PEOPLE ENGAGE WE OUGHT NOT
TREAT. UP CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
THIS VICTIMS EVEN THOUGHTHERE
ARE VICTIMS NO NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT WE NEED TO TREAT THEM
AS AGENTS OF CHANGE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT. GIVEN THE WAY
WE'RE APPROACHING THIS CAMPAIGN
WE'RE APPROACHING IT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE. AND CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING DEEPER INTO
DETAIL WITH YOU ON ON SOME OF
THE TACTICS AND HOW WE SEEK TO
EMPLOY THIS THOSE TACTICS
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO MEDIA
BUYS BECAUSE I THINK I HEARD
THAT QUESTION BEING REYES AND
COURSE STACY WAS SITTING OUT
THERE. WANTED TO JUMP IN ANSWER
THE QUESTION BEFORE WAS
ACTUALLY HER TURN. SO I WILL I
DO WANT TO I DO WANT TO TURN
TO. CAROLINE BACKER AND YOU SEE
ON THE FOR MORE INPUT ON THAT
BUT ALSO TO SAY. THIS ABOUT
BOTH OF THEM. I MEAN CAROLINE
HAS BEEN. COVERING ALL OF THE
CENSUS ACTIVITIES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS. ALL BEFORE WE EVEN KNEW
THAT WE WERE IN PLAY FOR THIS
CALL. OR THAT THIS R. F. P. WAS
WAS HAD BEEN PUT OUT IN. THE TO
THE MATTER IS THAT YOU KNOW FOR
ALL OF US AND BURKE THREE.
CERTAINLY MERCURY CALIFORNIA
THIS IS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY. THERE'S NOTHING THAT
WE'RE DOING THAT IS MORE
pWORKING AND STACY. IF I WERE TO
DESCRIBE THIS AS IT IS AS AS I
DO IN THE TERMS THAT I THINK
OF. CAROLINE IS MORE LIKE THE
CAMPAIGN MANAGER STACY IS THE
CAMPAIGN STRATEGIST. BOB AND I
WILL TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE. A
FORMIDABLE TEAM OF PEOPLE ARE
THAT ARE READY TO DO THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. SO THAT
WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF THE
ACCOUNT WHEN IT HAPPENS. SO I'D
LIKE TO TURN OVER START FIRST
TO A PARENT. Q. FAR BEYOND AND
THANK YOU. CHAIRPERSON BERMAN
AND CHAIR SENATE. AND TOP
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK WITH YOU OPENLY
AND WITH THE PUBLIC AND HEAR
FROM YOU ALL I'M HERE FROM THE
PUBLIC AS WELL AS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED AND DO THIS BEFORE
HIM I'M CAROLYN BACKER I'M
BASED HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND I
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON SINCE THIS
RELATED ACTIVITIES FOR OUR FOR
QUITE SOME TIME I GEARING UP
FOR THIS VERY MOMENT AND TWENTY
TWENTY AS WELL. OUR GOAL IS
YOUR GOAL WE SHARE THE SAME
GOAL IS ALL ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHICH IS TO GET COUNTED. SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION IN CONGRESS AND
ACCESS TO SUCH A CRITICAL
PROGRAMS IN COMMUNITIES UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. SO WE SHARE
YOUR OBJECTIVES AND WE TOO ARE
HERE TO HELP. WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF OUR TEAM AND AT REALLY THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE. YOU'VE HEARD A LOT. OF
TALK TODAY WHICH WE WILL ADD TO
ABOUT THE INTEGRATED AND
BLENDED APPROACH. I ALSO WANT
TO TAKE JUST A MOMENT TO TALK
ABOUT THE WORD MEDIA I KNOW
IT'S COME UP A LOT. WE
REFERENCE ETHNIC MEDIA A LOT
BUT WE ALSO REFERENCE MULTI
CULTURAL MEDIA. BECAUSE ARE
HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. REPRESENT VARIOUS
ETHNICITIES BUT THEY ALSO
REPRESENT. CHILDREN AGES ZERO
TO FIVE. VETERANS THE EIGHTY A
COMMUNITY WHICH TAKES ON MANY
DIFFERENT FACES. HOMELESS YOU
KNOW I COULD GO ON WE HAVE
MEDIA PARTNERS THAT HAVE BEEN A
PART OF OUR TEAM. SENSE BEFORE
THIS RP WAS OUT AND CERTAINLY
WERE WITH US. AT THE TABLE IN
REAL TIME WHEN WE WERE PUTTING
A PLAN TOGETHER. TO PRESENT TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE
DO HAVE VISIONS FOR ROBUST AIR
GAME IF YOU WILL TO COMPLEMENT
THE ACTIVITIES ALREADY ON THE
GROUND I ALREADY UNDER WAY ON
THE GROUND. WE HAVE A TEAM OF
WHAT WE CALL MICRO MEDIA
REGIONAL TEAM LEADS WHO ARE IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE CUT
THAT COMPRISE THE TEN REGIONS
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BUILDING A PLAN THAT
INTEGRATES BOTH OF THEM. AS
CHAIRPERSON BERMAN MENTIONED
THERE IS NO TIME FOR A
HONEYMOON PERIOD WE'VE ROLLED
UP OUR SLEEVES QUITE LITERALLY
AND GOTTEN TO WORK AND WE HAVE
ATTENDED AN I. P. W. JUST LAST
WEEK AND SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES. SO WE'RE EAGER AND
ALREADY UNDER WAY HEARING FROM
THE STATE'S CONTRACTED PARTNERS
AND OTHERS I. PERSONALLY I'VE
BEEN ON THE RECEIVING END OF A
LOT OF INCREASE FROM COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS A CBO'S.
AND WE WANT TO HEAR FROM AS
MANY AS WE CAN BECAUSE THIS IS
REALLY I GROUND UP EFFORT.
SECRETARY PATEA MENTIONED SO WE
ARE IN A PHASE RIGHT NOW OF
DATA AND INTELLIGENCE GATHERING
IN AUGUST. I TO INFORM A
CAMPAIGN THAT THAT IS EVIDENCE
BASED THAT IS CULTURALLY
CONGRUENT AND TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT ALL OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND MORE THAT I
JUST MENTIONED. THAT'S REALLY
OUR OUR OUR APPROACH IS THIS IS
THIS BLEND OF GROUND AND AIR
AND IT COMPLIMENTS WITH THE
STATE CENSUS OFFICES ALREADY
BELTS. AND THEY WORK UNDER WAY
RIGHT NOW IS FOR US TO LISTEN
AND COMPLIMENTS AND NOT
DUPLICATE RESOURCES UNLESS WE
DO SO WITH INTENTION IF THERE
IS A PARTICULAR COMMUNITY THAT
NEEDS. YOU KNOW THAT WHERE
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE REACHING THEM FOR VERY
INTENTIONAL REASON THAT IS OUR
INTENTION IS TO DO EVERYTHING
STRATEGICALLY BUT YET NIMBLY
BECAUSE THIS CAMPAIGN ISN'T
JUST BEING FORMED IN INFORMED
IN THE MONTH OF AUGUST. IT'S
GOING TO BE INFORMED IN REAL
TIME EVERY STEP OF THE WAY ALL
THE WAY THROUGH APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE NON RESPONSE
FOLLOW UP PERIOD AND EVEN
BEYOND INTO INTO THE LATTER
PART OF TWENTY TWENTY WHEN WE
WILL COMPILE ALL KINDS OF
INSIGHTS THAT COULD EVENTUALLY
INFORM THE STATE. IN TEN YEARS
FROM NOW SO WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO BE WORKING IN
PROGRESS AND CONTINUE OUR WORK
AND BUILD A CAMPAIGN AND DESIGN
A CAMPAIGN THAT IS INFORMED.
YOU DO HAVE SOME MATERIALS IN
FRONT BE TODAY THAT GIVE US
SERVE OUR TIME LINE CERTAINLY
RIGHT NOW AND INTO SEPTEMBER
WHEN WE HOPE TO. PUT FORWARD
SOME MEDIA ACTIVITIES SORT OF A
SOFT LAUNCH A FEW WELL INFORMED
BY THE ANALYSIS THAT'S UNDER
WAY RIGHT NOW. THAT WILL
INCLUDE THING WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT WHICH IS WEBSITE THAT
HAS A PASSWORD PROTECTED
PARTNER PORTAL SO SOME OF THOSE
VIDEOS THAT YOU HER GENEVIEVE
TALK ABOUT. HIS TACKLE
COMMUNITY CAN BE SHARED SO THAT.
WE CAN SHARE MATERIALS WORDS.
THERE ARE SO DOES AN A. CBO'S
WHO WOULD LIKE THAT HELP WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD IT. THERE WILL BE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
DOWNLOAD MATERIALS BUT ALSO
UPLOAD MATERIALS SO THAT THERE
IS A SHARING OF BEST PRACTICES
AND RESOURCES AND IT REALLY IS
COLLABORATIVE. FROM THE BOTTOM
UP AND TOP DOWN IF YOU WILL
FROM A STATEWIDE LEVEL BUT
REALLY INFORMED BY A REGIONAL
APPROACH AS WELL. YES WE WILL
HAVE A ROBUST EARNED MEDIA
STRATEGY PAID MEDIA STRATEGY
AND SOCIAL MEDIA STRATEGY BUT
IT WILL CONTINUALLY CHANGE IF
YOU IF YOU TAKE AWAY ONE WORD
FOR ME TODAY IT IS NIMBLE.
BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO CHANGE
IN REAL TIME PARTICULARLY WHEN
THE CENSUS IS LIVE AND WE HAVE
ACCESS TO WHO'S FILLING IT OUT
AND WHO'S NOT. YOU KNOW DOWN TO
THE TRACKS LEVEL WITH THIS IT'S
INCREASE I BELIEVE. DEEP DATA
RESOURCE SO WERE WERE
APPROACHING THIS CAMPAIGN VERY
DIFFERENTLY THAN YOU MIGHT
THINK OF A TRADITIONAL MEDIA
CAMPAIGN AND WE WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT AND ASK QUESTIONS AS
YOU HAVE THEM. MISINFORMATION
AND PERMISSION IS A BIG PART OF
OUR TEAM IT'S A BIG PART OF OUR
PLAN. TO CLARIFY MISINFORMATION
IS USUALLY DEFINED AS PERHAPS
SOMETHING THAT IS RE TWEETED
INADVERTENTLY BY SOMEBODY WHO
DOESN'T NECESSARILY KNOW THAT
THEIR SPREADING. SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT EVIDENCE BASED. THIS
INFORMATION COMES FROM BAD
ACTORS. THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
ATTENTION LATELY UNFORTUNATELY
ON THE DEEP AND DARK WEB AND WE
HAVE ONE OF THE NATION'S TOP
TEAMS IN THE COUNTRY INSIDE
MERCURY. HIGHLY EXPERIENCED IN
ROOTING OUT BAD ACTORS AND AS A
TEAM WE WILL COLLECTIVELY PUT
FORWARD RECOMMENDED RESPONSES
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
TACKLE THOSE SO THAT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE BEING DEVELOPED
RIGHT NOW I KNOW THAT A LOT OF
US WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE TO DO
THAT. I AGREE IT IS THE SAD
REALITY AND WE HOPE TO COME AT
IT BEFORE IT MAKES ITS WAY INTO
THE MAINSTREAM. WE WILL COMBAT
IT. SO WE HAVE BIG PLANS IN BIG
VISIONS BUT WE NEED TO BE
INFORMED BY THE PARTNERS ON THE
GROUND THAT IS KEY TO WHAT WE
WILL BE BUILDING. TRUSTED
MESSENGERS. ARE AS CRITICAL IF
NOT MORE SO THAN THE MESSAGES
I'VE HEARD THAT A FEW TIMES
TODAY AND THAT'S THE KIND OF
MENTALITY THAT WE HAVE
APPROACHING THIS CAMPAIGN. AND
BY THE WAY THE GROUND
ACTIVITIES HAVE BEEN UNDER WAY
FOR SOME TIME RIGHT SO WE WANT
TO BUILD AROUND THEM AND LIFT
THEM UP AND SUPPORT THAT AND
COMPLEMENT THEM. SO WE THANK
YOU RESOURCES THAT YOU HAVE
HELPED GET US HERE TODAY. WERE
VERY PASSIONATE IF YOU CAN'T
TELL AND I THINK YOU WILL BY
THE END OF THIS HEARING ABOUT
THIS WORK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PROJECT THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROJECT. OFFER MERCURY
CALIFORNIA AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. AND I WOULD BE ALSO
REMISS NOT TO GIVE STACY JUST A
FEW MINUTES TO TALK ABOUT. THE
MEDIA ASPECT AS WELL STACEY
COMES WITH A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
FROM TRADITIONAL MEDIA BUT ALSO
AT HAS BROUGHT. A VERY UNIQUE
SET OF EXPERTISE TO OUR TEAM AS
WELL SIXTEEN. I'D LIKE TO
QUESTION ABOUT THE RATES THAT
ARE GOING TO BE PUT FORWARD AS
THE WE HAVE A COMPLEMENT OF THE
ELECTION AND THE CENSUS ROLLING
I THINK THAT WAS IMPORTANT THAT
WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER AND I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT BUT BEYOND
THAT I WAS EXCITED EARLIER. THE
DRESS THAT. AND WE'VE ALREADY
HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR MEDIA
PART. AS WE WENT INTO THIS AS
WELL AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD AS
RECENTLY AS THIS LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS WE HAVE MET WITH OUR
ETHNIC MEDIA PARTNERS AS WELL
AS OUR OTHER MEDIA PARTNERS
THAT ARE GOING TO HELP US REACH
SOME OF THE OTHER POPULATIONS
THAT CAROLINE MENTIONED. I'M
TRADITIONALLY CALMS CONTRACT
YOU WOULD BY MEDIA AND-
NEGOTIATES. THE PLAN FOR A YEAR
THAT'S A TRADITIONAL APPROACH I
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO DO THAT
THIS TIME AND WE'VE BEEN VERY
UP FRONT WITH OUR ETHNIC MEDIA
PARTNERS AS WELL AS OUR OTHER
MEDIA PARTNERS TO SAY LOOK WE
ARE GOING TO PARTNER WITH YOU
BUT WE HAVE TO BE NIMBLE AND
RESPONSIVE AS WE GET INTO THIS
CAMPAIGN. FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS ONE WE WANT TO BE RICH
REACTING IN REAL TIME WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO AND FORMER
CAMPAIGN AS WE GET FEEDBACK
FROM THE COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
WE SEE AS WE GET INTO THAT
COUNT WHO'S RESPONDING AND NOT
RESPONDING. SO I NEGOTIATING IN
ADVANCE WITH OUR MEDIA
COMPANIES WILL TAKE IT WILL
HAPPEN BUT WILL TAKE A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF TURN IT WILL
TAKE OUR TEAMS COLLABORATING
AND SHARING AN ADVANCE WHERE WE
THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE AND
KNOWING THAT MEDIA MAY NEED
DISPATCH WE MAY NEED TO MOVE
FROM ONE LINK MEETING TO AND
BIG AS WERE HAVING A SHORT
CAN'T IN THAT READ. IN THAT
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY SO. YOUR
STAFF ARE YOUR PARTNERS LOOK
INTO THIS WITH A COMMITMENT
THEY HAVE. US THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO THEM. AND IN A WAY
THAT HAS NEVER. PROBABLY
MATERIALIZE IN THE PAST THEY'VE
WORKED ON IT HAND IN HAND WITH
A MERCURY OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS I'M ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS AND ARE COMMUNITIES. AND
THEY SAID THEY HAVE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO US THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO COME UP WITH CREATIVE
WAYS TO IT TO HANDLE THAT
SITUATION AS WE GET INTO NIMBLE
NESS. MOVING OF DOLLARS AND
REACTING IN REAL TIME.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SO ON OUR
YARD CURRY YEAH I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION I WANTED TO KNOW IF
YOU HAVE AN IDEA OF HOW WE USE
WITHIN THE WORLD. WE HAVE
SEVERAL. MULTICULTURAL MEDIA
PARTNERS INCLUDING ONE BY THE
NAME OF ETHNIC MEDIA SERVICES
WHO SERVICE SAYS MIDDLE EASTERN
NATIVE AMERICAN API. LATINO
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA AND HAS FOR YEARS.
SO WE ARE LOOKING AT ALL OF THE
DATA TO SUPPORT THOSE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES AND- OUR
REPRESENTATIVE FROM ETHNIC
MEDIA SERVICES HAS BEEN A PART
OF THAT HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN
CENSUS ACTIVITIES AND DOING
BRIEFINGS ALREADY NOT
SEPARATELY FROM OUR CONTRACT
AND IS IN IS REALLY PLUGGED IN
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
ANALYZING THAT LANDSCAPE WHICH
IS WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
IN AUGUST TO INFORM A GREATER
PLAN TO REACH VERY SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES BUT WE FEEL
STRONGLY THAT WE'VE BROUGHT THE
RIGHT PARTNERS TO THE TABLE TO
HELP US DO THAT. YEAH YEAH. YES
RIGHT. A DIFFICULT TO COUNT
RIGHT I'M GOING TO BE VERY
POSITIVE AND HELPFUL SO I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT PORTION OF
OUR COMMUNITY AS WELL SO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HELP YOU MIGHT
NEED ON THAT BUT I HOPE THAT
YOU'RE REACHING OUT TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND ONE AND ONE
THING TO NOTE ON THAT IS WE DO
HAVE A SURVEY IT SHOULD BE IN
YOUR IN BOXES AND YOUR STAFF'S
IN BOXES AS OF THIS WEEK TO ASK
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE MEDIA AND
SITES THAT YOU HAVE COME ACROSS
IN YOUR DISTRICTS REGARDLESS OF
ETHNICITY OR DEMOGRAPHIC. SO
THAT WE CAN HELP UNDERSTAND HOW
YOU'VE REACHED VOTE HERBAL
POPULATIONS OF ALL ETHNICITIES
BUT ALSO LIFESTYLES RIGHT
ETHNICITIES ONLY MAKE UP A PART
OF THE HARD TO COUNT TO YOUR
POINT THERE'S QUITE A FEW OTHER
DEMOGRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS AND
ACTUALLY AN INDEX THAT MEASURES
HOW HARD SOMEBODY IS TO COUNT
SO I DEFINITELY APPRECIATE AND
SHARE YOUR CONCERN AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IT'S OUR JOB TO
REACH ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
CREATE ALL ALL USE A TERM THAT
JONATHAN USED EARLIER A
SURROUND SOUND SO THAT WE ARE
SHOWING UP IN YOUR FACEBOOK
FEED IN REACHING PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE. NO MATTER WHERE YOU
COME FROM IT ALSO ALONG THE
LINE NOT TO FORGET THERE'S NOT
ALWAYS INTERNET. RIGHT. THAT'S
ONE OF THE HTC DEMOGRAPHIC YES
OVER ONE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHEN YOU SAY THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO DO THE MEDIA HOW THE MEDIA
IS GOING TO GO OUT. LACK OF.
INTERNET SOMETHING JUST THIS IS
A HAD THE- JUST ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT MORE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR QUESTION THE OTHER THING
ABOUT MEDIA IT'S NOT JUST
NECESSARILY ON WHAT MEDIA.
PLACEMENT MEANS ON DIGITAL OR
INTERNET WERE ALSO WERE AWARE
ABOUT DOING OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENT AND THAT MEANS LIKE
THE BILL BOARDS OUT ALSO
LEVERAGING MOVE MOVIE THEATERS
OR- RADIOS OR OTHER SORT OF
TRUSTED MESSENGERS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO. THE PARTNERSHIP AND
I THINK YOU HEARD THIS IN THE
LAST PANEL BUT ALSO WITHIN.
WITHIN THIS PANEL THE
PARTNERSHIP AT THE GROUND LEVEL
IS GOING TO BE SUPER CRITICAL.
AND WE ARE AYE DENNIS AIN'T
THAT LAND AND THOSE TRISTEN
MESSENGERS SO WE CAN HAVE A
MULTI LEVEL APPROACH ON
DISSEMINATING THE INFORMATION.
WE ALSO HAVE HAVE CONNECTED
SOME. EXISTING EFFORTS IN THE
RURAL AREAS IN PARTICULAR WITH.
COUNTY CITIES THAT WE CAN
LEVERAGE AND THEY CAN HELP
DISSEMINATE THAT INFORMATION.
SO IT'S NOT JUST THE I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
ALL. UNDERSTANDING WHEN WE SAY
MEDIA COULD ALSO JUST BE A
BROCHURE IT COULD ALSO BE. A
VIDEO AT A CLINIC OR EVEN AT A
MOVIE THEATER OR BILLBOARD AND
THE STOP SIGN SO WE ARE WANTING
TO BE SUPER. CREATIVE AND HOW
WE DISSEMINATE THAT FOR ME. I
THANK YOU. OKAY IF I ADD
SOMETHING. I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT OUR TEAM DOES HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH OTHER
STATE CONTRACTS I'M LIKE FIRST
FIVE. I'M IN GOING INTO THOSE
RURAL COMMUNITIES SO WE HAVE
TAKEN SPECIAL ATTENTION ANNA.
BUT ON TOP OF THAT I THINK
WHAT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
CRITICAL SPECIALLY AND REGION
ONE AND TWO. IS BEING ABLE TO
LOOK AT HOW WE INTEGRATE WITH
THE GROUNDS. BECAUSE THERE'S OF
THE HEART THAT COUNTS ARE
SPREAD. OUT THEY'RE NOT IN THE
AREA AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
GET OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY. AND
WORK IN A- AIR GAME
TRADITIONALLY WITH PROBABLY
LOCAL RADIO AND A LOT OF THOSE
REGIONS REALLY LOCAL LOCAL
LOCAL. AND THEN ALSO GET INTO
THE GROUND AND REALLY GO IN AND
MAKE A CONNECTION. ON A ON A
ONE TO ONE BASIS AND WE LOOK AT
THAT AS THEM. IT IS THE IN YOUR
URBAN AREAS RIGHT. FAST PICKET
SURE THE RURAL AREAS START NOW.
YOU'LL BE THERE NOT. YEAH YEAH.
THANK YOU GERMAN PAN. THANK YOU
AND AFTER THAT I DO HAVE
SEVERAL QUESTIONS AND AGAIN
FREE **** YOU BEING HERE. FIRST
OF ALL. HE FRETS SO YOU TALKED
ABOUT THEM ON THIS AND SO FORTH
AND THAT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
CAN YOU SPEAK TO I WOULD SAY
THE PURPOSE SO LET'S WAS THAT
YOU HAVE TO FOR WELL YOU HAVE
MORE TO FACE FONG AS A TOO BIG
BROAD PHASES RIGHT SO ONE IS
THE LEAD UP TO THE CENSUS.
RIGHT BECAUSE ALL YOUR CAP PROP
IN THE GROUND. AND THEN. DURING
THE CENSUS AND THAT'S WHERE YOU
GET THE FEEDBACK WHILE THIS
NEIGHBORHOODS REALLY COUNTY
WELL THAT ONE'S NOT WE NEED TO
GET SOME. THAT'S A NUMBER OF
THIS PART NOTHING THAT YOU WILL
BE DOUBLE THE BEGINNING BUT YOU
WON'T HA. DIRECTED ON HIS
PARTICIPATE BECAUSE UNTIL THE
ACTUAL START COUNTING. SO I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS WHAT
PROPORTION RESOURCES THE C.
DOING I GUESS THE- PREP WORK ON
THE GROUND RIGHT TO GETTING
LIKE GETTING EVERYONE READY
THIS IS WHY THIS AT THIS IS
IMPORTANT. THE WHATEVER
STRATEGIES YOU THERE AND THEN
OF COURSE GAME ON. POSTCARDS
ARE OUT NOW WE'RE TAKING THAT
YOU'LL THE RAPID RESPONSE.
DEBBIE SURE WE GET THAT SO CAN
YOU PERHAPS SPEAK ABOUT HOW YOU
THINK YOU NEED TO DISTRIBUTE
THE RESOURCES BETWEEN THOSE
TWO. PHASES ARE THOSE TWO
PARTS. I SHORT IT IT'S A BIT
PREMATURE BECAUSE WE ARE IN
THIS. TO BORROW YOUR WORD PHASE
OF. LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS AND
LISTENING AND UNDERSTANDING THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
UNDER WAY BOB BY THE WAY BOTH
ON THE GROUND AND RAN IN THE
AIR RIGHT YOU HEARD FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT TODAY
ABOUT SOME OF THEIR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH UNIVISION. SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT DEPLOYING AND
ALLOCATING RESOURCES ALL OF
THAT WILL BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
AND THAT'S HAPPENING IN IN REAL
TIME. OKAY SO YOU'RE SENT
BECAUSE THEY ALL TWENTY TWENTY
APRIL FIRST WE DO ENVISION A
BIG DAY I TAKE OVER AT THE
STATEWIDE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
QUITE PREMATURE OBVIOUSLY TO
TALK ABOUT. DOLLARS BUT WE
ENVISION THAT EVERY COMMUNITY
ROB ORAL AND URBAN ALIKE WILL
HAVE SENSES IN THEIR AIR.
CENSUS ON THEIR MOBILE DEVICES
IF THEY HAVE THEM SINCE THIS AT
THEIR COFFEE SHOP IN THE
MORNING. AT THEIR CHURCH OR
PLACE OF WORSHIP SO IT THAT IS
OBVIOUSLY A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. DAY AND PERIOD FOR
THAT REAL TIME RESPONSE BUT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE JUST LOOKING AT
THE LANDSCAPE AND TRYING TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS SO THAT
THEIR INFORMED AND WISE RIGHT
SO THAT IT'S NOT JUST MADE UP.
ALL RIGHT SO HOPEFULLY CAN GET
BACK TO US AS YOUR FIGURED OUT
RATE IS IT I MEAN I'M NOT TALK
ABOUT. I MEAN JUST ROUGHLY LIKE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A QUARTER
AND THREE QUARTERS OF THE HALF
AND HALF TWO THIRDS ONE THIRD
IRATE JUST GET IT. SO YEAH SO I
PART OF OUR PLAN FOR THIS FALL
IS TO REALLY BREAK DOWN SOME OF
THE BARRIERS FEAR HAS BEEN A
WORK FOR HEARING A LICENSE AND
SO. THIS ISN'T A NORMAL CALMS
COMMUNICATION EVEN BEHAVIOR
CHANGE CAMPAIGN THIS IS THAT WE
GOT TO GET UP AND GOING AND GET
PEOPLE COMFORTABLE. AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WHEN WE DO LAUNCH
A LARGER. CAMPAIGN WE'VE
STARTED THE SOFT CONVERSATION.
SOMETIMES THAT IS MORE
EXPENSIVE. RIGHT THEN DOING THE
AIR GAME. THE SO IN THEIR NESTS
AND WHY WE PLAN THOSE OUT. I
WOULD IT WOULD BE REMISS FOR US
TO TELL YOU A PERCENTAGE
BECAUSE- THE REALITY IS THOSE
COSTS WHEN YOU DO THOSE MORE IN
COMMUNITY VERY FOCUSED APPROACH
AS- IT CAN BE MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN DOING A BIGGER BROADER.
BLAST YEAH SO. WE WILL HAVE
THAT HERE VERY SHORTLY ON HOW
THAT WILL ROLL OUT FOR THE
FALL. AND WE WILL MAKE SURE WE
GIVE YOU GUYS THAT KIND OF FLAT
LANDS. BUT I WANTED TO. SHARE
WITH YOU IN A PLANNING PHASE.
HE GREATER THAN THIRTY EVEN
JUST BUYING WELL BY AND I WOULD
IT IS YES FOR EXAMPLE THE FIRST
OFF FARTHER DOWN QUESTION IS
BECAUSE BY THE WAY ONCE YOU'VE
THROUGH PHASE ONE YOUR WRIST
EITHER SPENT THE MONEY OR BEEN
BILLED FOR IT SO I MEAN THEN
YOU'LL HAVE WHATEVER'S LEFT FOR
FACE TO SO. YOU NEED TO THINK
IN ADVANCE ABOUT IT RIGHT. I DO
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
ANYWAYS IF YOU HAVEN'T DONE THE
PREP WORK A LOT OF LAST MINUTE
LIKE YOU CAN BE NIMBLE BUT
YOU'RE YOU CAN'T BE SHOWING UP
FOR THE FIRST TIME AND WELL
THAT COMMUNITY IS NOT
RESPONDING FOR AWHILE NOW WE-
SHOW UP LITERALLY AS YOU KNOW
WE'RE COUNTING DOES NOW SAY
HEY. YOU KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO
COUNT YOU RIGHT I MEAN IF YOU
HAVEN'T DONE THAT WORK UP
FRONT. YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE.
A SO YOU HAVE TO. YOU KNOW SO
OKAY. THE OTHER THING THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD ACTUALLY. IN
TERMS OF INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES
TO WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE
PREVIOUS PANEL PEOPLE TALKED
ABOUT. WELL THOSE MADE
REFERENCE THAT. ACTUALLY YOU
MAY NOT ACTUALLY BE. LESS THEY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE CENSUS
IS THE MAIN TOPIC BUT SORT OF
WORK IT IN RIGHT SO FOR EXAMPLE
DO WE GET CENSUS MESSAGES INTO.
MOVIES ARE COMING OUT OF TIME.
TV SHOWS DO A NOVELLA ABOUT THE
CENSUS RATE OR SOMETHING RIGHT
HAVE THAT BROADCAST OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO. YOU MAY
BE SPEAK TO CONVERSATIONS YOU
MIGHT BE HAVING OUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT THAT AGAIN WE'RE SEVEN
MONTHS OUT SO. PROBABLY IF YOU
WANT TO GET. IN THE VALLEY
PRIDE HAVE TO START FILMING
READY. SO I DO I JUST THE ONE
DAY I CAN I CAN IMAGINE THE
PLOT NOW. I'LL GO AHEAD AND ADD
A COUPLE OF THINGS I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
HEARING ON. IS THAT PEOPLE WANT
TANGIBLE AND PRACTICAL
INFORMATION SO THEY CAN
CONNECTED TO THEIR EVERYDAY
LIVES. ALONG WE ARE ALSO DOING
AMER CREE SUPPORTING US WITH
THIS IS A FIVE PRONG APPROACH
TO REVIEWING ALL THE EXISTING
DATA AND ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT. OUR EXISTING PARTNERS
HAVE COLLECTED. THEY WILL ALSO
HAVE A MESSAGE TESTING THROUGH
OUT AND WE WILL ALSO DO SOME
MESSAGE PAULINE TO ENSURE THAT
THE MESSAGE IS STILL
RESONATING. THE INTEGRATED
APPROACH IS SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVEN'T PLANNED. WE WERE WE
WANT TO IDENTIFY THOSE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS WITHIN THE MEDIA OR
EVEN IN THAT IN TRUMP WHAT WE
CALL THE INTRON LEVEL. WITH%
WHICH COULD BE A DOCTOR OR A
COULD BE A COMMUNITY PROMOTE
THOUGHT OUT OR IT CAN BE A AT.
CITY COUNCIL OR EVEN A PASTOR.
WE. ONE IDENTIFIED THOSE SO
THEY CAN HELP US SORT OF.
COMMUNICATE THAT INFORMATION SO
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND HOW THE
SENSES IMPACTS. WE KNOW THAT
MOMS TRANSPORTATION CHILDCARE
AND SCHOOLS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
MESSAGE. PARTICULAR IT WERE
TRYING TO REACH THE ZERO TO
FIVE. I'M WITH THE HOMELESS
POPULATION HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IS SOMETHING
THAT IS SUPER IMPORTANT. SO WE
NEED TO IDENTIFY AND MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IT'S
QUANTIFIABLE BUT ENSURE THAT
IT'S A CULTURALLY CONGRUENT AND
WHEN WE SEE CULTURING
CONGRUENT. WE MEAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DEVELOP A MESSAGE FOR
THAT ROUTED. COMMUNITY OR THAT
TARGET. OF AUDIENCE. ALSO SAY
WE'RE DOING SAID WE ARE DOING
SOME INTEGRATION SO WE HAVE
SPOKEN TO OUR MEDIA PARTNERS
FOR THEM TO HELP US NOT ONLY
DEVELOP CONTENT AND PROGRAMMING
WITHIN THEIR- THEIR OWNED. AND
OPERATED PROPERTIES WERE ALSO
WORKING WITH BUSINESS
SO WE'RE EXTENDING BEYOND JUST
WHAT THE MEDIA'S GONNA DO FOR
US. FOR EXAMPLE WORKING WITH
HOSPITALS TO BE ABLE TO GIVE AB
PARENTS THAT ARE GOING HOME
WITH NEW BABIES CENTERS THESE
YES EXACTLY CENSUS ONESIES THAT
THEY AYE COUNTS REALLY TRYING
TO. GO DEEPER AND INTEGRATE IN
PEOPLE'S REAL LIVES SO IT WHEN
THEY DO GET THE BIG MESSAGE.
THEY ARE IT'S NOT COLD IT'S NOT
A COLD FIRST TOUCH SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND UNIQUE. AN
ADVANCE THOSE ARE GOING TO
START SEEING IN THE FALL WAYS
OF INTEGRATING OKAY AND THEN I
KNOW I ASK THE QUESTION THE.
PREVIOUS PANEL BUT MADE JUST
BRIEFLY YEAH I SAID. YOUR
SENSES CAN COME IN WITH THEIR
STRATEGY ON A TO WHAT DEGREE
ARE THEY COMMUNICATING WITH YOU
BUT WHAT THEY'RE PLANNING TO DO
SO HOW DO YOU SEE THE
POSITIONING OUR STATE. STRATEGY
IN RELATION TO THE FEDS. WHAT
IS THAT SO WE CONTINUE OF AND
OF COURSE WORKING WITH THEM THE
LAST TWO YEARS ON A NUMBER OF
THINGS. I'M ALL LET THEM DO
MORE THE LOGISTICS AND HOW
THEY'RE COORDINATING OR NOT IN
TERMS OR NOT. IN TERMS OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT SECTOR MIGHT BE
WORKING WITH MARIE TOMATO HE
WAS THE PRODUCER OF EAST LOS
HIGH. WITH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE ANNENBERG INNOVATION LAB SO
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY WE'VE BEEN
REALLY DOWN IN LA WE'VE MET
WITH THE WRITERS GUILD
DIRECTORS' GUILD REALLY TRYING
TO. FIGURE OUT HOW TO PLACE TO
PLACE IT IN TWO OF THAT AREA
THAT REALLY WANTS TO DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY REALLY
DO WANT TO DO SOMETHING. YOU
KNOW TERMS OF NOVELLAS ONE OF
THE THINGS THERE'S ALWAYS THAT
THAT SOAP OPERA CHARACTER THAT
IS UNEMPLOYED. AND SO THEY
TALKED ABOUT BRINGING THEM IN
AS A NUMERATOR ALL YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW. YOU GOT A JOB RATE LIKE
IN THESE AND SO THEN THAT THEY
WERE LIKE WEAVING THAT INTO
THAT SO. AT THE CENSUS BUREAU'S
TALKING ABOUT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL AND WE'RE TRYING TO
PARTNERS IS THAT HERE IN AND LA
BUT- WE ALSO HAVE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH A LOT OF. THE A Y. IN OUR
TEAM AND THEN THEY'RE GONNA
DEEP IN IT NOW THAT YOU KNOW.
THAT I DON'T NEED TO BE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THAT AND THEN BE ABLE
TO COURT. OKAY WHY ARE YOU
YOUNG AND RUBICAM HAD THE FIFTH
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS CONTRACT
AND WE HAVE PARTNERS AS PART OF
OUR- CONTRACT WHO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE MEDIA PLANNING AND-
STRATEGY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE AGAIN ONLY DUPLICATING
EFFORTS WHEN INTEND WHEN
INTENDED. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ACCESS TO SOME OF THE
COLLATERAL MATERIAL THAT THE.
US CENSUS BUREAU HAS PUT
FORWARD. HE CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO WORK IN A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES SO WERE. IN
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR PARTNERS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO TALK
ABOUT THAT. THE WAY THE TERM
HARD TO COUNT IS DEFINED
DIFFERENTLY AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THAN IT IS AT THE- STATE
LEVEL. SO THESE ARE THE
INSIGHTS THAT WE'VE MADE SURE
TO HAVE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
ON AS PART OF OUR TEAM SO THAT
WE CAN BE INFORMED. OKAY AND
THEY'LL BE WORKING THROUGH WITH
US THROUGHOUT THE CAMPAIGN IT'S
NOT JUST AT THE BEGINNING THEY
ARE GOING TO BE WORKING WITH US
ALL THE WAY THROUGH SO THAT WE
MAKE SURE WHEN WE RESPOND. IT'S
RELEVANT AND NOT CONFUSING AS
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER AND
EIGHTY. YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
TAKING A WHILE. THE SURF FILED
MORE COMMENTS AND BECAUSE WE
ONLY A PREVIOUS HEARING WAS
FOCUSED A LOT ON LANGUAGE
OBVIOUSLY THIS INVOLVES
LANGUAGE. THE API COMMUTERS
MANY MANY DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
BY THE WAY WE ALSO THINK ABOUT
ALL THE VARIOUS OTHER
COMPANIES. HOW WE CAN MAKE A
PEOPLE'S ABILITIES. OTHERS SO.
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO
ABOUT. DOING THIS I CERTAINLY
HEARD. FROM TO BE STABLE MIKE.
ARE GETTING IN OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS BECAUSE OF THEY CAN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE MESSAGES
ARE. ANYWHERE AND OUT OF AND
HOW IT'S CONNECTING IN. SO THAT
CERTAINLY. WHICH ONE. ABOUT
THIS THIS GOES ON. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN. QUESTION. DESERVE
STATEWIDE COORDINATOR FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. DIFFERENT QUESTION
BUT ONE ISSUE THAT A LOT OF
CONTRACT PARTNERS HAVE BROUGHT
UP. IS THE DIFFICULTY THAT THEY
FACE MAKING PLANNING AND
BUDGETARY DECISIONS ON MEDIA
WHEN THEY DON'T KNOW. HOW MUCH
THE STATEWIDE MEDIA CONTRACTORS
GOING TO INVEST IN THEIR REGION
IT SOUNDED LIKE MAYBE FALL.
WHICH IS WHICH IS RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER YEAH TIMING FACTORED
IN VARIOUS HIGH YEAH THAT WE
WILL BE I GOT BEING AT AN
EXECUTIVE REPORT ON ALL OF OUR-
DATA GATHERING THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT OUR RESEARCH. THAT WE
PULL TOGETHER FROM ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS AND EVERYTHING THAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING OVER THE
LAST. I'D SAY TWELVE MONTHS.
AND THEN WILL USE THAT TO APPLY
HOW WE'RE GOING TO IMPLEMENT
THE MEDIA FOR IMMEDIATELY INTO
THE FALL. I AM. I WOULD SUSPECT
AS WE LEAVE SEPTEMBER OCTOBER
AND WE GET INTO NOVEMBER. WE
WILL BE ABLE TO BE EVEN MORE
INTEGRATED WITH OUR THE GROUND
GAME. THEY ARE IN THEIR
PLANNING STAGES WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY ARE WORKING ON THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS THAT ARE
DUE ON OCTOBER. OUR GOAL IS TO
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM.
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WE
WON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS. BUT
WE WILL HAVE ENOUGH FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO BE RESPONSIBLE OVER
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS GREAT. AND
SPEAKING OF COORDINATION GOT A
WITH THE FOLKS IN THE DIFFERENT
REGIONS AND ON THE GROUND. A
LOT OF STATE PARTNERS HAVE BEEN
USING THEIR BRANDS FOR MONTHS
ALREADY I KNOW THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING IN MY DISTRICT. I
THINK IS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
MAYBE ALSO SAN MATTEO COUNTY
ACROSS BEEN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
MANY OF THEM A BRANDING THAT'S
ALREADY WELL KNOWN IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WALL SOME OF THEIR
BRANDING OUR STYLES HAVE TO BE
MODIFIED. TO SYNC WITH THE
STATE OR BRANDING THEY'LL BE
DEVELOPED AND AS MERCURY HAVE A
PLAN EVERY BRAND. THE STATE'S
CURRENT LOGO SEN SEWED SO NOT
MODIFIED WHAT WERE WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS DEVELOP A BRAND AND WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING SO
RIGHT NOW. THAT THAT CAN BE
ADAPTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IF
NEEDED. BECAUSE THERE ARE
VARYING DEGREES OF NEED AND
DESIRE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
INCLUDING SOME WHO WANT A
BRANDT RIGHT HANDED TO THEM.
AND WERE WERE HAPPY TO DO THAT
BUT IT'S OUR CHALLENGE IN OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A BRAND.
THAT IS A STATE WIDE BRAND BUT
ALSO ADAPTABLE AND NOT
DISRUPTIVE TO THE BRANDS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN CREATED YOU
MENTIONED SEEING IN YOUR OWN
DISTRICT. SO THAT'S UNDER WAY
AS WE SPEAK AND WERE TALKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS ON THE GROUND
ABOUT WHAT THAT COULD LOOK LIKE
AND HOW IT COULD BE ADAPTABLE.
YOU KNOW CERTAIN COLORS DON'T
MATCH OTHER COLORS AND WE WANT
TO. GIVE THEM OPTIONS SO THAT
WE'RE NOT DISRUPTING OR
MODIFYING TO BORROW YOUR WORD.
OF GOOD BROWN'S THAT ARE
ALREADY OUT THERE AND- GREAT. I
DON'T SAID THAT BY THE WAY I
THINK I ALSO. I DO THINK THAT
GIVING. THE THERE IS A NEED.
AND WILL BE A NEED TO HAVE.
OVERARCHING THEMES THAT
ULTIMATELY THE STATE CAN RALLY
BEHIND AS A WHOLE. BECAUSE THE
MESSAGE ALL ULTIMATELY. THAT
THE OVERALL MESSAGE TO FOLKS IS
LOOK. YOU CAN BE COUNTED. AND
YOU'RE GOING TO BE OKAY. GOING
TO BE SAFE FOR YOU TO DO IT.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US
NOT TO GET MIXED UP IN TO. THE
DISSECTION OF IT BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY ME WE HELP WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THAT. REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT. BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE NEED TO KEEP OUR
EYES ON THE PRIZE AS WELL SO
THAT AS A WHOLE. OF FOLKS KNOW
THAT THERE'S A THERE'S A
TRUSTED ALLY THAT THEY HAVE IN
THE STATE. THE STATE'S GOT THE
BACK. YEP ABSOLUTELY. WHICH IT
WAS HAS BEEN HARD AT YOU KNOW
WHEN I'VE BEEN MEETING WITH
SOME FOLKS I THROW OUT ALL THE
DIFFERENT. LEGAL WAYS THAT WE
CAN PROTECT PEOPLE AND IT'S
STILL IT DOESN'T RESONATE AND
GIVE THEM THAT CONFIDENCE THAT
THEY NEED. SO THAT'S GOING TO
BE A CRITICAL. KIND OF HURDLE.
TO CROSS. SO I THINK CAROLYN IT
MENTIONED THE SURVEY. THAT WENT
OUT TO OUR OFFICES THE ETHNIC
MEDIA. SURVEY IT HAS IS GOING
OUT ALSO TO THE LOCAL. CBO'S
AND ANY CBO'S AND A VERY
SIMILAR VERSION OF THAT THEY
OBVIOUSLY HAVE QUESTIONS MORE
ABOUT THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
UNDER WAY. WITH WITH RESPECT TO
THE CENSUS. WERE DEVELOPING NOT
AND THAT'S PART OF OUR
LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS AND
FOUNDATION BUILDING PERIOD
PERFECT AND THEN WHAT'S THE
BEST WAY WE HEAR A LOT. FROM
FROM DIFFERENT. WELL IT
ORGANIZATIONS OR INDIVIDUALS
WHO SAY I'VE GOT THIS IDEA
ABOUT THIS INTEL I'VE GOT THIS
YOU KNOW HOW DO I GET THIS TO.
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE AT THE TOP.
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY FOR OUR
CBO'S OR ON YOUR DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY. LEADERS TO BE ABLE
MARKET WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
HERSELF. AS I'VE BEEN GIVING
YOU KNOW. PERSONAL EMAILS WHAT
I HAVE GOT TO PUT THE PHONE
NUMBER THAT IS RIGHT. ACTUALLY
WERE REALLY INTERESTED IN
HEARING ALL THOSE IDEAS AB THE
CENSUS OFFICE HAS DEVELOPED A
COMMUNICATIONS THAT SENSES DOT
CA DOT GOV EMAIL OKAY AND I
WE'VE BEEN SOCIALIZING THAT
EMAIL WE'VE BEEN SHARING THAT
AND THAT'S AVAILABLE TO ANYONE.
M. PUBLIC YOU COULD ALWAYS ALSO
EMAIL ME I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
THOSE BUT THE COMMUNICATIONS
EMAIL AS AS THE BEST WAY FOR
FOLKS TO SUBMIT THEIR
INFORMATION. SO WE CAN TRACK
THAT AND I THINK CAROLINE I'M
TOUCHED UPON AT SOME OF OUR
SOFT LAUNCH THAT SOFT LUNCH
WILL HAVE NOT JUST DOT ORG
WEBSITE BUT IT WILL ALSO HAVE A
PARTNER POLL PORTAL WILL HAVE
A- USER IMPOSSIBLE PASSWORD AT
PROTECTIVE IDENTIFICATION. SO
FOLKS CAN ALSO UPLOAD AND SHARE
INFORMATION AS WELL GREAT WILL
HAVE VARIOUS CHANNELS FOR FOLKS
TO DO THAT GRAY AND THEN TWO
MORE QUESTIONS I'LL TO KEEPING
QUICK. AS OF THE THAT'S BEEN IN
AS USED SPOKE ABOUT THE CAN
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION ISRAELIS AROUND
THAT AND- MAYBE WITHOUT GETTING
TOO MUCH OF THE DETAILS AND
pKNOW WHAT WHAT IS THE STRATEGY
THERE I KNOW I I'VE HAD
MEETINGS WITH FOLKS IN MY
DISTRICT TO. HAVE SCARED THE BE
JESUS OUT OF ME AS TO WHAT
PEOPLE ARE I'M NOT A DIGITAL
EXPERT BUT I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
TURN IT TO EITHER CAROLINE
STACY BUT I I'VE BEEN IN A
NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS WITH.
THE FOLKS THAT ARE DOING THE
WORK ON THIS AND I MEAN TO FEEL.
I THINK EXTREMELY CONFIDENT. OF
THEIR ABILITY. TO BE ABLE TO
COUNTER YEAH THIS THIS TYPE OF.
REALLY ON OUR ABILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE AN ACCURATE
COUNT WITH RESPECT TO THE
STRATEGY ONE WORD IT'S TO
MITIGATE YEAH SO IF THEY'RE
SOMETHING SURFACING IN THE DARK
WEB OR THE DEEP WEB. IT STOPS
BEFORE IT COMES UP TO THE
MAINSTREAM WHERE YOU AND I
MIGHT SEE IT. THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE IT'S
JULY OF TWENTY NINETY FOUR
NUMBER IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN NOW RIGHT SO THERE
WERE LOOKING BACK RIGHT NOW
DOING A WHAT WE CALL A LOOK
BACK PERIOD TO SEE WHAT'S
ALREADY OUT THERE THAT WE HAVE
TO. PREPARE TO MITIGATE BUT
WHEN THE MISINFORMATION
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN IS AT
ITS BEST IS WHEN YOU'RE WERE
FINDING THOSE. AS I SAID
EARLIER BAD ACTORS AND STOPPING
THEM IN THEIR TRACKS BY THE WAY
JUST BY MAYOR EXAMPLE OF. A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WHILE WE WERE
IN ONE OF THESE CONVERSATIONS.
THE ONE OF THE PERSONS IS
WORKING WITH US ON THIS SAID BY
BY THE WAY THERE'S THIS THIS
ENTITY. THAT'S TRYING TO IMPACT
ARE ADVERSELY IMPACT THE
COUNTING CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE
THIS CAMPAIGN GOING ON. AND THE
CITY GO ONLINE IF YOU FIND IN
THIS WHO THEY ARE. BUT TWO DAYS
LATER THE PRESIDENT I'D STATES.
WAS COMPLAIN ABOUT GETTING BAD
PUBLICITY AND THE AND THE
TRADITIONAL MEDIA AND HE SAID
IF YOU WANT TO GO TO A REAL
SOURCE FOR INFORMATION WHICH
THE SOURCE. CODE THAT GO TO
THIS ONE AND IT WAS THE SAME.
SITE YEAH THAT WAS PROMOTING
THIS SO THAT'S THE TYPE OF
THING THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
AND CERTAINLY FOLKS ARE GOING
TO BE ON THE GROUND. YOUR
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SOME PEOPLE
USE FOR LITTLE ROBOTS TO DO
THIS. BUT THEY USE ROBOTS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THAT SIR SO OUR
VIEW IS GOING TO BE PEOPLE ON
THE GROUND WORKING TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. TO MITIGATE THAT
INFORMATION AND ALSO ON THAT
PORTAL. YEAH AS THE
MISINFORMATION YEAH ALSO ON
THAT PORTAL AS FOLKS THAT ARE
WORKING ON THE GROUND WITH THE
B. C. B. O. TO OTHERS. THEY CAN
GO ON THAT PORTAL AND SAY HEY I
LEARNED OF THIS AND THEN OUR
TEAM CAN. ATTACK THAT
IMMEDIATELY. THE IDEA TO IS TO
USE A TEN FOUR MESSAGE. SO YES
IT IS TO MITIGATE YES IT IS TO
GET AHEAD OF THINGS AND TO GET
INFORMATION FROM THE GROUND BUT
IT'S THAN FOR US TO SAY OKAY
WHAT DO WE NEED TO BE
ADDRESSING. BECAUSE SOMETIMES.
IF IT'S NOT MALICIOUS IT'S JUST
SOMEBODY SHARING SOMETHING THAT
THEY THOUGHT WHAT'S TRUE. AND.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE NOT
EVERYBODY'S OUT THERE TO HURT
THEY JUST THINK THEY'RE SHARING
SOMETHING THAT'S FACTUAL. WE
WANT TO HAVE MAKE SURE THAT WE
THEN TAKE THAT INFORMATION AND
UTILIZE IT AS A TOOL TO
EDUCATE. IN A WAY THAT'S
POSITIVE AND HELPS SURE THE
RIGHT INFORMATION THE KIND
WHERE IS A CONFUSION OUT THERE
YEAH AND WE GET A HELL YEAH.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MISS AND
DEATH YEAH YEAH AND THEN AND A
SOMETHING THAT I'VE HEARD FROM
FOLKS BACK IN THE DISTRICT IS
THE INPUT AND I'D REPRESENT.
GOOGLE AND YOUTUBE AND SOME IS
I COMPANIES. IS THE IMPORTANCE
OF PUSHING OUT POSITIVE
ACCURATE MESSAGING EARLIER. SO
THAT WHEN THEIR ALGORITHMS YOU
KNOW WHEN PEOPLE SEARCH FOR
CERTAIN THINGS. THOSE POP UP
HIGHER. YOU KNOW AHEAD OF TIME
SO NOT EVEN YOU KNOW NOT
NECESSARILY WAITING UNTIL THE
LAST MINUTE TO GET THAT OUT TO
GETTING THAT OUT EARLY SO THAT
IT'S ALREADY COUNTY CUED UP.
WITH THEIR ALGORITHMS SO THAT
THAT THAT'S WHAT THE SEARCH
RESULTS FIND. LAST QUICK
QUESTION SO I KNOW THE SERVICE
THAT CURRENT CENSUS WEBSITE.
INCLUDES A CHAT BOT THAT
PROVIDES HELPFUL INFORMATION TO
THE PUBLIC. DOES MERCURY
PLANNED INCLUDED CHAT BOT
FEATURE. I GUESS THE CURRENT
ABOUT THE ONLY. PROVIDES THIS
ISN'T AN ENGLISH DO FUTURE
PLANS INCLUDE MAKING THIS
FEATURE AVAILABLE IN OTHER
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN JUST
ENGLISH AND POSSIBLY SPANISH SO
RIGHT NOW WE ARE AND AT
TECHNOLOGY REVIEW THAT POT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS WERE
REVIEWING AND HOW DO WE
INCORPORATE THAT BOUGHT FROM
THE STATE SITE TO THE MORE
CONSUMER CAN'T CAMPAIGN
COMMUNICATIONS. I AND WE WILL
DO THAT WE WILL HAVE A BOT AND
IT WILL BE AND IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES I'M AND IT FELT GOOD
NEWS AS THE BOX GET SMARTER. HE
IS THE IF IT'S AS GOOD AS THE
INFORMATION YOU PUT IN IT SO WE
HAVE A STRATEGY THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON RIGHT NOW ON HOW TO
BUILD OUT NOW. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO REVIEW THAT
PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY AND HOW
TO INTEGRATE IT AS WE LAUNCH
THE WEBSITE IN SEPTEMBER GREAT.
TO FOLKS ON THE GROUND PROVIDE
INPUT ON THAT OR IS OUR PROCESS
FOR THAT YEAH ABSOLUTELY I MEAN
THAT IF YOU MEAN CAN THEY SHARE
WITH US QUESTIONS THE QUESTIONS
OR WHAT THEY THINK WOULD BE
HELPFUL THERE ARE. ONLY THE
MORE INFORMATION WEEKEND. I
MEAN IT WAS NICE YESTERDAY
GOING TO AN EVENT WHERE I
BASICALLY ASKED LET PEOPLE ASK
QUESTIONS YEAH AND IT HELPS ME
WALK AWAY FEELING MORE INFORMED
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN OUR
PLAN TO ASSIST EVERYBODY NOT
JUST THE STATE. YEAH EVERYBODY
IN THIS PROJECT SO I'VE YES THE
MORE INFORMATION. WE CAN GET
THE BETTER GREAT. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN COME LONGER OF.
GREAT THANK YOU IT'S- YOU KNOW
AN HONOR TO SIT ON A SELECT
COMMITTEE WHERE IN YOU ARE
GRACED WITH THE PRESENCE. OF
ONE OF OUR- AMAZING FORMER
SPEAKERS I HOPE WHEN HE CAME IN
YOU ALL DIM THE LIGHTS. WE ONLY
DO THAT AT THE MARK WALK AT THE
CHURCH THE LIVES THAT. AND THEN
TO HAVE HIM HERE AT WITH THE
SURROUNDED BY STRONG
INDEPENDENT THINKING WOMEN GOES
TO SHOW YOU THAT I THINK WE'RE
IN FOR A SUCCESSFUL JOURNEY.
THANK YOU HAD TO GET THAT OUT I
HAD. ONE COMMON INTO QUESTIONS
YOU KNOW LISTENING TO THE
PRESENTATIONS. IT JUST MAKES ME
FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW. WE'RE
EMBARKING ON AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO CALIFORNIA RIGHT WHEN
MOST PEOPLE THINK ABOUT THE
CENSUS IN THE COUNT. YOU THINK
ABOUT IT FROM THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. AND YET WE'RE DOING THIS
IN THE STATE AND SO I'M I'M
WONDERING AND ALSO FEELS LIKE
WE'RE KIND OF GEARING UP TO GO
TO WAR RIGHT. SO THAT'S PRETTY
DISTURBING GIVEN WHAT THE
OUTCOME OF THE CENSUS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT WHICH IS
THE DELIVERY OF FEDERAL
RESOURCES. SO MY ONE QUESTION
WAS HAS THERE BEEN ANY THOUGHT
TO KIND OF HELPING FOLKS SEE
THE SEPARATION BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S ALMOST
LIKE IT'S OUR ACCOUNT OUR
CALIFORNIA WE'RE DOING THIS
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT
OUR STATE RIGHT THAT'S WHY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS THAT'S
WHY WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COUNT IS ACCURATE. SO
HAS THERE BEEN ANY KIND OF
STRATEGIC THOUGHT AROUND HOW TO
HELP PEOPLE SEE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND THEN YOU KNOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
PROACTIVELY AND POSITIVELY SORT
OF WRAP OUR HEADS AROUND. FOLKS
THINK THAT THIS IS THAT IT'S
VERY DIFFERENT WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS WE'RE DOING IT TO GET OUR
FAIR SHARE ARE ALSO DOING IT
BECAUSE IT'S OUR ACCOUNTANTS
ARE CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW IT'S
OUR PEOPLE. I OF WILSHIRE
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION I
ACTUALLY WE ARE ACTUALLY
EXPLORING NOTHING BECAUSE WE DO
KNOW THAT FOR A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES AND IN PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA IS SEEN
AS INSPECTION NO WORRY STATE
AND THEY ACTUALLY DO FEEL SAFE
THEY DO FEEL PART OF CALIFORNIA
WE ALSO LEARN FROM THE LGBT
COMMUNITY THEY ALSO FEEL THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED A VERY
SAFE HAVEN PER SE. THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO BE WHO THEY ARE ANOTHER
ANOTHER COMMUNITIES AS WELL AND
THAT'S SOMETHING WE DO WANT TO
EMBRACE AND SORT OF PROVIDE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO SAY THIS IS
FOR CALIFORNIA THIS IS FOR YOU
THIS IS FOR YOUR CHILDREN FOR
THE CALIFORNIANS AND TO SAY
THAT WE ARE DIFFERENT AND THAT
WE ALSO WANT TO SORT OF. YOU
KNOW WE WANNA RESOURCES WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE RESOURCES
ARE YOU KNOW PROVIDED TO
CALIFORNIA ON NOT ONLY IN THE
RESOURCE LEVEL BUT WE'RE ALSO
SHOULD ONE NEED TO EDUCATE
FOLKS BECAUSE OTHER PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FEDERALLY
FUNDED OR STATE ALSO USE CENSUS
DATA TO INFORM THE PROGRAM MEET
AND ALLOCATION AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO THERE'S A LOT
EDUCATION THAT WERE WANTING TO
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WERE
EXPLORING. DURING THIS PHASE.
NOT TO SAID SO YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN AT THIS FOR CASH TWO
YEARS. AND IT'S BEEN RIGHT UP
FRONT AND WE STILL I STILLHAVE
TO CONTINUE TO ALWAYS SEPARATE
BECAUSE WE SHOULD DO TRY TO
INVITE OUR SENSES PARTNERS TO
THESE MEETINGS. THROUGH ALL THE
CONVENES WE DID THE TWENTY FOUR
LAST YEAR WAS ALWAYS THEY WERE
THERE BUT IT IS VERY CLEAR
WE'RE FROM THE STATE THIS IS
WHY WE'RE DOING IT. THEY'RE IN
CHARGE OF THE YOU KNOW THE
ACTUAL OPERATIONS AND I THINK
I'VE BEEN VERY VOCAL ABOUT THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LEAVE THE
FATE OF OUR STATE IN THE HANDS
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
I THINK THAT A LOT OF OUR
PARTNERS THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH RIGHT NOW THEY'RE ON BOARD
WITH THAT BUT WEEK AS WE
CONTINUE TO DO THIS EDUCATION
MOTIVATION WE CONTINUE THAT
MESSAGE. OF LIKE. YES IT'S A
FEDERAL OPERATION AND THE
REASON WHY CALIFORNIA UNLIKE
MANY OTHER STATES IS REALLY
STEPPING UP TO A VERY HIGH TUNE
IS BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITIES. ARE
AT RISK OF ARMIES HAVE A LOT TO
LOSE AND THE PEOPLE ARE
FAMILIAR THE FACT THAT WE ARE
HAVEN AND THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA THE CALLS
ALL KINDS OF YOU KNOW. CALL ME
FOR YEAH THERE'S A LOT OF THE
OTHER A. B. C. AND D. SEES THAT
FOR ANYTHING BUT CALIFORNIA. SO
I THINK PEOPLE ARE ACUTELY
AWARE OF THAT AND OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND THROUGH THE CAN MEANS
THAT WE'RE DOING AND THROW
PARTNERS WE CONTINUE TO
DIFFERENTIATE. EVEN THOUGH THE
US CENSUS BUREAU TIRING
PARTNERSHIP SPECIALS ON THE
GROUND. YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE SAY
YOUR WHAT THE US CENSUS BUREAU
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY TO
ORGANIZE. AND THEY'RE GOING TO
TELL YOU WHAT. IT FROM THE
QUARTER DC. IT'S GOING TO BE
YOU KNOW. VERY YOU KNOW COHEN
AND WE'RE GONNA TELL YOU WHAT
WE NEED TO DO FOR THE COMMUNITY
RIGHT NOW. THANK I'M FOR THAT
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS YOU KNOW
NOT EVERYONE IS TRUSTING WHAT'S
COMING OUT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO IF WE WANTED.
GET WHAT'S DUE TO US RIGHT.
THOSE I ALSO HOPE I KNOW DOCTOR
PAN IS MAYBE HOPING THAT HE
WILL BE IN ONE OF THE NOVELLAS
AND SO HE OFFERED. THAT. BUT
AND THAT'S GREAT AND YOU HAVE
YOUR WALK ON. BUT AS WERE SORT
OF THINKING ABOUT INNOVATIVE
WAYS HOPEFULLY WERE ALSO I'LL
HOPEFULLY WE'RE ALSO. HOPEFULLY
I KNOW HOPEFULLY WERE ALSO
THINKING ABOUT OTHER YOU KNOW
INFLUENCERS EVERYTHING FROM
LIKE HOW PEOPLE GET AROUND IF
IT'S AN UBER LAUGHTER OTHER
THESE OTHER MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION AND SORT OF
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THOSE GROUPS TO. SOME OF THE
MORE AND I HAD TO KIND OF. BE A
COMMERCIAL FOR ANYONE BUT EVEN
SOME OF THE BRANDS THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA LIKE
SUPREME AND SOME OF THESE
THINGS THAT HELP YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE YOU KNOW TO KIND OF CONNECT
WITH THEM THOSE KINDS OF
CULTURAL INFLUENCERS. ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT OF THOSE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY SO I'M JUST HOPING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL
OPPORTUNITIES AND THANK YOU FOR
TALKING ABOUT THE ADA COMMUNITY
HOPEFULLY WERE REACHING OUT TO
WEST SIDE REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
REGIONAL CENTER SORRY THAT'S IN
MY DISTRICT. BUT WORKING WITH
THEM AND OTHER PARTNERS TO GET
THE WORD OUT BUT MY SECOND.
QUESTION WAS. AND I THANK YOU
FOR SAYING THE TAKE AWAY WORD
IS NIMBLE. AND IT'S EVIDENT
THAT YOU ALL. ARE YOU YOU KNOW.
ACTIVELY USING THAT WORD AN
INTENTION MY QUESTION IS. AND
MY HOPE IS THAT THE STATE IS
ALSO GOING TO BE NIMBLE BECAUSE
IT'S ONE THING. IF YOU ALL HAVE
YOUR ACT TOGETHER AND YOU'RE
BEING RESPONSIVE AND REFLEXIVE
AND YOU'RE DEALING WITH
WHATEVER KIND OF HOSTILE FAKE
NEWS IS COMING FROM OTHER
PLACES. BUT IT'S ANOTHER THING
IF YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE IN THE
GAME THAT'S BEING NIMBLE AND
THEN THE STATE IS NOT SO CAN
YOU SORT OF TALK ABOUT. THE
NEED ON THAT END AND HOW WE CAN
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND IN OUR
WORK MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
BEING GOOD PARTNERS IN THIS
BECAUSE. RIGHT I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT IF I MAY FIRST OF
ALL OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW. I THINK
THAT THE LEVEL OF COOPERATION.
FROM THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
STRONG. IT TYPICALLY WITH THE
WITH AN ISSUE LIKE THIS YOU
DEAL WITH THE CONTRACTING
AGENCY IT'S VERY BUREAUCRATIC
HERE'S WHAT YOU SAID YOU WERE
GOING TO DO HERE'S WHAT WE
EXPECT THIS THESE ARE YOUR- THE
OBJECTIVES YOU MEET YOU NEED TO
MEET HERE YOUR DEADLINE SUBMIT
YOUR STUFF AND THAT'S AND MOVE
FORWARD ON THAT HAS NOT BEEN
THE CASE THIS HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY COOPERATIVE OF VERY
PRO ACTIVE. CAMPAIGN WHERE THE
STATE HAS BEEN CERTAINLY IN
TERMS OF OUR OWN INTERACTION
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY A
COOPERATIVE AND I THINK IT'S
REFLECTIVE OF THAT SAME SPIRIT
OF WANTING TO GET THIS DONE I
ALSO WOULD SAY A LOT OF THE
COMMUNITY GROUPS OF THAT HAVE
BEEN ALREADY ON THE GROUND YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LITTLE BIT WITH
SOME OF THEM I THINK THERE
THERE THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF.
UNEASINESS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
GET GOING AND I THINK THAT'S
VERY HEALTHY TENSION WHICH WE
LOOK WE NEED WE WANT TO HEAR
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S THINGS
THAT ALREADY GOING ON THAT
WE'RE GOING TO LEARN FROM YOU
KNOW THE ONE THING THAT YOU CAN
REST ASSURE ABOUT THIS CAMPAIGN
IS ISN'T THIS WILL NOT BE A TOP
DOWN. A CAMPAIGN THIS IN
OBVIOUSLY THERE WILL BE SOME
TOP DOWN BUT THERE WILL BE A
LOT OF BOTTOM UP AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S
IMPORTANT HERE AS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE KIND OF TEAM THAT IS
READY AND WILLING TO MAKE
CHANGES TO ADAPT TO THE
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
MIGHT THAT MIGHT COME UP. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME. BOB. 80% OF
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO. IS GONNA
BE YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO FOLLOW AT IN TRACK. THE
REST YOU HAVE TO CALL US INTO A
HEARING LIKE THIS SO THAT WE
CAN EXPLAIN TO YOU WHAT'S GOING
ON. BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS THAT I FEEL THAT THE YOU
HAVE A GREAT TEAM IN PLACE AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND CERTAINLY.
WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT GROUPS
THAT ARE WORKING SOME OF THE
FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED
ALREADY. I BELIEVE ARE
EXCEPTIONAL GROUPS AND WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WAR THE
BEST MESSENGERS. IT'LL THESE
GROUPS WILL TELL US WHO THE
BEST MESSENGERS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO BE.
AND WE'RE GONNA WORK WITH THEM
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT. YOU
KNOW WE RUN A STRONG CAMPAIGN.
ON THAT WE CAN LOOK BACK ON AND
BE PROUD OF. YEAH I WANTED TO
ANSWER AND- I AGREE WITH WHAT.
BY THE END HAS INDICATED AND- I
WANNA AND- ENHANCE THAT AND
THEN ANSWER YOUR- ONE OF. THE
SECOND QUESTION THAT YOU HAD.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DID
AND ACTUALLY WAS LIKE. MY FIRST
DAY AND THE JOB WAS DOING
CONTRACTS NEGOTIATION WITH
MERCURY AND THAT WAS REALLY TOP
OF. MINE AND WHEN I SAID WERE
FULLY EQUIPPED AT THAT WE WERE
FULLY AWARE THAT FOR THIS
CAMPAIGN. WE COULDN'T TREAT
YOU. TREAT IT LIKE A PUBLIC
HEALTH CAMPAIGN ALL SOCIAL
SERVICES AND I KNOW AND- KIND
OF SORT OF HIGHLIGHTED MY
PREVIOUS LIFE BUT- THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS CONTRACT.
AND THEIR ABILITIES AND SKILLS
SAID ALLOWED US TO DO THAT
BECAUSE WE KNEW WE DO. NEED IT
TO BE. A NEED TO BE NIMBLE AND
STRATEGIC. AND EFFECTIVE. SO
WE'RE NOT JUST ROLLING NOW BUT
JOKE COLLATERAL MATERIALS
WITHOUT DOING OUR HOMEWORK. AND
THAT'S WHY THIS PHASE AND
AUGUST. AS OUR DATA COLLECTION
PERIOD. AND WE'RE LAYING OUT A
LOT OF METRICS FOR YOU GUYS TO
FOLLOW AND- REVIEW. I KNOW THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS IMPORTANT FOR
A LOT OF YOU. THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THE REASON
WHY WE PICK MERCURY IS THEY HAD
THIS REALLY NICE. AND THEY WILL
DO THIS MICRO REGIONAL
APPROACH. THAT WILL FULLY
EQUIPPED EVERY REGION. AND THEY
WILL ALSO TAYLOR THOSE
MESSAGES. AND EACH REGION ARE
IN EACH COMMUNITY SO FOR
EXAMPLE A MESSAGE IN SAN DIEGO
WILL LOOK VERY DIFFERENT AND
HUMBLED. A MESSAGE IN CENTRAL
VALLEY WILL LOOK VERY DIFFERENT
THAN SALINAS ARE WATSONVILLE.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WERE VERY
MUCH MINDFUL AND ALSO. THAT
BURKE CREEK. CAN FULLY AND
EXECUTE IN A TIMELY MATTER. I'D
LIKE TO SHARE ONE. THING THAT
WAS VERY CLEAR AS WHEN WE
FIRST. WHY AM WENT THROUGH THE
RP PROCESS AND THEN WE WERE
AWARDED THE CONTRACT OUR FIRST
DELIVERABLE WITH OUR CALMS
PLAN. AND OUR REQUIREMENT WAS
ONE COMES PLAN. WE AND THE
STATE WORK TOGETHER TO SAY.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE WITH
THIS TYPE OF A PLAN SO IT WAS A
DEMONSTRATION OF THE TWO
ENTITIES WORKING TOGETHER TO BE
NIMBLE AND REACTIVE TO WHAT WE
NEED AND NOT JUST SAYING THIS
IS WHAT IT SAYS DO IT AND SO
YES WE CONTINUE TO WORK THAT
WAY TOGETHER AND IT'S GOING TO
MAKE IT SO THAT WE CAN BE. I
THINK TRULY HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
AND MEASURED AND. BE ABLE TO
REPORT BACK TO YOU REAL
TANGIBLE RESULTS. IF I CAN ALSO
NOT TO NOT TO GO ON FOREVER
BECAUSE I KNOW CENTER HERTZBERG
IS REALLY BUSY ANY AND HE NEEDS
TO GO SOMEWHERE. BOB THE.
SERVICE THE CHAIRMAN OF THE PIE
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT CALM AND
HE'S HE WANTED ME TO SAY THAT
THE A QUESTION OF WHEN THE
QUESTION WAS RAISED ABOUT MEDIA
BUYS I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
TRADITIONAL WAY OF DOING MEDIA
BITES CERTAINLY FOR FOLKS THAT
ARE YOU KNOW WHETHER IN THE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AGENCIES YOU
KNOW EVEN POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS
YOU KNOW YOU BUY THAT YOU BUY
THOSE AHEAD OF TIME AND YOU PAY
FOR. IT THE EARLIER YOU BY YOUR
MEDIA AS YOU KNOW BETTER RATE
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE CLOSER
TO THE ELECTION THE MORE YOU'RE
GOING TO PAY WE WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCE AT AND ONE AND ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER WHAT WE'RE ALL
OF OUR PARTNERS AS THEY WERE
PART OF OUR ACT ACTUALLY THEY
WERE PART OF OUR PROCESS AND
IT'S PART OF THAT THEY HAD TO
SIGN AN AGREEMENT WITH US THAT.
THEY COULD SIGN WITH ANYBODY
ELSE INCIDENTLY. AS WELL. BUT
PART OF OUR AGREEMENT WITH THEM
IS THAT BOB WE'RE GONNA GET THE
BEST BANG FOR THE BUCK. ON
EVERY DOLLAR THAT IS SPENT ON
THE AIRWAVES OUR WEATHER'S
RADIO TV ARE DIGITAL MEDIA A
BUYS YOU KNOW SOCIAL MEDIA
EXCEPT FOR. AND THEY'RE ALSO AS
OUR PARTNERS ARE GOING TO DO
MORE CONTENT SO YOU MENTION
TELENOVELAS YOU KNOW WHEN WE
WHEN WE HAVE MERCURY DID THE
CAMPAIGN WITH THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT OF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DOMINANT. ONE OF THINGS WE DID
WITH UNIVISION IN THAT
PARTNERSHIP IS THEY HAD TO
EMBED EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT AND EVERY ONE OF THEIR
PROBE ALL THE PROGRAMMING WHERE
THEY STILL HAD INFLUENCE SO IF
THEY WERE. YOU OF IT BECAUSE
SOME OF THE STUFF IS DONE YOU
KNOW YEAR HAD A TIME OR TWO BUT
AND ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT
PLATFORMS GOING UP. TO
UNIVISION WHAT WAS ON THE RADIO
OR WHETHER WAS BEEN. THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IN AND
MESSAGING AT THE WAY WE WANTED
THAT TO BE MESSAGE. I THINK ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY WE WERE SO
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS BED QUITE
FRANKLY NOT TO BE BOLD BUT TO
SAY THAT WE WENT INTO THIS.
WITH MEDIA PARTNERS. KNOWING
THAT WE SAID TO THE MEDIA
PARTNERSNUMBER ONE YOU'RE
GOING TO GIVE US A HUGE DEAL
HUGE BREAK ON THE COST. AND
NUMBER TWO YOU'RE GONNA SPEND A
LOT OF YOUR OWN MONEY PROMOTING
THE CENSUS BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU
CAN DO SOME OF THIS ALREADY.
AROUND THE FRINGES BUT WE WANT
YOU TO GO DEEPER AND SO IT ALL
OF IN ALL OF THESE AREAS IN THE
STATE PARTICULARLY AND WHAT IN
THE MEDIA MARKET IS CONSIDERED.
SECONDARY MARKET NOT SECONDARY
OBVIOUSLY EVERYTHING'S. PRIMARY
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO BUT WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT CENTRAL
VALLEY YOU KNOW THE RIVERSIDE
SAMBAR DINO AREA IMPERIAL
VALLEY ETCETERA. IN THOSE
MARKETS. BOB WE'VE GOT BOB
MEDIA PARTNERS THAT ARE GOING
TO ROLL UP THEIR SLEEVES AND GO
TO WORK EVEN WHILE THEY WERE
WHILE WE'RE NOT PAYING THEM. SO
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
THAT THAT THAT THAT YOU WANT.
AND THAT AND THAT THAT'S PART
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING. THANK YOU.
WELL THE THANK YOU AND THAT
BEFORE I RECOGNIZE THAT ARE
THERE ALSO I MEAN IF TO GO BUT
I WOULDN'T WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU OF THIS CAT AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP OF
FORTUNATELY FOR YOU ALL OF US
HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH MEDIA IN
ELECTIONS IN COMMUNICATION SO
WHERE ALL EXPERTS AND WE'RE
PERFECTLY PREPARED AN ANXIOUS
TO SECOND GUESS YOU THROUGHOUT
THE COURSE OF THE CAMPAIGN AND
I KNOW YOU'LL COME BACK WITH
WITH EVIDENCE BASED
COMMUNICATION STRATEGIES SO YOU
CAN DEMONSTRATE US. THE MOST
EFFICACIOUS WAY TO COMMUNICATE
THESE MESSAGES AND THEN LASTLY
TO APPOINTMENT EARLIER IT IF BY
THE WAY IF I DON'T GET ANY
ADVERTISEMENT ADVERTISING
DIRECTOR ME YOU DON'T SHOW UP
ON MY SOCIAL MEDIA THAT THEY DO
THAT TRAINING I'LL BE PERFECTLY
CONTENT FACT I'LL FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE DOING YOUR JOB BECAUSE
OF LEGISLATORS. OR IN A HARD TO
COUNT CATEGORY WORLD HOST.
THANK THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
ELEMENT TURN OVER TO CHEER
BERMAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
WHAT'S MOST IMPRESSIVE ABOUT
WHAT YOUR YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION. WITH THE THIS
WE'VE BEEN WE'VE GONE THROUGH
NUMEROUS HEARINGS AND MEETINGS
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE FEEL
LIKE IT'S BEING INCORPORATED SO
YOU WERE LISTENING. NOT JUST TO
US BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY TO ALL
THE- STAKEHOLDERS WHO CAME
THROUGH DAY AFTER DAY WITH WITH
THEIR IDEAS SO A COUPLE OF
AREAS OF THE HAVEN'T
SPECIFICALLY BEEN. ADDED OR OR
LISTED IS. FOR ME AND YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS THE LATINO COMMUNITY IS
NOT EXCLUSIVELY AND ONLY A LOT
AND IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. IN
FACT WHEN HE COMES TO CIVIC
PARTICIPATION THE FIRST SECOND
THIRD GENERATIONS ARE MANY
TIMES THE HARDER. PARTS OF OUR
ALL OF THE LATINO COMMUNITY TO
INVOLVED IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
AND THIS IS A FORM OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS. AND THIS MAY BE
TRUE FOR OTHER IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WHEN YOU GET INTO
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN HERE A
LONGER AND SEVERAL GENERATIONS
IS THE DIFFICULTY. IN REACHING
THEM IT'S NOT EXACTLY THE SAME
MESSAGE SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER THAT TODAY BUT I JUST.
YOU KNOW. I HOPE AND EXPECT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
APPROACH THAT INCORPORATES OR
MAYBE DISTINGUISHES THEM AS FAR
AS THE MESSAGE. I DON'T THINK
IT'S THE SAME MESSAGE. MAYBE
IT'S THE MEDIUM THE ACTUAL
MEDIA OF APPROACH BUT IT IS
REALLY DIFFERENT AND THAT WHAT
WE CALL AS THE CHICANO
COMMUNITY IS NOT THE SAME. AS
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY SORRY I
WANNA BRING THAT OUT I THINK
THEY ARE THE LARGEST. IN TERMS
OF NUMBERSIN PERCENTAGE THE
LARGEST OF THE LATINO COMMUNITY
NOT THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY SO
THAT'S WHEN THEY WANT TO BRING
TO YOUR ATTENTION A SECOND IS
WE PUSHED REALLY HARD IN OUR-
SUBCOMMITTEE ON. ON THE BUDGET
PUSHED REALLY HARD FOR SCHOOLS.
TO BE UP INCLUDED IN THIS WE
RAISE THE BUDGET A LITTLE BIT
MORE TO REACH THEM BUT THERE IS
NOT A SINGLE COMMUNITY IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. THAT DOESN'T HELP
THE SCHOOL. I DON'T CARE HOW
HARD YOU ARE TO COUNT. YOUR
KIDS GO TO A SCHOOL. AND IT
SEEMS TO ME THERE'S GOTTA BE A
WAY TO GET THAT INFRASTRUCTURE.
OF THAT WILL REACH THE PARENTS
INVOLVED IN THIS AND I KNOW IN
TERMS OF ORGAN IS ORGANIZING
AND REACHING OUT TO THEM BUT IS
THERE A WAY. OF THROUGH OUR-
BROADLY SPEAKING COMMUNICATIONS
STRATEGY THE GETS TO THEM IT
WOULD BE A REAL SHAME AND I
KNOW THEY'LL BE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT INVEST AND TRY
TO DO SOMETHING BUT THE TRUTH
IS I DON'T THINK WITH WHAT
THEIR PRIMARY MISSION IS WHICH
IS EDUCATION. I DON'T THINK
THEY'LL PUT THE ENERGY AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
IT SO I REALLY BELIEVE THAT.
AND THE OF COURSE YOUNG ADULTS.
WHERE WOULD SECRETARY BY THE A
HE'S REACHED OUT TO YOUNG
ADULTS THEY NOW CAN REGISTER TO
VOTE BEFORE THEY'RE EVEN
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE. THERE IS AN
ENORMOUS AND THERE IS I THINK A
AN ANXIOUSNESS ON THEIR PART TO
BE INVOLVED. THEY WANT TO BE
INVOLVED HOW DO WE TAP OF THAT
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S THROUGH.
THE ENTERTAINMENT MEDIA. SOME
SOME WAY THAT THIS THAT THEY
CAN BE INVOLVED IN THIS THE
INCARCERATED. I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THE. WHAT IT YOU KNOW THE
LEGALITIES I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
DO THAT BUT- WE ARE ALL TRYING
VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
BOTH INCARCERATED FORMALLY
INCARCERATED. BUT THE
INSTITUTIONS. OF THAT HAVE
INCARCERATED OUR COMMUNITIES IS
THERE A WAY OF INCLUDING THEM
WE WANT THEM TO FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE PART OF THE COMMITTEES
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY ARE
RELEASED THEY ARE NOT SEEN AS.
YOU KNOW NOT PART OR FROM
DIFFERENT OF SO THOSE ARE JUST
SOME AND THEN TO MORE IS THE- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE YOUR UP.
REALLY CONNECTEDNESS HERE
BETWEEN DETERS TEAM AND
EVERYONE THERE ON THE GROUND
AND YOURSELVES YOU TALK ABOUT
BEING NIMBLE. AND I DON'T NEED
TO HEAR ALL THE DETAILS BUT IT
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT COULD GET
FROM MESSI. OF THE COORDINATION
WITH THE ORGANIZERS YOU TALKED
ABOUT YOURSELVES DIRECTLY BEING
THERE ON THE GROUND I THINK
THAT'S GREAT IF YOU DON'T FEEL
TOUCH YEAR. YOU KNOW SMELL
WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE GROUND
IT'S- YOU WILL BE DISCONNECTED.
BUT ALSO FEAR FOR. SO MUCH SO
THAT WHO'S IN CHARGE HERE. SO
JUST ONE SORT OF CAUTION AND
FINALLY NOT FINALLY OF THE
TRAININGS AND LEARNING SESSIONS
ANA I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU WILL
FIT IN ON DOING TRAININGS ON
THE GROUND ON THE MESSAGE AND
AS WELL AS LEARN FROM THOSE
TRAINING SESSIONS. AND FINALLY
FINALLY. I KNOW YOU YOU'VE
MENTIONED LEGISLATORS AS WELL
AS EVERYBODY SHOULD BE DOING WE
SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN ALL THIS
BUT I WOULD LIKE IF YOU CAN
PROVIDE AN ACTUAL PROGRAM FOR
US WITH THE TIME FRAME AS TO
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING. NOT
JUST LIKE OKAY ASSEMBLYMAN
BERMAN YOU HE'S GOING TO GO OFF
AND DO HIS THINGS CENTER POUNDS
GONNA DO HIS THING CAN WE BE
PUT ON A. TIME FRAME IN THIS
SORT OF. PROGRAM YOU KNOW CARRY
IT OUT SO WE FEEL LIKE WE'RE
REALLY CONTRIBUTING AND NOT
JUST COMING OUT OF. NUMBER
THANK YOU. I HAVE TO ANSWER A
LITTLE RIGHT NOW BUT. GAS ONE.
YEAH WELL ANSWER A COUPLE OF
THEM BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT COUPLE OF THEM FOR
THE LET THE NOW WE AGREE WITH
YOU WERE NOT OUT ALL ONE SIZE
DOES NOT FIT ALL PARTICULAR
SECOND AND THIRD GENERATION AND
EVEN FOURTH GENERATION EVEN THE
WAY WE SPEAK. CHICANOS AND EVEN
RECENT SECOND GENERATION THE
SPANGLISH LANGUAGE HAS BEEN
MORE OF US SOCIALIZED WAY OF US
COMMUNICATING. TEXTING LANGUAGE
IS THE WAY THAT WE COMMUNICATE
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE NOTES
ARE. REALLY HIGH CONSUMERS OF
VARIOUS MARKET SO WE ARE
EXPLORING ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
IDEAS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
MEETING PEOPLE WHERE THEY'RE AT
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. I'M SORRY HAVE MY BACK
TO YOU AND BUT THIS IS WHAT
WERE WERE SORT OF EXPLORING
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CULTURE
CONGRUENCY THAT'S PART OF SORT
OF THE- ANALYZING AND THAT SORT
OF EXPLORING. IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT THE MESSAGE IS
THERE. WE TALK ABOUT ETHNIC
MEDIA IS NOT JUST AN LANGUAGE
WERE ALSO SEEN THAT ENGLISH
MEDIA. OR JUST TRADITIONAL
MEDIA IS WORD THEY'RE REACHING
LET THE NELSON PARTICULARLY SO
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WERE
WERE LOOKING AT. SO ETHNIC
MEDIA IS NOT JUST AN LANGUAGE
BUT ALSO THINKING ABOUT NOT
JUST FOR LATINOS BUT ALSO ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS NATIVE
AMERICANS. TO ENSURE THAT THAT
MESSAGE GETS TO THEM AND A VERY
COOL TREE CONGRUENT WAY WHETHER
IF THEIR. SECOND THIRD OR
FOURTH GENERATION. ON. IN ON
SCHOOLS I HAVE THIS IS WHERE
WERE LEANING INTO THE US CENSUS
AT AS WE KICK OFF THE CAMPAIGN
THEY ARE GOING INTO. THE TOP
TEN COUNTIES ACROSS THE NATION
AND DOING A BIG SCHOOL PROGRAM
AND I LA COUNTY IS ACTUALLY.
GOING TO BE ONE OF THINGY
COUNTIES THAT THE US CENSUS IS
REALLY DIVING INTO THEIR IN
DURING A PROGRAM. SO WE WERE
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN INTEGRATE
AND OTHER COMMUNITIES OUTSIDE
LA COUNTYSINCE THEY WOULD BE
WORKING WITH THE US CENSUS. TO
HELP DOUBLE DOWN ON THAT IN
OTHER COMMUNITIES SO WE TO
AGREE THAT SCHOOLS ARE
CRITICAL. AND WITH YOUNG ADULTS
WE THINK THAT THAT'S- I'M
CAROLYN MENTIONED THE MULTI
CULTURAL. I THINK IT'S SUPER
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND AND I
THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND THIS
BUT WE WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT. EVEN GETTING AN
CONNECTING TO. OUR MODELING
GOAL FAMILIES IS HAVING THE
CONNECTION WITH EITHER OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS OR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT ACTUALLY SPEAK
SPANISH AT SPEAKING ENGLISH.
AND SO WE WILL HAVE A ENGLISH
COMPONENTS SPECIALLY WITH YOUNG
ADULTS AND COLLEGE H. M. S.
STUDENTS. I'M AT ITS JUST
BECAUSE THAT COMMUNITY REALLY
NEEDS TO HAVE AN EMPHASIS SO
THAT THEY CAN BE COUNTED ON
BECAUSE THEY ARE OFTEN
FORGOTTEN BECAUSE ARE NOT AT
HOME. AND ALSO THEY CAN HELP
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS BE COUNTED.
CENTER JUST WANNA JUST OVER FOR
SO I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
THE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS GOING TO
OUR- OF OUR SCHOOLS. OUTREACH
PROGRAM AS YOU KNOW WAY BACK IN
AUGUST TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WE GOT WE JUST GOT THAT THREE
MILLION. THE FIRST THING WE DID
WAS DEDICATE DOLLARS TO
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT WHERE
FOLKS HERE IN CALIFORNIA TOOK
THE CREEK THEM THAT WAS
DEVELOPED NATIONAL OF AND SAID
LET'S BRING TEACHERS IN FIFTH
EIGHTH ELEVEN TWELVE GREAT
BECAUSE THAT CIVICS. TO REALLY
INTEGRATE IN THAT AND SO WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF ROLLING THAT
OUT ACROSS THE STATE AND THERE
I NOTICED SOME SOME. FOLKS HERE
FROM FRESNO COUNTY THEY'RE ALSO
PART OF THAT PILOT BUT WE ARE
LOOKING TO BETTER COORDINATE
THOSE DOLLARS THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH THE DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS BUT ALSO AS SORT OF A
HIGHER LEVEL BECAUSE- FOR ME
HAVING THIS IS MY THIRD TIME.
THE THING THAT'S GOING TO
REALLY MAKE THE DIFFERENCE IS
ARE YOU. AND SO WE WERE HAVING
CONVERSATION ABOUT U. G. C.
USER GENERATED CONTENT MY
DAUGHTER SIXTEEN SHE MAKES
VIDEOS ALL THE TIME KNOWN ON
TOPICS FROM YOU KNOW THE
LIBERATORS IN CENTRAL AMERICA.
TO CENSUS THEY'RE DOING CRAP SO
DOING ALL THESE GREAT THINGS SO
WE'RE PLANNING ON DOING VIDEO
CONTENTS WITH GROUPS LIKE USING
GOVERNMENT AND OTHER GROUPS
THAT ARE OUT THERE. THAT ARE
ARE YOU DOING THAT THAT'S
REALLY KIND OF MARRYING UP THE
GROUND SORT OF ORGANIZATION
WITH THE SCHOOLS AND THE YOUTH
AND THEN ALSO MEDIA. BUT I
AGREE IT'S THAT THAT
COORDINATING OUR PARTNERS ARE
AMAZING AND THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING REALLY REALLY HARD AND
NOW IT'S REALLY ABOUT US SAYING
HEY. LET'S LET'S. IS. OBVIOUSLY
YOU WE'RE GOING TO BE NIMBLE
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN
SPECIALLY RIGHT NOW AS WE'RE
GATHERING INFORMATION BUT THERE
WILL BE A VERY NOT GONNA SIX
STRIX DRUCKER BUT IT CERTAINTY
THAT WILL BE A VERY OUTLINES
STRUCTURE THAT FOLKS WILL WILL
BE WORKING WITH UNDER BECAUSE
IT'S TOO BIG A CAMPAIGN FOR IT
NOT TO BE I MEAN IT'S THE SO
MANY DEAL FIFTY TWO COUNTIES.
THIRTY EIGHT OF FIFTY EIGHT OR
THE EIGHT COUNTIES ALL THE ACE
AND THE OWES DOESN'T SAY SEE
BILLS AND THEN ALL THE CBO
SYMBOLIC MEAN THIS IS. THIS IS
A MONUMENTAL OPERATION AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW THE. IN A-
DUE TO THE MARK THAT ONE SAYS
BUT THE WEB WILL START WILL
START CRACKING THAT WHIP BOB
SOON SOON ENOUGH AND I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW YOU'LL SEE THAT.
THINGS WILL BE MOVING THINGS
WILL BE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND OBVIOUSLY. YOU
KNOW EVERYBODY'S WORK HERE IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THIS LEADS
THIS BODY HERE. WHEN EVERYBODY
HAS BEEN ALSO SECRETARY PRETTY
I IN IN HIS OFFICE MS BEEN VERY
ENGAGED AND IN THIS WHOLE
PROCESS AND- YOU KNOW WE FEEL
REALLY GOOD ABOUT WHERE WE ARE.
FOR SURE. THANK YOU ACTUALLY I
DO HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION. SO I
THINK THERE'S SOME QUESTION
ABOUT INTERFACE WITH THE
COUNTIES SO CERTAINLY KNOW THAT
MERCURY HAS ALLOW LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH IN THE HARD
TO COMMUNITIES. IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE COUNTIES WHO ACTION OR
THE GAP WHO OF ALSO VERIFY THE
GAPS ON THEIR OWN WILMER TO BE
WORKING WITH THOSE COUNTIES WHO
OPT IN FOR FUNDS AS WELL AND
HOW AND ALSO FOR EXAMPLE WHOSE
MONEY IS GONNA GET USED. FOR
THAT THING SO SAMPLE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WHICH I REPRESENT THE
WORD ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND ARE EXPECTED TO HAVE
USED THEIR OWN OUT REACH FUNDS
FOR MEDIA OR WILL THAT BE IT'S
AT. THE CIRCLE K. IDENTIFIES
MEDIA OPPORTUNITY THAT. THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
MERCURY AND YOU CAN USE THE
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED FOR MEDIA
OUT REACH INSTEAD OF THEIR OWN
OUT REACH FUNDS. YEAH THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION SO RIGHT NOW
WE ARE REVIEWING THEIR
STRATEGIC PLANS THAT HAS THE
COMMUNICATION ACTIVITIES SO.
ACROSS THE STATE EVERYONE HAS
ALLOCATED COMMUNICATIONS FUNDS
DIFFERENTLY THERE'S NOT A SET
FORMULA. SO WE'RE REVIEWING
THAT AND WE WILL BE PROVIDING
TANGIBLE RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW
TO BEST USE OR DOLLARS OR EVEN
PROVIDE. SORT OF SUPPORT ON
THEIR ACTIVITIES TURN SURE IT'S
EFFECTIVE. SO IT'S NOT A SET
FORMULA BUT- MERCURY IS GOING
TO BE PROVIDING THAT LOCAL
SUPPORT. IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATIONS BUT ALSO MEDIA
COVERAGE I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
MERCURY. WITH THEIR PAID MEDIA
THEY WILL COVER EVERY SINGLE
REGION ACROSS THE STATE THAT IS
A GIVEN. WHAT WE NEED TO
COORDINATE AND WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE LOCALS IS WHEN THE
SCHEDULING AND IN TERMS OF
SATURATION WHAT THAT WILL LOOK
LIKE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. TO
ENSURE THERE'S NO DUPLICATION
OKAY SO JUST TO CLARIFY BECAUSE
THE THING I'M HERE SO. IN TERMS
OF SO WITH YOU WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
STRATEGIC PLANS WHOSE IS THERE
AN EXPECTATION OF THE COUNTIES
ARE SPENDING THEIR OWN OUT
REACH MONEY ON MEDIA ARE I MEAN
THAT I MEAN THIS COMES DOWN TO
LIKE YOU KNOW THE DATE. SO THEY
SAY OKAY LOOK YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A LARGE SEGMENT OF COUNTY YOU
KNOW WE'VE A LARGE P. I
COMMUNITY WEWILL WE IDENTIFY
THIS IS BEING A HARD COUNTY
AREA WE NEED. TO BE OUT REACH
FOR THAT ARE YOU GOING TO
PROVIDE THAT FOR THEM. IT STILL
IS NOT THE WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE
LIKE AN ACTUAL DOLLAR IF THAT'S
THE QUESTION ARE. OR A SPECIFIC
YOU KNOW. WE STILL AT IT
THERE'S SO EVERYBODY HAS BUDGET
THEIR COMMUNICATION DOLLARS
DIFFERENTLY WHERE MERCURY IS
GONNA SUPPORT IS THE COMPLETE
BY ACROSS THE STATE SO THERE
MIGHT THERE THEY WORLD BE FOR
EXAMPLE I CAN PICK YOLO COUNTY
BECAUSE WE JUST REVIEWED THEIR
PLAN. THEY'RE PLANNING TO DO A
MEDIA BY AND THEY'RE TALKING TO
UNIVISION AND TELEMUNDO WE
COORDINATED THEIR BY OR THEIR
DOLLARS AND THEY'RE BUDGET WITH
THE STATE WHAT THE STATE
POTENTIALLY COULD DO AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT EVERY SINGLE SORT OF
FUNDING PARTNER. IN THE SAME
FASHION SO EVERYBODY LOOKS
REALLY DIFFERENCE OF SACRAMENTO
ELSE BUDGET LOOKS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN YELLOW AND
VEHICLES IT'S GOING TO LOOK
DIFFERENT SO MARK PRES. I THANK
AT THAT YOU KNOW I GET THAT I
GUESS WHAT I'M NOT CLEAR ABOUT
IS THAT BECAUSE YOU SAID WELL
WE'RE DOING STUFF ACROSS STATE
YES. BUT I MEAN NOT EVERYTHING
IS LIKE IT'S NOT LIKE YOU JUST
RUNNING ADS ACROSS THE STATE
YOU'RE DOING SPECIFIC THINGS IN
SPECIFIC AREAS. RIGHT THAT'S
AND THEN WILL PART AT CETERA.
SO WILL. SO HOW SO WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT TARGETED MEDIA
ACTIVITY. YEAH WE COUNTIES HAVE
THIS FIJI PLANS YOU'RE RIGHT
EVERYONE'S DIFFERENCES THAT
COUNTIES ARE DIFFERENT AND OF
THE COUNTY IDENTIFIES WORLD
THERE'S AN AREA WE'D LIKE TO DO
MEDIA. WHO PAYS FOR IT IS THAT
THE COUNTY IT'S HAS TO PAY FOR
IT IF THE THEY CALL I ARE ARE
DO YOU WORK WITH THEM LIKE WELL
ACTUALLY THAT'S A MEDIA BY SO
THAT SHOULD THAT'S ACTUALLY
PART OF. YOU KNOW WHAT SHOULD
BE YELL COMING OUT THE MERCURY
SIDE OF THINGS SO A BLACK AND
WHITE ANSWER IS IF THE COUNTY
WANTS TO RUN ANY PI. CAMPAIGN
AND WE ARE COORDINATING WITH
THEM. IT WOULD BE THEIR FUNDING
IF WE ARE WORKING ON A PROJECT
AND WE'RE COORDINATING WITH
THEM AND IT'S SOMETHING WE
AGREED TO COLLABORATE ON AND WE
HELP FIND ADDITIONAL FUNDS
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
IN THAT IT WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THEM. WE DON'T
WANT TO SAY LIKE WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO HELP A COUNTY OR A
REGION WITH A PARTICULAR
MESSAGE BECAUSE IT MAY BE
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO AS PART OF OUR PLAN AND IT
THEN COMPLIMENTS THEIR PLAN.
BUT IF THEY HAVE A PLAN TO GO
AFTER THAT WE WILL WORK WITH
THEM TO HELP THEM ON THAT
STRATEGIC COORDINATION WITH OUR
PLAN BUT IT'S THEIR DOLLARS.
OKAY I THINK WE NEED TO WORK
THAT OUT BUT MORE. SO YEAH I
MEAN IT IS THE FIRST OF ALL I
DON'T EXPECT YOU JUST LIKE I
WANNA PLAN HE'S GOT A CHECK FOR
IT OR DO THE BUYER WHATEVER
ELSE BUT- I. YOU KNOW I EIGHT.
I THINK THAT THE OUT REACH
MONEY FOR THE COUNTIES I MEAN
WE'LL TALK THAT'S A SECOND OKAY
I JUST GO PICK ON BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT IT. MEANS WE'RE
GONNA PAY NEED MOST AFTER THE
GROUND AND BUT THEY BUT DOES
THAT YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE TO
COORDINATE BETWEEN GROUND AND-
AIR. TO AIR WHATEVER ELSE YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S- AND SO I'M
HOPING THAT AS YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH THE PLANS HAVING
CONVERSATIONS OF THE COUNTIES
THERE IS. A YOU KNOW THERE'S A
DISCUSSION ABOUT. BECAUSE YOU
ARE THEM YOU KNOW. YOU'VE BEEN
CONTRACTED TO DO THE MEDIA WE
BUDGETED FOR MEDIA. WE NEED. SO
GET OUT YOUR TO YOUR TO COURT
YOU'RE YOU'RE TO COORDINATOR
FOR THAT DIDN'T BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WELL THAT
MEANS ALL THE MEDIA ALL THE
MEDIA MONEY CAN ONLY GO FOR
LIKE THIS LARGER THING IT THEN
THE CAN'T MISS NOT BEING HELP
BEING USED TO HELP OUT AND
LOCAL OUT REACH RIGHT AB
PARTICULARLY WITH COUNTIES ARE
OTHERS SO. I JUST WANNA BE SURE
WERE. YOU KNOW WE AT THE DATA
THIS IS A PARTNERSHIP THIS IS
NOT LIKE WHAT WE HAVE OUR MEDIA
PLAN RIGHT YOU AND YOUR ON YOUR
OWN THAT IF YOU WANT TO ANY
MEDIA THAT WE DIDN'T DECIDE TO
READY BEFORE WE EVEN TALK TO
YOU. THEN YOU HAVE TO SCRAPE
THE MONEY TOGETHER FOR SENATOR
PAN ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THE
ANSWER IS TRICKY IS BECAUSE
THERE'S GAP ANALYSIS UNDER WAY.
RIGHT NOW RIGHT BOTH BY US BUT
ALSO AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND
NOT I WITH A BORROWER TURN TO
SEIZE LAST WEEK WE CAN TURN
THIS GAPS AND OPPORTUNITIES SO
IT'S REALLY THAT ANALYSIS THAT
WE WANT TO ENSURE INFORMS US
YET NEITHER ARE SENT. YEAH BUT
THERE ARE SOME INSTANCES IN
WHICH- ANY GIVEN COUNTY. YOU
RECEIVE DOLLARS OF PART OF
THOSE DOLLARS EVER DOING ALSO
THERE WERE ALSO DUDE MEDIA SO.
THINK OF IT AS THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN PLAN. MAN THERE'S DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF THE PLAN WHICH
SHOULD BE LAID OUT ALREADY IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO
WE'RE GONNA SAYS THAT PLAN.
THEY WILL LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN TERMS OF THE STATE
MEET. THE STATE WIDE MEDIA. IF
THERE'S GAPS IN THAT PLAN. THAT
THERE AREN'T ADDRESSING ALL THE
NEEDS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE GONNA COME IN AND WE'RE
GONNA FORTIFY THAT. WITH WITH
WITH MORE MEDIA BUYS INTO THOSE
AREAS WE'RE NOT GONNA WRITE
THEM A CHECK SAY HEY HERE'SA
CHECK TO GO THE- BUT WE ARE
GOING TO REINFORCE THE WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WITH THAT THAT
THOSE FUNDS ARE ARE ARE SPENT
EQUITABLY. OKAY WELL I JUST
THINK THAT YOUNG. PERHAPS THE
ON THEIR NEED. SOME
CLARIFICATION AND DISCUSSION
ABOUT SO THAT YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
YOU ARE REVIEWING THE COUNTY
PLANTS AND SO IN THAT IT IN
THAT REVIEW IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS EXACTLY HOW WE
SURE WE YOU KNOW EXECUTE ON D.
DELTA PROBABLY MEDIA SUPPORT
FOR THAT THAT THE GROUND
EFFORTS ARE HAPPENING I KNOW
YOU'RE WORKING AGAIN YOU WORK A
LOT TO ME PARTNERS AND SO FORTH
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE. I THINK
THERE'S A THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND WE HAD SOME DISCUSSION THIS
LAST HEARING I THINK THERE WERE
SOME BAKERY ABOUT EXACTLY. KNOW
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT AND
SO FORTH AND ALSO WHEN WE WHEN
WE BUDGETED FOR MEDIA. WE
WEREN'T SAYING THAT WELL NOW
THAT YOU HAVE TO BUY ADDITIONAL
MEDIA ON YOUR OWN AND IT'S NOW
ALL BEEN CORDONED OFF SO. OKAY
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH I AM CONFIDENT THIS WILL
BE OUR LAST CONVERSATION AND I
KNOW THAT I THINK THERE'S SOME
PLANS COMING FROM MERCURY SOON
HAVING SOME REPORTS COMING FROM
THE STATE SOON ON ON DIFFERENT
ITEMS SO LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THOSE LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING FOLLOW CONVERSATIONS IS
YOU ALL YOU KNOW KIND OF.
FINALIZE THE PLANS A LITTLE
MORE. WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE NIMBLE AND THERE
IS NO REAL FINALIZING BUT BUT
GET A LITTLE MORE. KIND OF
FLESHED OUT ON SOME OF THESE
PLANS AND IDEAS AND THANK YOU
FOR. US DANCING ALL THE
QUESTIONS TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA APPOINTED UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE'RE GONNA
LIMIT COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE PER
PERSON BUT I ALSO WANT TO
REALLY ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN COMMENT IF YOU
WANT TO GET DEEPER THAN THAN
WHAT ONE MINUTE WILL. ALLOW BUT
FEEL FREE TO. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING AND THEN MAKE YOUR
COMMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS
AND MEMBER SUSAN REYES HERE
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. ALSO KNOWN AS
THE A CC YOU. ARE WE ARE THE
UNIFIED VOICE FOR THE EIGHTY
FOUR INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE COMPLETE COUNT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I WANNA THANK
CARLOS BELTRAN WHO'S HERE TODAY
AND ALSO MEAN MIGNON POLL ART
EDUCATION OUT REACH. MANAGER
FOR THE CUT CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
COUNT CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY
OFFICE FOR REACHING OUT TO A CC
YOU. EARLY ON IN WORKING WITH
OUR STAFF TO CONNECT WITH THE
NUMBER OF MEMBERS THE TUITIONS
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
PARTICIPATING IN THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION FOCUSED PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONALLY AACC
YOU RECEIVED GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
LETTER TO A CC YOU EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR ASKING OUR
INSTITUTIONS TO COMMIT TO THE
COLLECTIVE STAY OR A STATEWIDE
EFFORT TO GET EVERYONE COUNTED.
AND I'LL MENTION A FEW OF THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
EXPRESSED INTEREST AT OR HAVE
ALREADY STARTED TO ENGAGE IN
CENSUS ACTIVITIES THE CLAREMONT
CONSORTIUM THE CHICANO LATINO
STUDENT AFFAIRS OFFICE THERE.
THAT SERVES THE SEVEN CLAREMONT
COLLEGES. CALIFORNIA LUTHERAN
UNIVERSITY AND THOUSAND OAKS
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
DOMINICAN UNIVERSITY IN SAN
RAFAEL CAN CORDY UNIVERSITY AND
IRVINE LOYOLA MARYMOUNT
UNIVERSITY IN LOS ANGELES AND
AS YOU WRAP UP. AND WITH THAT
I'LL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THAT
AHCC USE STANDS READY TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH
THE GOVERNOR. TO ENSURE THAT
ALL OUR STUDENTS AND ALL
FAMILIES ARE COUNTED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. HI HOUSE OF AN ENEMY
IS NOT TO KNOW WHAT CHILDREN
NOW CHILDREN NOW AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT RESEARCH AND OUT OF
STORES EACH AND DEDICATED TO.
ALL KIDS ISSUES THERE ARE
TWENTY SIX WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION TODAY AND THE IMPORT
DISCUSSION AROUND ENSURING THAT
THE STATE'S CRITICAL INVESTMENT.
IS AN ADEQUATE ONE TO ENSURE
AGREE COUNT AND ALSO WANTED TO
SAY THAT IN THE NEXT STEPS OF
THIS WORK WANTED TO ADVOCATE
FOR. TO ENSURE THAT WE ADVOCATE
AND WE AND WE ENGAGE FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN ZERO FIVE WHICH
ARE PART OF ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITY IN THE
LAST CENSUS IN TWENTY TEN OVER
TWO MILLION YOUNG CHILDREN WERE
MISSED NATIONALLY. SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THE PEOPLE CONSIDER YOUNG
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT ARE
LIVING IN LOW INCOME IN HIGH
POVERTY NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
LIVING COMPLEX FAMILY
SITUATIONS LIVING IN HOMES
WHERE ENGLISH IS NOT THE FIRST
LANGUAGE. AT THAT WE HOPE THAT
THE OUT REACH OUR SUPPORT
INSURING A ROBUST EFFORT. FOR
FAMILIES WITH YOUNG CHILDREN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS IT GOT
REALLY BAD I AM REPRESENTING
CENTER LEFT ME ADVOCATES
SERVICES FROM FRESNO. AND I
COME WITH SOME REPRESENTATIVES
WITH THE CBO SAID THE AREA WERE
PART OF THE- COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE OF FRESNO COUNTY.
LIVING IN CENTRAL VALLEY WE
KNOW MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS FIT
INTO MULTIPLE HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS. UNFORTUNATELY MANY
OF US A CBO THAT RECEIVE THE
STATEWIDE CONTRACTS. DO NOT
WORK IN THE REGION SO THEY DO
NOT KNOW THE OUR POPULATIONS
AND AS AN EXAMPLE ARE A CBO HAS
FOCUSED ITS EFFORTS ALMOST.
EARLY ON THE LATINO POPULATION
BUT LEAVING OUT OTHER
PUBLISHERS SUCH AS NATIVE
AMERICANS LGBT Q. AT THE EIGHTY
A COMMUNITY OF. RURAL
POPULATIONS ETCETERA SO WHAT WE
ASK IS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE CAM COMMITTEE HOLD
CONTRACTORS ACCOUNTABLE TO
REACH OUT TO ALL HARD TO COME
POPULATIONS. AS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY CANNOT AFFORD ANOTHER
UNDER ACCOUNT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO
MY NAME IS GABRIELLE RIVAS AND
I'M FROM FRESNO ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES COMMISSION.
PROCESS CHANGES COUPLED WITH A
LIMITED BUDGET FEAR AND SUED BY
THE POSSIBILITY OF US
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION AND NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR CENSUS WORKERS
AMONG OTHERS WILL EXACERBATE
THE UNDERCOUNT NERIO SUCH AS
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. WHEN THE
STATE'S REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS
BEGIN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PUT THEIR BEST
FOOT FORWARD IN PROPOSING THE
MOST EFFECTIVE OUTREACH MODEL.
AS TRUST ISN'T TRUSTED
MESSENGERS WERE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE THE UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIPS WE HAVE HOWEVER
OUR REGIONAL A CBO HAS NOT BEEN
TRANSPARENT AND SHOWING THEIR
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL. FOR
STRATEGIC PLAN IN ORDER TO VIEW
THEIR PROPOSAL ORGANIZATIONS
WERE TOLD TO CONDUCT A PUBLIC
RECORDS REQUEST. THIS LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY CREATES BARRIERS
FOR TRUSTED MESSENGERS AS THEY
DEVELOP OUT REACHED STRATEGIES
WITHOUT VISIBILITY IT IT IS
HARD TO PLAN AND CONTINUE OUT
REACH. OUR RESIDENTS AND GROUPS
WORKING ON CENSUS DESERVE TO
KNOW WHAT IS OUTLINED ON
STATEWIDE PLANS IN ORDER TO
AVOID DUPLICATION AND
COMPLEMENT WHAT IT'S COME.
ALTHOUGH SPECIFIC STATEWIDE
CONTRACTS WERE LATER DEVELOPED
TO CATER TO HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HAS YET TO SEE THESE FUNDS. THE
CENTRAL VALLEY COULD NOT AFFORD
AN UNDERCOUNT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M NAZARIAN JOHNSON
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
FRESNO ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
COMMISSION WE PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES AND SERVICES FOR
LOW INCOME. INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES AND FRESNO COUNTY.
OTHER TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS A
NEW METHODS WILL CREATE A
DISADVANTAGE FOR OUR LOW INCOME
IMMIGRANT AND RURAL RESIDENTS
MANY LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER AND WANT
TO CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE CENSUS
ART REACH BUT WITH LIMITED
FUNDING CAPACITY AND
TRANSPARENCY PLUS LACK OF
STATEWIDE SUPPORT WE STRUGGLE
TO CONTINUE AT THE SAME
CALIBER. AND THESE ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT I'M SPEAKING
OF ARE THE TRUSTED MESSENGERS
AND THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND
WE'VE BEEN HEARING IS SO
NECESSARY FOR THIS ACCOUNT TO
BE COMPLETE. IT WILL TAKE A
VERY DELIBERATE AND PERSONAL
TOUCH TO CONNECT WITH OUR HER
TO COUNT POPULATIONS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE ARE
REQUESTING FUNDS TO REACH THESE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN OUR LOCAL A CBO'S
PLANS. ARE THE CENTRAL VALLEY
CANNOT AFFORD ANOTHER UNDER
COUNT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M ERIK VAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
URBAN INSTITUTE. THE LEGACY OF
UNDER COUNTING AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THE SINCE THE
STATE'S BACK TO THE CENSUS
COUNT IN SEVENTEEN NINETY.
DURING THE WRITING OF THE US
CONSTITUTION IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN DELEGATES DEBATED
OVER THE NUMBER OF SEATS IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES. IN
SEVENTEEN NINETY A COMPROMISE
BETWEEN THE NORTHERN INSIDE THE
SEVEN OR STATES RESULTED IN A
DECISION FOR IN FLAMES AFRICANS
TO BE COUNTED AS THREE FIFTHS
OF A PERSON. FOR CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATION AND TAXATION WE
ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BLACK HOUSEHOLDS WITHIN OUR
REGION FACING A POSSIBLE UNDER
COUNT. AND LOSS IN FEDERAL
RESOURCES WE HELD OUR FIRST
REGIONAL MEETING WITH THE STATE
LAST WEEK WITH A HUNDRED AND
FORTY PEOPLE IN A ROOM AND NOT
ONE OF THE STAFF MEMBERS WAR OF
AFRICAN DYSPHORIA. NOT ONE OF
THE FIFTEEN PANELISTS WE HEARD
FROM DISCUSSED A STRATEGY TO
REACH BILL BLACK FAMILIES NOT
ONE OF THE NINE STATE WHY
CONTRACTORS PRISON. PRESENTED
DISCUSSED A WAY TO ENGAGE BLACK
FAMILIES IT'S ALARMING BECAUSE
WE'RE ON A PATH TO REPEAT
HISTORY FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN WERE HISTORICAL BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS WENT UNDER COUNT
IT BY SIXTY SIX. PERCENT AND
FRESNO COUNTY HAS THE FIFTH
LARGEST CONCENTRATION OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND IF IT'S
HAPPENING TO US WHAT ELSE IS IT
HAPPENING IN THE STATE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED WITH THE STATE WHY
PUBLIC OUTREACH CONTRACTOR
WHILE IT HAS BEEN IMPLIED THAT
THE STATE Y. CONTRACTOR IS NOT
EXPECTED TO INVEST IN LOCAL IN
ETHNIC MEDIA OUTLETS. ALTHOUGH
THESE ARE PLATFORMS THE BEST
SUITED TO CONVEY A SENSE THIS
MESSAGING RESIDENTS WITH. WHAT
MUCH RATHER HEAR THAT THEY NEED
TO COMPLETE A CENSUS FORM
THROUGH THEIR LOCAL TV RADIO
STATION OR NEWSPAPER RATHER
THAN A STATE WIDE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN PLEASE WRAP UP. MY
FINAL MINUTES. THE NEEDS. THE
NEED THERE NEEDS TO BE A
STRONGER. EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT
OUR SINCE THIS IS NOT
WEAPONIZED THE SILENCE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
UNDERSCORING AFRICAN AMERICANS
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
COULD HAVE REAL CONSEQUENCES.
BECAUSE AFRICAN AMEICAN
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
POVERTY AND FEDERAL PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO ALLEVIATE THE
IMPACT OF POVERTY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I JUST WANNA REMIND FOLKS
THAT. ARE WRITTEN TESTIMONY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
ACCEPTED INTO AUGUST THIRTIETH
DETAILS ARE ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE WEB PAGES FOR THE TO
SLOW THE- ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
SO I COMMITTEES THERE'S ALSO
INFORMATION AT THE BOTTOM. OF
THE HEARING AGENDA IS THAT I
THINK ARE IN THE BACK OF THE
ROOM ABOUT WHERE YOU CAN
SUBMIT. ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH I WANT TO
THANK MY CULTURES DOCTOR PAN.
CENTER NUMBER GOING TO TAKE OFF
THANK YOU FOR EVERYBODY FOR
STICKING OUT THE REST OF THE
YEAR. THANKS